>> he's getting
he's getting
he's literally a hostage right now.
No way. >> Did they just invent the wheel in Thailand or
like where you guys at right >> Oh, you're clearly a welltraveled
guy. How many countries have you been to, >> How many countries
are you banned from?
>> spent a million dollars and your girlfriend on a mattress
with no
Dude, it's so brutal. It's so brutal.
It's so brutal.
>> You're such a girl's girl. >> You're such a girl's
girl. I bet you really went up to her and you said to her, "Oh,
Kimmy, thank you. We can be friends." You're such a gal.
>> Where do we start here? Okay, it started with there
were some vibes that like earlier on there were some vibes that
uh maybe maybe Kimmy wasn't really invested in the event. Maybe
there was a fight. Maybe something was going on and Kimmy started
hanging out with Amaranth. So Kimmy and her friend decided to
go hang out with Amaranth. Okay. >> Mine's an ingground
one. >> Oh, nice. They're waiting. >> They weren't
really They weren't really scavenging or hunting.
>> Just hanging out with Amaranth instead. >> It's
here. >> I got a couple clips. Okay. >> Down the
street. >> They do some classic Amaranth content. There's
a Kimmy walking onto Nick's >> We're just ordering drinks.
I have to get my ID.
>> Now, I will say I was given these clips. I did not select
these clips. I was given these clips and I I haven't checked
them, so I'm not sure if they prove a point. Okay. I I say that
before I drag this one on because this is the next one. >> This
is the amaranth content. Okay, I was These clips were pasted
in the Discord. You can verify it for yourself. Go to the scavenger
hunt channel. Okay. But this is the content they were doing.
>> A notification for when the guy comes. >> No more
scavenger hunt. >> Oh yeah, the the tulies.
The true.
>> Is there any seeds in here? No, it was at the >> I
think it's short enough though. >> Okay, so this is this
is two days ago. This is two days ago. you. >> Okay, so
Kimmy and her friend, instead of continuing on with the scavenger
hunt, they're just chilling.
And where do we go from here?
Okay, I think I have a time stamp for this. We'll see if we have
a time stamp for >> We literally solved it just >> I
literally solved it in the >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. This
is out of order. This is out of order now. I'm just going to
check this one last clip and then I think we're on to the start
of the Lav Gunnar content. I actually don't know what this clip
is either.
This is just a random clip, dude. This is from their their fight
or whatever.
What is Nick? Sorry. That's a random clip. Random clip. Just
fun little time. I think we get like right into it. Okay, so
earlier in the day from two days ago, Lav and Gunnar, I thought
Lav and Gunnar were starting to form like a friendship with Ice
Boseidon. Okay, this was yesterday. I thought they were starting
to form a friendship cuz they were talking to Ice and they were
bantering back and forth. Okay. Uh, no. Omni, I have no idea
on that. >> What's up, you gay? >> All right, listen.
This shit's so [__] I want, since you're so smart,
to give me some suggestions on how to make it better, though.
>> Okay. Uh, make less convoluted clues. >> Your
clues. >> They're talking about the clues in the event.
Okay. >> I know that you like they're good clues. They're
good clues. >> They don't need to be as like the you there
are too many answers and the city's too big. Give a solid hint.
Now, keep in mind during this, Gunnar knows that he's like kind
of this guy's girlfriend and that probably I would imagine it
could get like a little tense. Now, I'm like going back in my
head and trying to like figure out
why was was Ice Pesidon like cold to Gooner before? I'm not sure.
Hello. Who's that? Who's that? >> Blessings, young one.
>> Who that? What's up? Covering
content. >> Resident black man in your stream. That is
who who knows. >> Yeah. Yeah. What's up? How's it going?
>> Uh
listen
uh I saw your tweet. Okay. I'm one of the five people who look
at your tweets to be able to look at what you're doing for the
day. Okay. I don't know if it's five people. I'm making it up.
And uh I I'm here because >> I think there's a chance Lab
might be miserable. And I think that's funny. So what's going
on? >> Yeah. I don't know. This might be like I don't know
if Lav will be miserable miserable. Okay. Um, Lav and Gunnar
are doing the scavenger hunt like everybody else does or everybody
else is. I don't know if you're familiar with the scavenger hunt.
Okay. It's like uh hunting around Austin for different.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, they're doing the scavenger hunt.
They're crushing it. Okay. They're like top three, top five pretty
consistently. And
they ended up kind of, I think, bickering here earlier yesterday,
I want to say.
Should be like earlier.
This would be It's probably two days ago on the 12th, probably.
They end up bickering with Ice. No, this would be No, this would
be Hold on. Same shirt. Same shirt. Yeah, this would be yesterday.
Actually, this is the VOD we're looking at.
Yeah. So, yesterday they end up bickering with Ice here. And
then a little bit later, they get in another fight with him and
Lav goes on to leak that Gunnar his girlfriend. And >> wait,
are they not are they not in a relationship or is he talking
about in the past? >> In the past. Like I think I think
Ice and Kimmy were on a break. I don't think Ice I don't think
Lav and Gunar were together. I think Ice and Kimmy were on a
break. But basically, Lav just mocks Ice because Ice has had
some, you know, he crashed out a couple weeks ago, about two
months ago, because his girlfriend wasn't him or something, right?
He was like, "She doesn't she doesn't me at all. She's like ruined
my confidence and all this." And
I think Lav probably knows that and was pressing some buttons
a little bit. Okay. Probably likely seems like >> I I thought
Gutter I I thought Gunnar cheated on her, bro. Damn. I thought
this was about to get spicy, bro. >> No, no, no. It's uh
It's Lav. It's Lav that's like kind of going hard on on ice in
this. Like it's Yeah, it's um >> Let's You know, that could
be funny. Lav can be funny sometimes. Okay, hold on one second.
I need to set up your avatar really quick. >> Oh, I got
I got delegated down to pleb tier. Is that what happened? And
then doesn't come through for a couple months and then he just
get down to >> normie tier. No, that's what happened. >> I
have to avatar cuz I'm on a different discord account and that's
how the avatar thing works is like if you're not on the right
Discord account then it's uh it's all
>> You would have thought of me. You would have set it
up before I came in here. That's all I'm saying. >> Can't
set it up without you in my my Discord. I can't even I can't
set it up for rent, >> bro. Just let me have this. Let
me have this. Let me be a victim. Let me be a victim, bro. Come
on. >> All right. You're a victim. I wasn't thinking about
you at all. >> Thanks. Yeah, you weren't. >> Yep.
There it is. Okay, so this is from earlier in the day. They I
think they just sniped back and forth a little bit. It's just
some context for why it sort of escalates. Okay, we had Oh, we
also have had apparently Sam Pepper's been referencing this in
the background like that, you know, Kimmy Brown and Ice Boseidon.
Um, every time they have drama, every time Kimmy and Ice decide
to have drama, Sam kind of implies that, oh, she [__]
around with on him and like she's not loyal and all of this [__]
right? Because what Ice crashed out about two months ago was
her being at a party with kicksters without him there.
Yeah. So anyway, we >> we could continue to everyone with
every clue. Make it go faster like no. >> And live is now
explaining to Ice how he could make the event better. So I if
he's like any other man on the internet, woman is telling him
how to improve something, he is about to rage the >> he
wants to be here for a month >> Oh, I have another idea.
Let the fight for the chest. >> I want to be here for a
month straight. >> Yeah, I know. Cuz you're making a bag.
You get paid by the hour. >> But also, and Ice, that makes
sense. But also, you have to realize that the people who you
foster your relationships with are your content. So the people
who are doing this event are who are giving you content. the
people who if you over so many of us so many times people are
going to stop doing your events then you have no money. >> Yeah.
Then it's just retire. Well, he'll still have money. He could
retire right >> Well, then then you don't have people who
are interesting or smart doing your events. Then you have like
people who are like
>> just start spamming chest so all the go for them and
you get your content and let the actual people that are solving
>> and get better hints and get better hints. Don't let
it go. Don't let it go 5 hours. So, I've heard this Kaimar, don't
don't spoil too much. We'll get to that. Okay. >> What
are you guys actually upset about here? Like, what are you agitated
about? >> Because the clues are [__]
Like, they you're artificially bottlenecking the people that
are actually >> And also, you're giving you're you gave
like zero, you're changing rules. You gave zero points for like
just getting lucky and finding an RFID from before. Like, he
didn't even do the clue and you decided to give him extra point.
That doesn't even make sense. Ice >> 5,000 point. That's
five first scans for going to an old RFID that they found the
other day >> that they were so stupid. >> Why do
you care so much? You're still ahead of him. What does it matter?
>> I know. And I've done nothing the last two days and
I'm still top five. >> We care because we care because
we care about the integrity of this scavenger
>> They care cuz they've been super hardcore tryharding
this and they don't like other people getting points. That's
just it. They've been like try hard. They were like top five
the whole time. They have been top five the whole time. >> If
it's anyone's game, >> who's number one? Tazo. Tazo's number
one by a mile. Tazo's crushing everybody. Yeah.
>> Change the rules. Why would we work hard to do it? We've
been off and we're still at four. >> Why would we work
hard? >> I haven't done except for just leech and scan
the last two days and I'm still >> You guys have been Yeah,
because you guys have been consistently doing well. So, you have
a lot of points. >> Yes, I know. So, why is zero who's
gotten what? Two per scans right behind me. Negative sense. Ah,
>> well, you think about the people under us who also works
harder.
>> What? 43. No, no, no. >> 43 RFIDs.
They had to scan 43.
>> there's like 50 or something.
>> Gunnar and Lav are in uh 39th place kind of, but they've
got 10,000 points. So, if you like scan up, you find the people
with 43 and 10,000 points, they'd be like number six right now.
If they if they just go scan all the RFIDs and catch up, they'd
be at like number six. But we'll see. We'll see. There's a reason
they might not finish the event. Okay. Don't want to spoil. Don't
want to >> Yeah, he does. >> Yes, he does. >> Yes,
he does. >> Zero is sitting here and he's solving [__]
on his own, which is impressive. >> First of all, that's
not even true. Every single every single person here has a Discord.
>> Everyone has Discord and AI. We're all on the same level
playing field except for Tazo because he has some like >> No,
I didn't get my money from ICE yet, Zezy. Okay, I'll get it.
I'll get it. Don't worry. >> He has an inside. >> I'll
get it because you're texting.
>> Well, you you No, I'm not. >> Tazo gate. Tazo
gate. >> You you said that you want me to give hints for
every clue because there's too many possibilities. That just
makes it
>> because you Yeah, because you don't realize that when
it's like it's not It makes it easier, but it also makes it doable.
Ice like >> Yeah. It needs to be like solvable so we can
like move forward. >> We don't want to have to drive 30
minutes there, 30 minutes there, 30 minutes there. Then >> these
[__] is getting paid for gas and he's just driving
around the city all [__] day getting the CO2 fumes
the greenhouse gases, bro. >> I would say the KCIP is probably
paying them. Eddie's paying them for the gas. Okay. Eddie's paying
them for the gas. >> Eddie's not doing carbon offsets,
>> Eddie Eddie gave big gave big money to Mr. Beast. I'm
not sure he can bankroll
>> The Mr. Beast collab is coming, >> dude. The Mr.
Beast collab. Yeah. No, it's right now. Uh oh, Mr. Beast online.
It was No, it's here. Mr. Beast collab, >> but who I I
don't particularly care. >> We had a We had a screenshot
from that earlier today. >> Mr. Beast. >> Oh, just
this. Oh, never mind. He He gone. He gone. He gone. Yeah, this
is Mr. Beast, Aiden Ross.
Let me find this picture really quickly. Stream stream. Stream
chat. And we've got this is at kick headquarters.
Thank you for the donation. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Uh,
goofy.
>> All right, we only have a little bit further to go in
this once ice starts going in on lav a little bit here. >> 12
hours each clue. No, that's not tent for you. >> Yeah,
but you guys solved 10 clues yesterday. So, >> yes, we
did. And yesterday was really >> Yes, that was my >> Yesterday
was extremely fun, but the day before we had to go to the hospital,
so we couldn't really participate. But like the first two days
of the >> What happens? What happens when we're on clue
50, right? Do you just want me to give hints and make clue 50
super easy? >> No. No. 50. It makes sense for the last
five to be difficult. >> Yes. The last five makes sense
to be extremely difficult. Yes. >> The problem is like
if Tazo is extremely smart, which I think he is, and he has a
good operation behind him, why is he not allowed to pull ahead
by two or three clues? Like that makes no sense at all. Like
Tazo is getting bottlenecked just like the rest of everybody
else. >> Also, another thing is that you put on >> You're
telling me that like Merk off the perk should be on the same
RFID as Tazo right now. Like that does not make lot
>> You give the clues way too early. >> You also
give
when somebody scans an RFID, everybody else seems to know exactly
where it is and they go to it. >> Yes, I get that. But
like stop bottlenecking people cuz if Tazo can bang out three
in a row and he doesn't leak the location then that's actually
like fun because everybody's like panicking and trying to catch
up then you can drop chest. >> Okay. Uh apparently I apparently
Ice does like yell at Lav at some point here but I'm not I'm
not seeing it. And honestly I just want to go to the actual drama
here. So they fight about this. Ice eventually tells Lav she's
or something and then it boils a little bit. Okay. I'm just going
to spoil for you guys. Ice calls Lav and I wonder if that didn't
roll around or rummage around in Lav's head a little bit. Okay.
Leading to like later that evening the the clip we're about to
go to now. The time stamp we're about to go to cuz there's quite
a bit going on in this next part. Okay. There's quite a bit going
on. >> Who the [__] is Gwen? >> Goon
Goonch. >> Oh, I can't read. It's so small. >> You
did like a You did like a KCIP. Not KCIP. You did like a kick
or keep with Goch, right? >> I'm not going to lie to you.
I did a kick or keep with a lot of people and I forgot who. >> Okay.
Well, I think you did. Yeah, >> I think I think I did.
I I think I did. >> Yeah. Yeah. So, that's that's him.
That's Lav's husband or boyfriend. I don't know. She's gone back
and forth in this. We're not sure. Yeah, we're really
>> Ice Poseidon. >> Nice event. >> Also, it's
up what you did to Shuy. Pick on someone your own size. >> One
coming up very soon that I know for a fact
you haven't found. Oh, your little chaos theory. Oh, man. The
chaos theory. >> I actually hit one too that I know for
a fact that you haven't found. It's in Kimmy's vagina. I know
>> that Kimmy bec's girlfriend. >> Damn. Jesus.
So, she just she just starts talking out of nowhere. Like, this
is the content. Unfortunately, this is this is just incredible
content. Honestly, it really >> Know for a fact you haven't
found it. >> It was hidden eight months ago.
I know. >> No.
Yeah, they're joking. They're joking about Yeah. Uh, so I don't
know if that's Goon saying he or eight months ago because I heard
2021 before this, but I meant to ask Lav, does that mean eight
months ago is when they cuz some people say it's 2021. Goar says
eight months ago.
Either way, I feel like they know what they're doing. I feel
like they know they're [__] with this guy, right?
You don't make these comments and not know that you're going
to piss this guy off, right? >> And like these are heavy
comments. substance. Thank you very much for the 13 months. Let's
go. Oh, it's not as bad. It's not as [__] >> Hold
on. Hold on.
>> Oh.
Oh, here the chat goes. So, we're losers. I'm not even losing,
dude. >> That's crazy that you know Ice is watching the
stream and you throw that
>> Oh my god. >> I mean, they're flagging for PvP.
It just is what it is, you know? >> They are flagging for
PvP. Okay, they they are flagging for PvP.
Can you ask uh Oh, can you ask why Lauren makes all the heart
comments on Twitter? I Dude, I don't know. What's the Lauren
daily? Is there is there something going on there? Just like
>> I don't know. I I
She was I think she was probably just [__] with like
people [__] with like DG or >> Okay, I got
you. Fair enough. >> I was when I was in first place. >> Yeah,
you just got a [__] sometimes. You just got a [__]
sometimes. You're not losing, but act like you're losing, which
is even worse.
>> I don't think we're acting like we're losing. We're
>> I've had I've had a sit down dinner for the last 4 days
with my beautiful wife. >> We've had more times in the
last 24 hours than you have in 6 months.
>> We have taken our time. I spent what he
>> What is this, man? What are we doing? >> Rean
Ruben donated
>> and semitism. >> Thank you for the donation, Reuben.
Reuben, thank you. Thank you.
>> Oh, yeah. He's >> We just celebrated birthday.
>> It is. We are having We're on vacation. >> It's
over. It's just over for you. >> Yep. And in the And in
the in the 20% chance that >> I'm a very busy man. I have
a lot of things going on that make me money and a lot of I have
a lot of work to do. I don't have to. You got more to do. >> And
what's it all for? >> This is your hard work. >> And
look at your kingdom. What's it all for, buddy? unmarried, childless,
>> you have to do your own life, >> dude. What's
happening?
No,
>> they're just gonna
>> look, I I was going into this. I don't like anybody
in this situation. I don't like Ice. I don't like Lab. I don't
like I I mean, I kind of don't really know much about Goodter.
I don't like any of these people, but God, if they don't got
me rooting for Ice right now, he's just taking a beating, bro.
Like, what is this? Defend yourself, man.
I think he was hoping that it would just pass and they weren't
going to say much. But uh >> yeah, that's what it sounded
like. He was just like he's like, "Yeah, you know, I'm a busy
guy. You know, I'm doing stuff. I'm working." And then Le's like,
"Nah, I'm I'mma get something out of this guy. I'm going to get
action." >> He does. Yeah. He deescalates and and she's
like, "Hey,
I said something to you. You want to you want to you want to
say something?" I was like, "Dude, >> exactly." That's
why I was looking for somewhere I should find the clip cuz somewhere
back here I'm pretty sure Ice calls her for like giving these
suggestions and then probably whatever she suggested would have
prevented what happened here. And so I think she's looking to
farm. Okay, she's or not even farm. She's looking to fight. She
wants to fight with this guy now. Like, hey, your [__]
over. We're working really hard, dude. Obviously, Ice needs to
hire a Witcher to take out these monsters. I heard the going
rate is 100k. Okay.
Why? Why would you need a Witcher to take out
Lav queen always gets what she wants. All right. All right. Syber
drifter. Ain't no one wants to see that. Mid I meies. That's
a weird comment, but also I feel like um Lav's making a bunch
of money off of Only Fans, too. So, I don't I don't know. A lot
of lot of cope going on about Lav in general. Goon and Lav are
the new Darius and Zena when it comes to kick views. I think
they've done really well this event. Yeah, they've done really
well. Anyway, let's let's continue. Uh, give me one sec. I just
need to grab some water. I'll be right back. >> Is Darius
still Okay. >> Is Darius still streaming? I I I want to
talk to chat while you go do Is Darius still streaming? >> Is
he still doing this? Yes. Okay. Because I haven't seen him like
live or whatever. I I don't know what's going Also, what happened
with Zena? I saw she got arrested. Is she like like what's happening
there? Because before I was like, you know, she shot somebody
with a paintball gun. She's probably That's probably not time.
But then I remembered she's a felon, isn't she? She's like a
repeat offender. No, like I don't know how that's going to hold
up. And it's in
I don't know about that, homie. A repeat offender. Was her first
offense violent? If it's a repeat violent offender in Texas.
Oh. Oh. Or was it fraud? I think it was fraud. Right. She's she
I don't know, bro. She tells story. She was like, "Yeah, I I
defrauded I I put like 200k. I I I did, you know, frauded people
200k." Some [__] like that. I'm black. I can say
it. Come on. >> I'm back. I'm back. Um, so Zena did get
arrested. We're going to cover that a little bit later. >> You're
muted or weirdly silent. No, that's really talking to chat. You
just weren't paying attention, soapbox. You just weren't paying
attention. Um, we are going to cover the Zena stuff. She did
get arrested. I don't know how they handle repeat offenses when
it's state like in a different state. I don't know if they do
pull your records from other states and consider it. I'm not
sure cuz it would have been Florida before, I >> Mhm. Yeah.
I don't know. We'll see. >> Yeah. So Box definitely thought
that I was just like ignoring you as you were asking questions.
Like you weren't asking questions to the chat. >> He ignores
me all the time. Soapbox. No. Would have been rude. Yeah. He
>> ignores me all the time. >> Not true. Also, won't
they go after her for the MK assault? Uh they might. I don't
know if she got charged for that or not. I I don't know.
Uh yeah. >> Didn't she just randomly beat M?
>> Not really randomly. MK was Murk was being weird and
with her with her boyfriend in like a bed. M was like >> there
was some weird [__] going on there. I wouldn't say
it wasn't like vi uh assault cuz I think that's what Zena called
it, but it was probably like harassment pretty easily. She was
like drunk and like >> Yeah. being super weird in the bed.
It was playful. Uh, I don't think you should be assaulted for
it. Obviously, Zena's super weird for doing that, but it was
like, it was odd and it was meant to with Zena. And Murk said
as much. MK said, "I knew I would get her with this. I knew I
would get her. I knew I could get her to up, right?" I believe
M said, "You did exactly what I wanted here." >> Some like
that, right? Like, you play like she basically was like, "Ha,
you just fell for my trap card." cuz Zena was getting a restraining
order against Darius was going to [__] Darius and
so I think Murk wanted to get Zena to to up somehow. Yeah, I
don't know. So, one of >> none of these
little finger trying to play games like that. >> Yeah,
it's not that deep. >> yeah, it's not that deep.
But anyway, let's continue on with this. Let's wait for Ice's
response. I think we've got this stuff and then we'll eventually
go to an ice stream. These two Lav I think hops onto a Discord
with Nick Lee. Do you watch any of the Amaranth Nick Lee >> Uh
the only that I saw was when I was in here with you like just
very limited. >> Okay. Yeah, but Amaranth and her husband
are here as well. So lap talks to them. There's a lot of stuff
going on. And then Sam Pepper reviews it this morning. We got
a lot of content all on this stuff tonight. It's going to be
very exciting. Very excited. Is this >> I just tipped $10.
>> Wait, what? The Amazonian merc was making Shuy play
out of food boy roleplay and Zena wasn't having it. >> Thank
you very much, God, for the 10 food fanboy roleplay. I don't
know. I don't know if that's what was happening there, but thank
you very much. I appreciate the donation, guys. If you want to
donate, it is uh I'll throw I'll pin the link here for you, okay?
If you guys want to donate, get get TTS in on TTS in on the stream
exclamation point. Donate in the chat. You get the kickbot link,
you get the Streamlabs link. Either one donations through either
one accepted. You add more time to the stream when you donate.
So, really appreciate all the support. Let's continue on with
this.
>> Damn, he's just sitting there. >> He's just sitting
there. There's nothing you can do.
>> Oh, what the Somebody just sent me. Apparently, Zena
gets progressively hot as her mug shots go on. But the first
one, I don't Is that really her?
>> No, that's not her. The first one is just somebody else.
>> Yeah, Zena keeps getting like more attractive as she
gets mugshotted.
So, as she as she like gets mugshotted, she gets more attractive.
The first one's not her, though. That first one's not her. I
don't think she has tattoos like this. I don't think so. >> Oh,
yeah. The tattoos. Yeah. >> Yeah, that's in there for some
reason. Zena. Zena. Zena. Zena. Yeah. >> Damn. How How
many times has she been arrested four times? >> Apparently
been arrested four times.
>> Apparently, she was allowed to put lip gloss on for
her mug shot, and she was happy with that. Okay.
Okay, dude. All right. Okay. We got to continue. >> Yeah.
Yeah, I'm sure. >> So much content. We got to get through
it, guys. >> The car will help. I'm sure. >> I'm
sure that'll help a lot. >> The car will help you. >> Wait,
that's not a tattoo. That's a shirt. Okay. Even if it is a shirt,
I don't see how that could possibly be Zena. That doesn't look
like >> Are you allowed to wear shirts like that when you're
getting a mug shot? >> Is that really Zena? That's crazy.
Anyway, anyway. Anyway, >> I will just be your >> I
don't know what precipitates this. One >> Ruben donated.
Why she looked like a character from Wind Waker in that first
one sec?
>> I don't know, man. I don't know. I don't >> Damn.
He's just sitting there. >> He's just sitting there. There's
nothing you can do. >> Dude, Ice is seething.
>> Roll
something. >> Yeah, I'm sure that'll fill the hole in your
heart. >> The car will help. I'm sure. >> I'm sure
that'll help a lot. >> The car will help. You >> I
don't know why she does that. Just >> Hey, how about this?
She just wants to watch that. She She literally just wants to
watch that on Ice's stream, right? She's literally just like
She did that so that she could pull out her phone and watch it
on Ice's stream.
>> How about I drop you guys a chest? Maybe. You know,
>> we don't want your
>> You homo playing this game for the off chance that you
have to give the guy who [__] your girlfriend $30,000.
again. She hits him. She hits him with it again. That's why we're
playing this game as well. You were supposed to take the IQ test.
That's what happened.
>> $2,000. The guy for >> Wait, did I miss it? Everybody
in chat saying, "There it is."
>> You did miss it. You did miss it. I'll roll it back.
I'll roll it back.
Christ. >> Yeah, she started licking Goon's face and then
she's watching it. >> How about I drop you guys a chest?
Maybe. You know, >> we don't want your chest.
>> You will. We're playing this game for the off chance
that you have to give the guy who your girlfriend $30,000.
That's why we're playing this game.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. I know. Holy
>> God damn. >> So, I don't think she said it precisely
before this and now Yeah, it's Yeah, there it is. She just throws
it out >> That's why we're playing this game as well. You
were supposed to take the IQ. What happened?
>> $2,000. The guy [__] your girl 30,000. That
that's from the uh earlier in the day he called a and was like
take an IQ test. Yeah.
>> That's why we're playing this game. >> And there's
good one. >> And for what? You have a million dollars and
he [__] your girlfriend on a mattress with no furniture,
>> dude. It's so brutal. It's so brutal. It's so brutal.
It's so brutal.
>> Oh my god. >> It's so brutal. It's so brutal,
dude. >> What's up,
>> Front page. How we doing?
>> Him and his head mod his head chatter.
Who else? >> Talk about other things that you have done
yourself. >> Like what? I
>> So, well, >> he's still composed. He's He's kind
of composed, man. You got to give him points. You got to give
a point. >> Do you? It's Ice Poseidon. Isn't he composed?
Like, hasn't he done everything? Is Hasn't he been through like
all kinds of drama on stream? He knows how to stay composed at
minimum, but I I feel like that's not composed. He's like, "Well,
yeah, Lav, but uh what what about what you've done, Lav? How
about the things you've done?" And it's like, how would anything
she's done help you in this current situation? >> I don't
know. >> He's coping. He's coping. He's coping. >> That's
chatter.
>> Zirka. Who else? talking man. Nah, >> that you
have done yourself. >> Like what? Like what? >> 188
Poseidon. >> One H Poseidon. >> Oh yeah, Zirka heads.
Okay, >> dude. I don't even think you know what she was
up to. >> You're mad. Tim got to try out her leoplasty
before you and you're >> Oh no.
No.
>> She got renovations on the curtains and Gunnar got to
see him first. That's crazy. That's a crazy thing to point out,
dude. >> that's a That's an evil thing to point out. Oh,
no. Dude,
>> hope you didn't pay for it.
>> He needs to He needed to He didn't He was not familiar
with Lav. He didn't realize that he needed to shut the stream
off the second she started talking [__] He just needed
to get out. As bad as it would look, he need to get out cuz he's
platforming her now to like 10 20,000 people or whatever on his
stream. And she's just going to she's going to cook with that.
I'm sorry. She's going to she's going to say
and he >> I think I think if I I think if Ice cuts away
he's a [__] I think if Ice cuts away he's a he does
like this. This is his content is when other people on his stream
get blown the out this way at the moment somebody blows the him
out this way to him if he cuts away. Nah, that's made bro. That's
been made. You can't be a guy who gets people to shave their
head and like eat dog [__] and the moment somebody
starts talking like this, you cut away. Can't happen. Can't >> Yeah,
that's probably true. That's probably true. Yeah, that's probably
true. Uh Junar, link me a time stamp for ISIS's stream. We'll
watch his side of the reaction. At least from when she starts
talking [__] as well. We'll get his side of it. >> What
can he do? He can't turn the stream off or else like a [__]
>> He's saying it. Yeah, he's saying it. He's saying it.
>> You want me to keep going? Ice. Turn the
>> I think
>> Oh, no.
>> He's literally a hostage right now, D.
>> It's so
It's so >> You want me to keep going? Ice, turn the
>> I think Tazo's close. Ice. >> Ice. I think >> I
think Tazo's really close.
>> Very upset. >> Jose's close. Think positive.
>> Guys, app isn't working. I think I think we're going
to do white t-shirts now. >> Already got it. >> [__]
What am I going to do? >> Let's go camping. >> Okay.
I I think this it does keep going for quite a while after this,
but I'm just going to go for Ice's stream real quick. We'll check
out the reaction when he hears it for the first time. >> Yeah,
I'm sure that'll fill the
>> That's That's a little too late. That's a little too
late. Hold on. Go back to the beginning here. >> Had his
Discord figured out if I'm being honest. But he also must be
pretty smart cuz he seems to consistently be able to find first.
>> There's four more. There's four more. >> Only
has one RFID at it.
>> Fact that you haven't found. >> I can't wait to
see you complain about that one. >> There it is. We got
the time.
>> Oh man, the chaos. >> I actually hid one too that
I know for a fact that you haven't found. It's in Kimmy's vagina.
>> Oh, I I I know exactly where that is. months ago.
>> Oh, Jesus. Never mind. He's coping so >> I know
exactly where that is. >> I know where that is. I know
her vagina >> I've seen the inside of her vagina.
>> I know her vagina well. >> Oh [__]
Oh [__] Here the chat goes. Sore losers. I'm not
even losing, dude. >> Oh my god.
>> You're not losing, but you act like you act like you're
losing, which is even >> Just got to [__] Sometimes
you just got to go. We're >> not losing, but you act like
you act like you're losing. It's even worse.
>> I don't think we're acting like we're >> I've
had I've had a sit down dinner for the last four days with my
beautiful >> We've had more times in the last 24 hours
than you have in six months.
>> We have our time. I spent the night in the hospital.
We just >> Well, I'm a very busy man. I have a lot of things
going on that make me uh >> a lot of money and a lot of
I have a lot of work to do. I don't have time for
>> 20% chance that >> very busy man. I have a lot
of things going on that make me money and a lot of
>> he's he's look he's still confident right now that he
can pull this back. He's still like chilled right now. As much
as he's got getting owned a little bit, he's like still confident
at this point that he can pull it back. He's like leaning back
in the chair. He's just eating a little bit. He feels like he's
gonna pull this back. He feels like he's gonna make it through
it. He has no idea what's coming to do. >> And what's it
all for? >> This is your hard work. >> And look at
your kingdom. What's it all for, buddy? Unmarried, childless.
>> Oh, I might buy >> Do your own laundry. >> Might
buy a Rolls-Royce at some point here. Join Nick with over there.
>> He's just sitting there. >> he's just sitting
there. There's nothing you can do.
>> Yeah, I'm sure that'll fill the hole in your heart.
The car will help. I'm sure. >> I'm sure that'll help a
lot. >> The car will help you. >> Oh, she
or whatever. Just real quick. >> Laugh. How about I drop
you guys a chest? Maybe, you know, what are we thinking? $5,
maybe 10. >> I'll pull it back a little bit. >> Don't
worry. How about this? >> Makes a chat. Watch that. Gross.
>> We don't want your
>> Whatever happened to that IQ test as well? You were
supposed to take the IQ test. What happened? >> For the
off chance that you have to give the guy who your girlfriend
$30,000.
That's why we're playing this game. That's why
Good. >> You were supposed to take the IQ test.
>> Okay, buddy. Good one. Okay, buddy. Good >> That's
why.
>> So, should I drop the chest or not, >> And for
what? You have a You have a million dollars and he [__]
your girlfriend on a mattress with no >> Well, I'm not
sure. No, >> I'm not sure where you're pulling that from,
but >> I mean, you should talk about uh other things, Lav
that you have done yourself >> Oh, that's a brutal response.
He's getting absolutely torched and that's his response.
>> That's crazy.
>> Zirka. Who else? >> Talk about
>> Oh, yeah. Zirka head mods. Okay. >> What? Ice.
>> Oh, no. >> Like what? >> One HP. One H Poseidon.
>> One H Poseidon. >> Oh, yeah. Sorry. >> DQ.
DQ. >> You know what? >> Oh, good one. All right.
>> Day one. Switch stream quick.
>> Hope you didn't pay for it. >> Oo, Lav's really
pulling out all the >> It's over, man. She won.
>> They are very upset. They are very upset that they are
>> I think Tazo's close. >> I think Tazo's close.
>> I think Tazo's really close.
>> They are very upset. Oh, Zi is close. >> Well,
Zei already got it.
>> Oh, no.
That's what gets this whole chat against him is when she's like,
"You got to switch." Okay, you got to you got to you got to reason
to switch. Tanzu's getting close, guys. Taz is getting close
right >> guys. App isn't working. I think I think we're
going to do white t-shirts now, >> bro. He's just vibing.
>> Look at this dude. >> Oh, he did switch over for
a second. >> What am I going to do? >> He's just
vibing.
>> Let's see. Tazo is pulling up now too with Gary. >> Oh,
he does actually just go away. No
>> No way. No way. >> O. I wonder does he go back
to them at all? We'll see if he goes back.
>> No, I don't. I don't know if he goes back to them at
all here. Yeah, he gets off of them entirely. So, we'll go back
to their stream. We'll keep watching from here. See what they
keep saying. >> Switch. Yeah. Look. Hey, chat. Look at
>> He did switch. Hold on one second. I just need to reset
my headphones, guys.
Two seconds.
Make eat another cockroach. >> Uh, they have not reset
yet for me. Hello. Headphones. Go. >> Hi. Headphones.
>> dead. They're like mostly dead. I'm back. By the way,
what's up? Sorry. These headphones were mostly dead. I didn't
notice when I started stream, so I I didn't have them charged.
It's my bad. I went I went live early for you guys. Don't make
Don't make fun of me. Don't talk [__] I went live
early for you guys. Okay. I spends the rest of the stream coping.
Like every four minutes he says something else. Oh, we'll go
to the cope session at the end, guys. Okay, we'll get to the
cope session at the end. It'll be good. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. I've got that time stamp. Junar Arc. Okay, but I think
they keep talking for a while here if I'm not mistaken. Let me
see if I've got that old tab open still. I feel like they go
to like 10 hours here. They just keep
>> Yeah, look. Hey, look at this. >> Make Chuy eat
another cockroach. Yeah, I think I think they talk [__]
for like a while here. >> Well, I'm blacklisted now. So,
let's enjoy our last Ice Boseidon event. Babe, >> we have
to win now. Chat, let's keep it
really pulled out the punches here. >> Yeah, remind me
off. >> I was going to bring up the dog picture.
>> That's probably not you, buddy. You're saying how Goon's
such a loser, such a whatever. What does that make you? If he
could get what you had for free. I did it on a budget >> within
with on a budget within six
>> What? Why did he say that? >> Oh my god. I meant
to turn it down.
>> You come for You come for the bull. You get my horn.
Okay.
>> Call my Call my husband stupid and a loser again. I
dare you. Holy. >> Okay. So, how did your old feel, babe?
Do you feel good? >> It felt like I need to go to sleep
and we should not be Actually, should we try to win now?
>> Now, if we win, it's so much sweeter.
>> It would be so good if they just won now and forced
them to pay. That would be so much better. >> But I ain't
getting that money if I win. There's no way. He'll find a way.
You You just like >> It would be legendary content. And
if everybody worked together to get these guys to be the winner.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying is like I I'm willing to go join
this >> I'm willing to go join this Discord and like power
them through so they definitely win in the end. Okay. >> Got
the J deep AI on the on the >> Yeah, we we we could go
help. We could definitely go help. I feel like I feel like Ice
is borderline like ready to just give the solution to somebody.
He'll be like, Tazo, this is it. Never tell anybody. I'll give
you 30k. Just don't let them win. Go straight there. Go straight
to the solution.
I feel like I actually think he would do that. I actually think
he would do that. >> I'm not joking. I think he would do
that 100%. Yeah. >> Husband, you little rat.
>> Jesus. Not shocking. >> I love you. >> Not
a shocking comment.
>> And Hydrris, no spoilers. >> You [__]
dog.
>> Let's talk about
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Let's talk about it. >> Classic Goonar quitting
arc. >> Did you see that? Goar ate Kimmy's ass. He has
worms now. Not good. >> I told you there's always a trop
pack, >> Dude, not good. Destroying Goon's
>> I have a real job, man. >> Make the kid eat another.
>> Don't you ever. >> Apparently, Ice made Shuy eat
a Okay. And they're pissed about it. >> Bully Shuy again.
>> You bully Shuy again. I swear to God, I'm sick of this
big bully. I'm sick of this big bully thinking he's untouchable.
Sorry. >> Sorry that I see a man who needs to be humbled.
Sorry. I need I see a man who needs to be humbled >> and
I do it. Sorry. >> It hurts to see your god bleed. I know.
I wouldn't wish it on the worst of you. Actually, I would. All
you >> They deserve war. They deserve a war. We're too
cute. That would be so
>> dude. No.
No. What is this picture of them? This guy. This is a little
preview for the stream. Okay. For the next stream we're going
to be reviewing. But apparently Live showed this picture today.
That's >> Is that Goon? >> And that's Goonar.
>> Tuner. Ah, >> dude. This could just be this could
be a meme image right here. If you get more of her face somewhere
where she's like laughing and showing it at the same time, you
put anything on this screen. This is perfect,
dude. He's on the throne. He's on the throne in this picture.
The porcelain throne.
>> No way,
bro. She She like looks She's in like a classy club dress. Not
classy. She's in like a >> an aggressive club dress or
something. And he's just here in a t-shirt sitting on the sitting
on the toilet. Okay, man. >> That's crazy. That's crazy.
That's crazy, dude.
>> That'd be so totally >> What does he even do now?
>> I don't know. What can you do? >> What does he
even do? Go get on the plane, baby. >> Want to go to Six
Street? >> Kind of. Yeah. >> All right. Sorry about
that, guys. My wife got a little bit crazy there. I do feel like
he had no chance here, right? He had no option to pull out of
this. He had no option to change it up. He was just he knew he
was in as soon as she said it. Like he I it seems like he thought
it was funny and he's like in. But he he literally doesn't have
a choice anymore. Once that once she puts that info out there,
he's either way, so he's got to go this way. >> Sorry.
My wife My wife's off her meds. My wife is off her meds right
now and she got a little bit bananas. Okay. Where the [__]
is this RFID? See, my wife gets a little hungry and starts saying
crazy [__] I don't know where that came from. on
the electrical box. >> Is Gunnar kind of regretting it?
Well, yeah. He makes like a decent amount of money streaming,
right? So, obviously, if you have like a super, you know, anti-fanish
community or something, you get like a community, people who
hate you, right? You build that up on kick, that's going to make
your kick streams rough. You don't necessarily want that. Maybe,
maybe it's good cuz it builds up KCIP anyway. Maybe it doesn't
matter, but yeah. >> Ice, by the way, uh did you not hear
>> Ice is the reason he got bumped up from 99 cents a day?
I don't know why his KCIP would have been lower. I have no idea
what why would that even make sense. Go ahead, Really. Sorry.
>> I don't I don't know. Why is
Why is uh Does he not know this? Does I not know this? Does he
not know who who all his girlfriend is that is in his immediate
vicinity? I feel like that's that'd be like weird. No, >> it
could be. Yeah, it could be weird. I would expect
I would kind of want to know. Yeah, like your your girlfriend
is
allegedly
like five or six of the people who are contestants or whatever
or hanging out with you daily and you don't even know like >> what
are you doing, bro? Yeah, give a brother letting breathe, man.
Come on. >> Oh, I see. Hold on. This is like a fake image.
This was not Gunnar. They said this and they brought this up.
Somebody sent it to me. False.
False. Okay, that's not that's not uh that was not Gerard. That
was a fake image. Okay, that was a fake image from before.
>> It's like some Only Fans person. >> Yes, it was
some Only Fans person. It did seem weird. Okay, fake news. That
was fake news. I was sent that. It was fake news.
Okay,
>> that would have been pretty brutal if it was real. >> Yeah,
would have been would have been pretty crazy. >> Discord,
I'm two FR RFIDs behind. >> Yeah, me and my crash out wife.
>> This is the lab tent. Anemone, this is the lab. You
just missed. >> You just missed the big the big punch line,
but don't worry, there's a lot more coming. >> My Discord
didn't even react. They're still working on the next clue. Holy,
you guys are locked. Sorry to let you down. Sorry to let you
guys down. I'm uh definitely getting DQed at this point.
>> That's uh that's rough. >> Where the is this thing?
I showed up 30 minutes late.
Oh, they cover it. Oh, >> Yeah, I'm going to speed this
up till they get back in the car here. >> Do we even >> start
talking about this again? >> No. So, just with the whole
Shuy thing, they were like getting mad at Ice for Shuy. Apparently,
Ice said he'd pay Shuy 500 bucks if he ate a and then Shuy did
it,
right? Shuy did it and they didn't pay him. They ripped him off.
>> I can like force somebody out of the top
>> You really just didn't pay him for doing that? Was there
a reason he didn't pay >> He He must have paid him now,
right? Yeah, he must have paid him now. >> That That's
a crazy thing to do. That's
>> no. That's insane. >> Hold on. Completely wrong.
It was 500. Oh, why am I Why are people just messaging me and
saying things that aren't true? It was 500 points apparently
they were going to give him and then he didn't eat it. The Why
is everybody saying that Chievy got ripped off? Also, check your
info before you send it to me. Stop with the fake. What are you
doing? No, we're not going over. No, Faith has follower. This
will always be the case. We go in chronological order. Okay,
chronological order
every time. So, we have not gone to this morning's Discord logs
because we're currently watching last night's stream. We will
get to it. >> Yeah. It'll give them a better chance. >> Yeah.
True. >> So, just keep doing me.
>> The they're feeling the come down from like we just
we just said some we can't really take back.
>> Never. Like I'm the wicked witch of the
>> He won't DQ you, but he will put a bounty on you. >> Uh
I stiffed him 200 because he didn't swallow it apparently. He
only said he put it in his mouth. Okay, I got you. >> I'd
like to see him cry. >> I love how much of a crash you
are, >> dude. I just I don't like seeing men with like
that big of a god complex. And especially that's what we met
because you had a gong god complex and I started bullying you.
>> Yeah. And I loved it. But guys like him, I don't think
they can handle [__] like that. He's so used to being
>> When he's calling you a stupid loser, I'm like, "Yeah,
nobody buddy. You I
>> I'm the only one who calls him a stupid loser." Okay.
Not anyone else. >> You don't want to go there. He's calling
you a stupid complainy loser after we gave him very salient feedback.
Like, >> yeah, the day started off so well. >> You're
making You're making kids eat bugs and fight and ju obviously
has a learning disability.
>> You attacked his girlfriend. His girlfriend's a too.
His girlfriend was a to me out of nowhere. Like, she doesn't
[__] deserve either. >> Well, she definitely
isn't going to be any nicer now. >> Well, she I she was
never nice to me ever. Even though even when I was extremely
nice to her. So she can get wrecked also. >> Destiny hit
it first. Just tipped $3.
>> Apparently. Yes. This is uh Lab Lab doesn't realize
that she set off like every community. And now now DG does just
openly harass people. So good luck. That's why we're on lab side
here. Well, sorry. That's why I take lab side. All right. That's
for saying down. >> We I think Desessie reviewed some of
this stuff today as well. I can't imagine he it seems pretty
obvious that like I don't know. It's just content. I I wonder
what the reads of >> Mary Dies sloppy. That's kind of wild
talk, but can't handle it. Lo the lore. >> The lore is
literally
that he did not [__] me. That is literally the lore
is that he never had sex with me ever and that's why he is upset.
>> The chick at the armor shows, bro. They should just
keep digging to copy. Well, he didn't me. It's like, all right.
Well, we know they know what to say. They know what to say to
get her upset. Ice, if he's taking notes.
>> Let's see it. Let's see it. >> To be fair, I would
uh I understand her hesitance to to admit that she did anything.
Okay. >> You have so little >> I understand, too.
Yeah. think I my dog
>> which I did and two and it's on my only fans and it's
on my only fans only
>> We're getting actually just banned from the website
and
>> and that I Destiny. >> This is a great outro stream.
Hey, >> let's play some goodbye horses.
>> Well, thank you guys for watching the Goon Squad. >> Good
got the outfit on to play goodbye horses right now. >> He's
dressed for the occasion. a great project for a while. >> God
forgives. >> God forgives the Goon Squad. You should have
never cheated us out of that Hunger Games win or the Rat Race
win for this win. It's been an honor. >> 07s. Can I get
07s in the chat? >> 07, guys. 07. >> It's been fun,
but it ain't been great fun. I'll see you all in hell. Great
work tonight, baby.
>> We got a third place scan. Hank, my career in a beautiful
symphony of raid. Uh, also just to be clear, guys, we we're going
to keep going on this cuz Lav starts leaking DMs after this with
Cammy. So, we'll keep going. Keep >> So, Shuy survival
stream when?
>> Yeah. I just wanted the stream down so I can suck your
[__]
>> Black bulb. It was bound to happen >> Invite to
Schwendy's house. >> Love this song. Yeah. >> We
never get to meet Hondro's dogs. >> Yep. Back to the Midwest.
>> If only they were good people.
Oh my god, I'm losing out on so many of the best people in life.
>> I do. Handra is great instead of 20 is a >> ton
of There's a ton of great people.
>> it is what it is. >> Sounds like we'll have to
be really happy in the Midwest again.
>> Ice is retiring soon anyway. >> Retirement, there's
room at the top.
>> last event. >> Oh, weird weird conflicted take
here. Lav and Gunnar are such good people.
Such good people, man. Ice doesn't deserve them. That's a crazy
take. Fiend. I feel like you're probably the only person with
that take, but I appreciate it. >> These suck anyways.
>> That's what I'm like. Do we even like You don't even
want to do this again. >> He didn't even want to do this.
>> I didn't even want to go. I just went for the money.
>> Well, we want to hang out with Chicken. >> And
Schwendy, which
>> Oh, the moon.
>> Whoa. The moon is orange. Goodbye CX.
>> Goodbye ACIP.
>> Goodbye CX.
>> Your dog [__] retards ruin my chat. Oh,
I skipped to the back. Run it back.
>> Oh my god, >> baby. Steak stream. >> Let's
run it. >> Ice. Ice. Can we get a steak chest? Ice. Can
we get a steak chest? >> Jesus. Steak chest. DQ.
>> $1,000 duel duel duel. They send this [__]
out with a bang. >> Dude, I'm I'm gonna say this and and
I fully believe this. If they get DQed or or lower pryo in any
way, Ice is a [__] He's just a total bull. I I don't
know what happens. He's just a total bull. If that happens, this
is just this is just good content. And more importantly, it's
the content that he pushes on the people he has on his >> He
cannot be a [__]
>> No, no, no. Continue. >> Yeah. He can't be a [__]
And the moment it happens to him, he backs the out. He farms
this from other people daily. I haven't seen it. No. >> You
haven't seen the when he invited them over for Thanksgiving and
he just like totally instigates the whole time until they finally
have like a meltdown fight about Sam Bond. He's like got the
camera here and he's like the whole time just like picking at
them trying to get them to fight, right? And now Gunnar and Laugh
are doing it to him and Kim Kimmy and he can't handle it at all.
You you dish it out, you got to be able to take it, right? That's
just that that's the >> You got to be able to take it.
>> Ungrateful and trashy with huge egos. I wonder who else
that could apply.
>> Mirror emoji. Um mirror emoji. Like okay, whatever you
say.
>> Yeah. Go to go to Lon Snark. You're going to find out
that I'm based in
>> I'm not racist.
>> Can I get a recap? I just got here.
Why did you even say that guy? >> I made you ner look like
a [__] >> Think of it. >> The August
13th incident.
>> They just hit the second. They just hit the Pentagon.
>> Um, what do we
do? >> We just I'm not going to lie to you. This is >> They're
They're just like >> This is kind of just cope mode. They're
just like letting it set in that they're just not going to be
a part of this
>> Yeah. I I don't I don't know spoilers or nothing. No
spoilers.
I don't know if Ice actually gets rid of him. They're just He's
to He's to >> He definitely signals that he's going to.
And he signaled before that he would like up Kimmy too when she's
like when he's mad at her. He says it, but I don't even know.
Like I actually don't believe like Kick's running a real operation
now. I feel like there's no way Eddie goes over this and with
people's case.
Yeah, that's the thing I was thinking about. I don't >> I
spend all
DGG and all you guys focus on is if Destiny asked for consent
before using that butt plug on stream, which he obviously did.
>> Okay, thank you very much for the five that Mantis.
H, sorry, go off now. >> All right, so I that's what I
was thinking. I like the idea maybe it's possible. I don't think
ice has the type of pull where he can just go like, "Oh, yeah,
whatever. just pull these people's like whatever. Like maybe
if it was train wrecks he could maybe do it maybe. But like in
general >> Well, here's here's the thing. I think getting
somebody's KCIP fixed is way different than getting it taken
away, right? Getting it fixed cuz you're like, I trust this guy.
Here's like my opinion of him and he like got it fixed for some
people. That's way different than going this guy my girlfriend.
I'm mad about it. So, can you take his Casey away? Like every
business person in the world is going to go no. That would be
weird. We're not doing that. >> Um, so I I do think Ice
has a lot of pull with Kick cuz I think he does these events
and he does them under Kick's brand and I think it does generate
a lot of traffic for the site and a lot of movement towards the
site. So I don't think they hate him. I think they really like
him. So but like it's it's mutually
Insane money for that, right? He already gets paid for it. >> Yeah.
My my point is what you're talking about is that pull taking
money away from somebody else especially for an arbitrary reason.
The kind of pull you would need to have is really really significant
and I would only really expect that from like maybe Train I think
maybe Train could do maybe Aiden as well could do that like these
people who are like the movers and shakers because Train owns
equity in stake doesn't he? Like he's like a partner.
>> Yeah. Yeah, he does. But like I don't know. I don't
think they when you run a business like this, you endeavor not
to let that happen. Maybe it happens early on. I don't think
that's happening anymore where they're like, "Oh yeah, like a
wink and a nudge and we're going to like [__] this
guy's [__] up." I just don't I don't think they're
going to do that. I think the worst Ice could do or the the only
thing ICE could do is say, "You guys, I'm leaving this platform."
But it's like, bro, you're making like millions of dollars a
year here right now. Why Why would you Why would you leave it?
Cuz we're not going to like bend your whims when you're making
so much money, >> right? Yeah, >> it doesn't make
any sense. So, yeah.
>> let's keep going. I'm going to see if they It's still
like an hour after this where Lab starts leaking DMs. So, I don't
know how we're going to get through this exactly. >> Why
are black people always FaceTime each other? Are you
>> That was >> That was a horrible timing. That is
horrible. Horrible. >> That was a content timing right
there. Why are black people always like immediately reaches for
the phone, snaps his hand out instinctively to hit the mute button?
>> That's [__] funny. I'm sorry. That's funny.
H That was That was funny. They're mad. They're mad that they
found my tweet where I said, "Why are black people always facing
each other in >> They are. >> They are.
>> I've never seen that once in my life. But I don't know.
>> But but like that's also not even close to the most
racist thing I've said. So I don't even know why you'd bring
that up as if it's like a do you think you cooked with that one?
I don't know. >> There's nothing wrong with that.
>> I'm just a noticer. I'm just a noticer.
>> Goon and Kimmy were roommates for a
>> Okay. So, that would be >> that would be when
they lived in the Cupot house, right? Yeah. I think I I think
I'm starting to see where this could happen. I would like to
thank all of your fine effort in getting my KP
to skyrocket before it is ripped away from me. This is the final
stream.
Thank you >> I appreciate it so much. >> The cute
bot house. They lived with Cutebot and Jaw Millionaire. Two two
streamers. That's Gunnar lived there. I'm guessing Kimmy lived
there as well.
>> This we passed at Twin Liquors 78.
>> Let's go home.
No, we're here for chicken and Adri. >> that means we crash
out. We're getting body armor. >> I think you did. >> No,
like on everyone.
>> No, everyone here is good. >> They're really They're
really letting it hang now. I'm going >> invited a lot
of places. Why? She's not
>> This [__] up 10fold. >> Yeah, there's
more. There's more here. >> Even she wouldn't go there.
>> Hold on. I'm I'm backing it up. They do start Lab starts
checking her phone and getting messages. >> You realize
lab is a toilet.
Is that >> Two Twitch streamers with a combined body count
probably in the five digits. Oh, I thought you were going to
say viewer count and then I was going to say yeah, cuz there's
999 9,990
for her cute pod and 10 for >> guys. Is that real chat?
Oh, hell no, >> Oh, hell no, chat. >> Oh, hell no,
chat. Is that real, >> bro? Bro, who the is Tim? And who
is Why do you [__] Tim?
>> Why Tim Kimmy? And who the is Tim, bro? Who the [__]
is Tim? Oh, hell no, Chad. >> I'm assuming he's Tim. >> He's
Tim. He is Tim. Okay. Oh, >> hell no. Nick White. >> Nick
White. Maybe. >> I kind of I kind of doubt he [__]
just because he was living with Cubot and her >> But you
never know. >> You
has a husband. >> Yeah, the Jaw guy is her husband. >> Or
they're they're engaged at least. They're engaged at least. >> Oh,
I didn't I didn't know that. >> Yeah. For all of Jaw's
flaws, he is like 7 foot tall. So, >> ghost done suicide.
>> I kind of understand in jail.
Gross losers cry. Cry. >> We're about to be gross winners.
Yeah, >> we're about to be the trashiest winners.
>> Gia, Gia, let's ramp this up 10fold. Josiah, I shouldn't
name him. Those who who are on the team,
>> ramp it up. Take your Adderall. Don't go to bed. >> Unbel
from the Discord, but I She's streaming a goon right now, so
she's not going to join right now. >> Your tattoos are
ugly. They have nothing to actually say. Holy [__]
Could you guys think of a single thing to say? >> I mean,
this I'm not going to lie to you. This like a nightmare if you
don't know anything about the people that you're insulting and
they're not like hideously ugly. You're just like, because they
know everything about you. Like, what do you even do? Oh, bro,
you're wearing a bandana and you're what? Driving a truck. I
don't know. You're redneck loser. >> You look like a redneck.
>> It's like literally she cultivates is like the red the
redneck persona, right? Like you you're just missing entirely.
Yeah. Yeah. It's rough.
>> That's also why you can't really fight with chatters
very effectively. It's like really difficult to actually talk
like chatters and [__] as well. Yeah. Because they
they just you don't know anything about them and they'll know
everything about you. So, how the [__] you even trash
talk them? Like there's just nothing there. It's like you are
a loser. You watch me. It's like oh [__] Just hit
everybody else. Collateral
>> Oh boy. >> Don't make fun of the girl Ice threatens
to kill everyone.
>> We could have been friends, Kimmy. I came up to you
and you were such a rancid cop to me. I came up to her >> I
offered you my friendship and you spat >> I said I went
after a dream hack. I was like, "Hey, you said something really
nice to me two years ago. Like, thank you so much." And she looked
at me and she was like, "Okay." And I was I was so taken aback
>> and that's when Lav conspired to kiss. From that moment
forward, I knew I had to ruin this in public. Okay. >> How
rancid it was. Never. Nobody has ever talked to me like that
before. And then crashing out at me because you didn't text her
back after she was like reaching back out to you in >> Oh,
yeah. >> What was it? December
January. >> Months ago when she was reaching out. >> That's
That's where the eight months ago thing comes from. That's where
it comes from. That's eight months ago. Yeah.
>> Ice He's doing the math. Ice right now is doing the
math. >> Yeah. No, that's not favorable.
>> That's not good. That's not good. >> He's like,
"Wait,
January, wait.
Hold
>> Oh, no, bro.
>> Wait, hold on. Rewind. I missed that. Uh, Lab said Kimmy
was also a B to her in a different scenario as well. >> I
was I was so taken aback
by how rancid it was. I've never Nobody has ever talked to me
like that before. And then crashing out at me because you didn't
text her back after she was like reaching back out to you. And
>> Oh, yeah. >> What was it? Yeah. >> Yeah.
Months >> months ago when she was reaching out after she
her face up for the
way
>> you were sweet and you were like, "Hey, if you >> I
had to switch headphones over. Can I hear you, Really? Just need
to see if I can hear you." I cannot. Okay, let me I'll fix this.
I'll fix this. Really? You got the You got the helm for two seconds.
Sorry. I I had to charge these headphones and they just died
on me. So, [__] [__] They're coming back.
They're coming back. I swear to God these headphones will click
in in two seconds. Okay, now I should be able to hear you. Just
did it manually. Oh, he's got his mic muted. Well, unfortunate.
Unfortunate. Unfortunate. Okay, we're >> Anything? Let
me know. Cuz she was on like suicide. >> Everything's working
on my end. >> And then she was like, I really wish that
I could move back in and you didn't have anything to say to her.
And then she was getting mad at me that you didn't text her back.
And then she was like, you know, ice Pesidon could leak it. Cuz
I was like, >> yeah. Like she tried to threaten it like
two weeks ago. >> Yeah. So what Kimmy basically had done
through the is that say that maybe like he like that Tim was
like obsessed with her or something that wrote her love letters
or something maybe to like pacify it for Ice to like be less
embarrassed by >> I can't plug those other headphones in.
I can't plug them in while they're on. And yeah, they they don't
work while they're running or while they're charging, which sucks,
but unlucky.
>> And because it is embarrassing to obsessed with her
or something that wrote her love letters or something, maybe
to like pacify it for ice to like be less embarrassed by him.
And because it is embarrassing to him. >> When I was sleeping
on >> Lav is feminizing Goon. Men should not gossip. Is
Gooner gossiping?
I feel like if I'm not mistaken, I think Sam Pepper's been the
one who's like been trying to drop this for like months now,
right? That this happened. I don't think Gunnar's Gunnar told
his girlfriend something. She's gossiping. Okay. But it sounds
like other people knew this. Okay. I don't think this was like
as well kept a secret as some people are suggesting it was >> on
the floor with no mattress. >> And gambling. >> Yeah.
Um for by in the first six hours of meeting him, by the way.
Like just pretty brutal stuff. >> Um and uh Jesus
>> That is that is wild. She just keeps going. She just
keeps hitting. She's the guy's down and she's just like pounding
him into the floor right now. Will not >> Yeah. So then
Sam Pepper like teases it when Ice Boseidon's crashing out
and we're like and I'm getting scared like oh is there a narrative
that's like going to get pressed and like all of a sudden we're
not going to be on top of it. I message her. I'm like, "Hey,
need to know what you said." She's like skitsoing at me. Writes
this whole big thing. Whatever. Just is it just so rancid to
me. Has only been rancid to me except for >> to tell me
not to get plastic surgery. I guess it was the only time she
was ever nice to me. But it was like very >> cuz I had
made a joke about how I was going to get what did I say? A BBL
or something. I made a joke. But yeah, Sam Pepper, shout out.
Thank you for making this happen. is dude. Sam Pepper leaking
the supposed love letter that Goon wrote Kimmy. Goon denies it.
Of course. Okay, I'm pulling this up to say once again guys to
stop spoiling for the love of God. Stop spoiling. I have all
the content for this. Stop spoiling. Okay, stop being like I
watched ahead and now I know all Stop. Just stop. Okay, I love
you, but chill. >> I want to I'm going to do this every
time I'm sabotaging my own reputation with any distinct group.
I'm just going to shout out a bunch of people so that way they
get caught in the crossfire.
This is so big. Yo, shout out Sam Pepper that my bro. Yo,
thanks for giving me that 50k.
>> crazy. This whole everyone in this >> just to
be clear, I believe she's talking about this and I think I can't
remember precisely what Sam said. >> Ice would call me.
Ice would call >> Sam went through all of these these uh
Discord messages. I have these, but like hold on. Um, loyal.
I can't remember. If somebody could find this, I'll put it in
the chat. If somebody could just find where he like kind of stealth
references this, right? Like around with kick.
Oh man, I I don't know how I don't know where it's in here. Okay.
I don't know where it was. If anybody has that like stealth shout
out from before, I would want to hear it, but we'll see. We'll
see if we can if we can find if someone can buy it for us. >> Everyone
in this space is so the only real people in this space. Adriana,
literally the most down ever. So sweet. Maddie, another sweetheart
who Kimmy tried to blackball because Ice messaged >> Oh
yeah. >> Another Yeah. Telling you about it. Yep. >> Telling
you about it. How she was going to get her removed from every
single event just for being >> There's a reason why Maddiey's
not here. Cuz Kimmyy's a psycho. >> Yeah. I mean, she probably
also didn't want to do this because it was scuffed. But like,
yes, there's a reason why Maddie was not invited a lot of places.
Why she's not bigger than she is. And it's just because she's
hot. and blonde and Kitty's replacement. That was the fear. So
>> yeah, I like just these poor Maddie who's like a sweet
girl. Real girl sweet
this is so >> Dude, I I don't know why. Okay, Gonar's Goonar's
gossiping now. They're they're now gossiping about Kimmy and
just how she blacklisted a bunch of other people. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
I I hope Gunnar has those messages because that would be that'd
be kind of crazy to just to put that out there and then not be
able to back that up. >> And you know, we love Lav. Okay,
not all of us, not really. But um some of us are cool with Lav,
but she does do this sometimes where she'll put something out,
she can't really back it up and then it's like really really
>> so rancid to each other. >> We have no problem
with the real people who are genuine human beings just trying
to make it. It's the people that take advantage of those people
that are [__] up and scumbags. >> Yeah. And
this there's so many secrets cuz everyone's trying to get in
like Ice's good graces because he has the most money and he puts
events like this. >> We don't give a because we make real
money outside of this and we do this for
>> See our friends. Yeah. There was a time >> I think
Gunnar from what I understand about Gutter is he's got like a
job where he's like inherited or he is like >> he's got
his parents' money or parents parents run a company or something.
So he is a job through that. But I think he does focus quite
a bit on streaming. >> You needed ice when you
>> Got a dono. >> Reminder that all Ice did was call
Yin stupid. I'm [__] crying, dude. Never give Lavagon
because she'll blow your brains out for bumping into her. >> Uh
yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> You know, we're younger, but is changing now. He's on
his way out. Obviously, he can't throw together a [__]
good
>> Yeah. How many test runs? >> Shuy, I'm Shu is
going to be top guy next. Sh going to be >> and I'll be
watching my >> bandic. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. People in ISIS Discord are trying to find your family business.
>> Yeah. Damage control time, guys. >> Yeah. Oh,
no. >> He He doesn't have money. He works at his dad's
landscaping company and lives in one of his dad's houses and
they still about not having money. Sorry. They So, his parents
have money. That's what I'm talking about is I'm pretty sure
his parents have money and he like really doesn't have that much
to worry about, right? Like I think that's why he can just stream
is cuz he's just got a fall back. like his parents have a business.
He'll just take that business >> You're going to tell people
that you is his girlfriend like you. >> Hey, this person
who I don't know guy and he had uh yeah, thank you. Bye. >> Good.
Also, >> I don't know why people come at people who are
like 25 plus with this. It's like, hey, your girlfriend [__]
the other dude. It's like, yeah, that's that's like 99% of the
female population. So, I don't know what to tell you, bro.
It's just bizarre. It's I don't know. No, shout out Kimmy because
Kimmy was the one who who told you to date me because you kept
talking to her about me while you guys were >> and now
we're married which is >> Good call Kimmy. >> Good
call. Maybe she has some intuition. >> Okay. Are we getting
>> I don't know why she decided to answer to me after that.
>> We're still like an hour away. She's not even attractive
in the slightest. Lav.
>> guys. Chat's moving a little too fast. Can you start
TTS so we could hear it >> Yeah, I can't. I'll only reply
to TTS, guys. I really >> It's just so hard. We're like
both driving.
We're both driving and it's like really hard to respond to everything.
So >> Oh, Kimmy. I see. Kimmy. Oh, okay. I didn't see your
previous message then. >> My bad. My bad. Keep going. Oh,
laugh. Could play Trans Zelda. >> Special announcement.
I'll be on Kick Talk next weekend, guys. Eddie's going to have
a stern talking to me. Oh god, >> That was pretty >> And
welcome to rumble.com.
>> That That scavenger hunt didn't go quite as planned
there, Goon, did it? >> Base Ghost said, "Good and Lav
are so disgusting. Hope they never get invited
>> We're not coming. >> Ice Poseidon
had a gun to his >> base ghost I believe is it Ice Boseidon's
head mod? I'm not sure. Or if it's another streamer cuz I I see
him having like mod and ISIS Discord and >> Reban Ruben
donated $3. You'd expect someone wearing a tie-dyed shirt to
have a little more love in her heart. >> But we know her,
so we didn't expect
>> Bar on Aderall. >> Wait, what? Hold on. What was
she about to drop? >> They're not coming.
had a gun to his head.
>> Bar on Aderall. >> We're looking for Sam referencing
the situation on Kicker Keep. Uh, wait, was was he doing that?
Did he do that? Cuz Oh, yeah. I've got another clip from Kicker
Keep, which is funny as well. Wait, weren't you just being friends
with Ice is good networking? Were you not just going on how it's
like good networking to work with other streamers? [__]
[__] >> So much is unlocking in my brain right
now, which I can't say on stream, but now I know who you are.
>> Oh,
that's Gunnar up here. And Sam's like Sam Gunnar's talking to
Sam and and Sam's like, "Oh, so much unlocking in my brain right
now. Suddenly I realize who you are.
>> Look, look at this. Top right.
>> You being friends with Ice is good networking. Were
you not just going on how it's like good networking to work with
other streamers? [__] [__] >> So
much is unlocking in my brain right now, which I can't say on
stream, but now I know who you are. >> Yeah, you know.
>> Oh my god, >> dude. They're just openly talking
about it. That's crazy. >> Embarrassing. Everything just
unlocked in my brain and you know what I'm talking about. I know
what you're talking so
I want to know. So embarrassing. >> What the [__]
I want to know.
Get Get that off the screen, man. Come on. What are you doing,
bro? Get that off the screen. Get me off the screen, man. Come
on. >> I can't I can't. That's That's wild. Hold on. There's
another clip from Kimmy's Kicker Keep that I'm going to pull
up right now since we're at a little lull here anyway. Okay.
There's another clip from Kimmy's version of Kicker Keep that
also seems kind of sus in retrospect. Wait, where are my downloads?
The hell? I can't I don't see my downloads. Hold on, I'll pull
it up. Give me a second. Give me a second.
Oh, no, Kimmy. >> Well, believe it or not, I'm very attractive.
Um, you should know that. >> Keep telling yourself that.
Keep telling yourself that. >> It's so weird that Goonar's
the one reacting to it in this case.
>> Keep telling yourself that. I mean, you should know.
>> What does that mean?
>> What? It means Maui tried to >> Bro, when you
DM'd me after you broke up in me, by the way, I didn't reply
to
>> You reached out to me. What did I say to
>> I don't know who did that edit. That's a crazy edit,
but thank you. Okay. I just >> high effort edit. Yeah,
I just had that clip kicking around today and I was like, "Oh,
that that works so perfectly now in this situation." Gooners's
reacting to it. It was wild. All right. I'm not sure. >> Begging
begging us to do another one of these events, we wouldn't do
it. >> So, Lav just said if he was going to kill himself
or something. >> I thought Kimmy was with Data. Wouldn't
put it past either of them. Actually, that's not true cuz Dam
really likes smart girls. >> Tape did it. Okay. Based God,
you are on fire, baby. You're like, there's something wrong with
you, but it's so
>> that it's actually so funny that Dam the meatthead does
like smart girls.
>> I actually really like that for him. >> They just
keep
as they go to talk and your position >> cuz we're we're
still like 30 minutes away from where she leaks the uh
>> never do something like that. >> He wouldn't.
He actually wouldn't. >> Josiah, this this is the end game
of >> Get a real job. Find a wife. >> No. No. the
endgame of like what you've been dealing with, Josiah, with the
constant scumbag. Natalie Reynolds, uh, >> another [__]
Oh boy.
>> Oh, boy. What is this? Kick notification. Hamster, thank
the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you, guys. We are
I don't even know how far we are away. We're nine, 10, five.
Uh, you know, I'm gonna add the two hours to No, no, we're two
subs away. Two subs away from another two hours on the stream.
Okay, 2 hours away. Thank you very much, hamster, for the five
gifted. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> What website
are you using? Why are there so many colors? Wait, you can win
money off of that?
>> You just click. >> Is that her Kimmy impression
or fake >> I don't know. Are they trying to say
>> She's doing like a She's doing a bit right now. I don't
get the bit. Oh, it's the Kimmy impression. Okay. >> God,
I didn't know the crash was going to last like an hour and a
half. Holy [__] Did >> someone say cat's being
so funny? >> I know.
Love you guys, chat. It's been an honor, but it's all over now.
>> And now it's Diet Coke fun.
>> Don't let mean girls and mean boys hurt me and
my family. >> Diet Coke's losers. >> And I don't
like watching mean guys with an ego do mean things to mean people
or to nice people like Shu. >> If you win the event, all
hell will break loose. Did goon make it slowmo? No, I did not.
>> We're getting close. We're getting close. We're getting
there >> to the leaks. >> So, you hurt others. Listen,
you steal from the rich, you give to the poor. Lav >> Lab
has said this like all the time. Like, if you hit me, I'm going
to nuke you as hard as I can. >> You are a mean girl. Yeah.
>> Not a good state to be in, by the way. >> Very
sweet. >> Also, Josiah, if anyone tried to bully you, I'd
have your back. Just know.
>> Look how good she is at. When you called when you called
the other night talking to or to Tim about you, I was ready to
throw hands with whoever you had beef with. Even though I was,
you know, I'm a miserable [__] But once he'll actually
>> but once you're in, but once you're in, you're in and
I'll do literally >> I will just be your pay.
>> We got another don. >> Donated $3. What you mean
getting close? I already finished. >> Okay, chill, Ruben.
Ruben, thank you for the three. Gross. Once you're in, uh, that's
what people say when they have like a tight-knit friend group
and they're saying once you're in our like family or friend group,
you're in. We'll we'll [__] with you no matter what.
No matter what you do, you're on our squad now. Okay. We [__]
with you. That's what she's saying. >> So, there's only
eight left. >> Should we go to the 41st RFID and go, can
we get We should get them to do the audience wave. >> Yeah.
There's only eight left and we have spots for two of them. >> Just
a terrible person masquerading as a >> She broke ice as
the prophecy foretold.
>> You come at the king. I I do kind of I almost feel like
there would be a Oh, Merk leaking Kimmy DMs right now. We'll
check that out Anderson. Thank you very much for the update.
Okay. Jesus. H
I got to go back. >> Just a terrible person masquerading
as a >> She broke Ice as the prophecy. >> Oh, yeah.
Sorry. I was going to say it would be so comfy to go watch Ice's
stream after that drops cuz I guarantee he's like muddling through
but in his head like everything there's like a million gears
turning in his head. Like he would be super checked out. He wouldn't
be there. It would just be like that. That would be some kind
of keynote. I don't know if I'm quite psychopathic enough to
make that funny on stream, but there'd be some kind of keynote
going on there where you could >> I see foretold.
>> You come at the >> Not the first of all, not the
first man I've taken down. Destiny's in a lawsuit because I was
completely right about what I was saying. Hassan, >> I
don't think that's quite true. I don't think that's quite true
at all. Like >> she's still coping. I I feel like I feel
like she's gonna she's gonna take a W because she basically had
an intuition about a person
possibly quite significantly from Spite and then she took her
shot and now turns out that person was also terrible. >> Your
fault. >> Try to take it out here. >> You are not.
>> We're going to get your get back, baby. >> I'm
sorry. Hassan will never get got on this. Okay. Look at Hassan
on the cover of GQ. He does not have to do this. I'm sorry.
That's like I I saw there's a thing where Ethan had like a document
where he's going to try to show how bad Hassan was. And one of
the things was Hassan like showed pictures of people to um to
a reporter like naked pictures. And I'm sitting there like, "Bro,
those are like unsolicited nudes sent to him that he clicks on
and doesn't know they're going to be there." Like, I'm sorry.
He is not the person spreading those nudes. It's that person.
That person is spreading their nudes. That person is sending
them to Hassan. And Hassan doesn't know it's there. Snapchat.
Okay. He's not going through an album. He's [__]
He's opening his
>> Yeah, he's not going to get caught on this [__]
Not in the same way. >> [__] Ice Poseidon and
his skunt. >> Oh, if Kimmy messaged Goon during January,
that was during the CX Japan trip when he was having massive
crashs over Kimmy. Dude, one of his crash over He was like that's
when he was in the car with the gun or whatever. Like he was
saying, >> was he in there with a gun? He was talking about
being in there with a gun. What did he do in that car? He like
gets out and falls over, goes and rants about her on the bed.
He was talking about himself, right? I'm positive. >> Oh,
is that what Lab was referencing when she said >> I think
that's what she was referencing. I think that's what she was
referencing. Yes. Was the Japan
>> crash out in the car. >> I don't know enough about
any of these >> He punched the windshield like
>> Yes, he punched the windshield and broke it. Dude, hold
on. I have to ice Poseidon
windshield. I don't know if Rey's ever seen this, but I would
pull it up right now if I could find. >> I haven't seen
any of it. >> It's so good. It's so good. >> It's
over. >> Ice Boseidon crashed out and punched his friends
his friend's car windshield after breaking up his girlfriend.
I'm going to kill her. >> Done. I'm going to
[__] her up. I can't [__] believe this.
He punched the windshield and broke it from the inside, dude.
He must throw a mean punch. What the You can't see the punch
get thrown. >> [__] kill her. You're going
to her up. I >> Oh, wait. He might not have punched it.
He might have thrown his phone. >> I can't [__]
believe that. >> I think he might have thrown some [__]
>> I don't care, dude. >> I don't care, bro. I got
glass in my hand. I don't care, bro. I can't. >> Who's
this?
>> That glass in my hand, man. >> This is the most
autism to ever be conjured up in a 45day period in human.
>> I need to get out of this car, man. >> Yes. Please
have when they pull over. They pull over like right here and
it's icy out. Look how icy it is. Oh crap. >> I don't know
why he can't just support me in my worst time ever. Worth the
[__] time. Real the [__] out. >> It's
overdone. >> Oh, you don't see it on his stream. On one
of these other streamers streams. Okay, that's fantastic.
Oh, this is deleted. What was it? [__] Oh, it's deleted
again. Damn it. Okay, this was bad. But when he gets out of the
car, you hear his feet go >> here. Listen, listen, listen.
>> It's over. >> You hear the You know that when
your feet slide out and they go, you do the >> Yeah. He
like falls over into the ditch. It's It's rough. Okay. It's rough.
All right. So, that this is when
this is apparently when uh or right after. No, right be right
before this would have been when Goon was getting messaged by
Kimmy. So, apparently she was uh not happy with him either. Jesus.
>> Oh, that's
ain't no way, bro. I've been through some
I mean there there's no way I'd be acting like that. That's crazy.
The only way I'd be acting like that is if like somebody shot
my brother and killed him like like a person would have to be
>> I'mma [__] kill you. Yeah. >> Yeah.
That's insane. >> I think he talked about it. I think that's
when he went up to uh I think he went up to his hotel and then
he said, "I was driving around at some point." He's talking about
like when he broke up with Kimmy or fighting with Kimmy. It's
like driving around with a gun. I'm pretty I'm almost positive
he talked about it. I'm putting in ISIS Discord right now. Does
anyone know where 42 RFID is?
>> Wait, dude. Wait, this is crazy.
>> I missed it. >> I'm putting in ISIS's Discord
right now. Does anyone know where RFID is? >> That is just
a fun thing. Oh boy. That's crazy. That's [__] up.
That's [__] up. That's [__] up.
>> Thank you. >> Thank you, bro.
>> Have a good one. >> How long before you get banned?
How long before you get banned? Oh, it I don't know if they can.
Like, they've got to save face somehow. >> My girlfriend
had sex before we met. No, buddy.
It was >> The gun was when she went to that streamer party.
Was it? Okay. >> Before they met. >> I probably had
the footage from that night, too. I've got a whole thread on
that night. So, we could possibly go see that. Did he say that
to Sam when they're in the Is that the Sam video? >> Like,
oh my god. Just get back with >> Just get back with them.
>> Like, we were we were hooking up. >> You have
You have Tim to thank, right? >> Yeah. I I told >> the
reason you guys got back together
dude this is ah this is unsatient activity man that's not right
that's not right bro
while I was your girlfriend on my mattress with no bed frame
I was talking you up bro you should thank me bro like >> I
totally told her you were a good guy while he's a cyber >> just
so you No, Paul's a nice guy. Oh >> Like, listen, we're
just here for fun right now. Could you just like go get back
with him and I'll go back to
>> No, he's actually saying it. He's actually saying the
reason you guys got back together.
>> I was like, listen, we're just here for fun right now.
Could you just like go get back with him and I'll go back to
doing what I do? Kylo Orbits Jay's talk just tipped $3.
And Lou and Kelly Jean walk into a bar. Who comes out alive?
Not Kelly Jean. She's dead to me now. Wink wink. >> Okay.
Thank you for the donation. Thank you. Thank you. >> They
just posted a picture where I look cute. What's the gag? What's
the gag? >> So funny. You are the most annoying person
in the world. >> Posting in his Discord asking where the
42nd RFID is. So funny, bro. Still making [__] up,
buddy. Billy Isish just tipped $5.
>> This is exactly why I co-signed Lav. Surprisingly, her
mouth is her filthiest
>> Jesus Christ.
Uh, thank you for the five, Billy Isish.
What the though? What the
>> Hey guys, don't donate and then [__] on
me. I can't read them. I don't know what was said, but you guys
should not donate and [__] on me >> ever. That
would be horrible. Thank you. I appreciate that. Um, somebody
just donated five bucks and said, "This is why I co-signed Lav
because somehow her mouth is her filthiest hole." Jesus
is
>> Most people actually did. He actually >> Most
people thought it was funny. That's from Discord. That's from
Discord. >> This guy's winning me over. This guy's winning
me over.
>> Yes. Key information being Billy Isish was the dono
name. Okay. and Billy Eyish did shout laugh out. That's true
>> Real facts.
[__] is that? >> I don't get it. Yeah, I don't
get it. Is this supposed This is Kimmy with a Photoshop on her
face. Oh, it's Nick White's face. Probably on Kimmy. I got >> Nick
White. Nick White. Nick White. Dude, I can't I I only know Nick
White in the context of like if he's not wearing a hoodie, I
cannot see Nick White. Okay. He has to be wearing like a hoodie,
preferably like a high viz hoodie, like an orange hoodie, a lime
green hoodie, and then it's obvious who Nick White is.
>> You all provided the best content. >> Yeah. First
of all, Ice thinks he's a chaos agent. He's never met the chaos
goddess. Okay. You think you're the Joker? I was born in darkness.
>> Hold on.
This from Ice's Discord. Kimmy cheated. Kimmy's nose job. Free
is real. Okay.
Uh I Dude, they're not filtering these things at all. Not even
a little bit.
>> Here they play my baby blue. >> We're getting
closer to the actual leaks here. It's going to be them singing
>> It's getting progressively worse. Not family teenage
beard.
>> Do you ever get depressed when you realize the man you
get stuck with is getting progressively worse? >> Yeah,
a little. >> Dude, I'm I'm sitting in which keep getting
progressively worse.
Jesus. I'll go back and we'll watch that again. Sorry, I'm I
opened Ice Boseidon's Discord and somebody threw in this uh this
copy pasta. So, I'm just going to read it real quick. I don't
know if this guy posted originally, but at you pathetic ass loser.
You're so desperate for
you. You pimp your out your wife, which is insane in itself and
pathetic. Lol. Your wife sucks off dogs and she has stronger
jaw a stronger jawline than you. your baby fat having ass.
She cheated on her previous husband with you. Lauo, you're my
guy. Tried to pick on Thanos because he was the smallest there
cuz you have zero sack in those guys in those gay ass shorts.
You homop
your girl Labs abuses dogs and looks like Michael Jackson after
the bleaching. Gunnar, you're a narcissistic clown ass and I
would spit on you IRL. Damn. Damn.
>> Wait, is it confirmed that Lab cheated on her husband
with Goonar?
Uh well, Lav and her husband had an open thing and she was with
Goonar at that time. I don't know. I don't know if she cheated.
I don't think that's necessarily confirmed. They were open, right?
I don't know. I don't know.
>> Yeah. I don't know the truth there or >> Realized
the men you get stuck with is for good. >> Oh. Uh Gunnar
had a huge fight last night that we watched a little bit of and
during that fight his he's wearing these like tiny these super
short jorts, like jean shorts, and his balls come out. His balls
are on stream. Sorry. You ever heard Have you ever wanted to
see Gunnar's balls without paying for Lav's only fans? >> Good
on that. >> Can find them there. >> It's getting
progressively worse. >> Yeah, a little bit.
>> I'm with my equal in every way. God Lucifer put both
of us on this planet and meet each other.
>> Ice turned TTS off. >> I think I >> Well,
you guys could always TTS the stream that he's watching.
>> that's true, guys. Because Ice Poseidon isn't giving
anyone money and everyone came here
>> to make money. >> You guys should TTS whoever's
watching. >> That's actually true. Like that's actually
Yeah, that definitely seems like a good idea. >> Help everybody
out for sure.
>> They are.
>> You're welcome. >> Are they the only one without
>> Okay, bro.
The recap is going to be a continuation and you will never stop
reacting to the ice events. Oh yeah. >> So you can't >> I
just $5.
>> Just found out that you can get an STD from internet.
Thanks Blab.
>> Can't hide ice. >> Might be time. >> Five
ice. Appreciate it. >> Marry your girlfriend.
If that's what you get.
>> It's happening.
>> He's throwing He's throwing that [__] $65,000
ring at Lady Bird Lake getting in his Rolls-Royce. >> He
doesn't have that yet. He's been saving money. >> Maybe
he could pawn it and then like maybe run a good event in the
future.
>> A $5,000 ring. What does he talk about? Did he Did he
propose to Kimmy?
>> Uh, I mean that seems to be what it would be saying.
I He must be He must have proposed. No. >> Nah. Anybody?
Any chatters? No. Did he propose to Kimmy? >> Maybe he
just bought her a $65,000 ring. >> It It can't be. >> If
the ring's 65K, I doesn't have to come with a proposal. Them's
the rules. Them's the breaks. >> Oh, man. >> We'll
see. We'll figure that out at some point, guys. By the way, we
hit the goal. So, thank you for the two hours on stream, guys.
Thank you for the support. >> Appreciate it. >> Not
yet.
>> Don't worry about >> Yeah, I will. I will.
>> I'll be back in a little bit. I got
>> Yeah, no worries. I wonder if this is the message she
just said. Don't read it. After this event, will I ice himself
and Kimmy?
>> Cops are killing 41. >> He called the cops on
his own. >> Okay, Accelerati, if you're here right now,
I need you to shut the up. Okay, reacting to ICE events earns
you just as much income from the comfort of your home. Shut the
[__] up. Don't tell people that. They don't know
that. They think going to these events is like really really
really really
Shut up. Let me do that and they can do whatever they want. He
was going to propose and mention the ring in the last fight they
had. I see. I see. I see. >> Somebody's
face on the shut it down me. >> That's a It's an anti-semitic
meme. Goonar, what are you doing there? What are you doing? How
do you know about that meme, Gunnar? It's an anti-semitic meme.
Not good. >> Will invite you to his >> No, Chad.
Who the >> Who the [__] is
>> What's that? What's that? What's that? Himster. Thank
for the 16 months. Friendship ended with Kelly. Now Lab is my
best friend. Many such cases.
>> No, I'm I still
>> Okay, we're so close. We're so close. We're so close.
>> I know. It's a little bit too >> Whenever she
does that, I know she just said some crazy [__] right?
When Lav When Lav covers her face, when she's like touching her
face like this, I feel like she just said some crazy [__]
>> She What? >> Can you do a sand pepper impression
when he's covering the doll tomorrow? What the [__]
Fuckon.
Wait, wait. Weren't they roommates?
They were roommates 3 years ago. She told me that he wrote her
a love letter.
Cha cha. Is this real though? Cha. >> Wait, does Gunnar
bring up the love letter first? Or was it Maybe it got mentioned
in some section we skipped, but there's Gunnar mentioning the
love letter, and I thought that Sam was just bringing it up out
of nowhere.
Some people made it sound like Sam was bringing it up out of
nowhere or Gunnar denying it. Sounds like maybe this happened.
Yeah, I know this is before Stram Sam's stream today. Yes. So,
I'm saying did Gunnar bring it up first cuz we already saw lab
talk about it before. Okay. Okay, >> chat. No, >> I
might have missed it. I skipped through a little bit of stuff.
>> Crazy cat. >> This can't be real. Chat,
she said that he wrote her love letters and was obsessed with
her. She said she never had with him. Does Paul know where did
she tell Paul? Chat, did you did he did she tell Paul? Oh my
god, chat. >> Paul, what did the love letter say? >> There
wasn't one letter. I could have pissed so bad. >> Ice still
too scared to show your
>> Brutal way to find out.
>> apparently Ice is saying he didn't know.
>> Yeah, I wonder if she told him the full truth. It's
fake. Ice confirmed.
She was my roommate for a year. It's not fake. >> We shared
a battlefield.
>> anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> Go ahead. Describe the before leoplasty.
Go ahead. See if it track. See if it tracks. I >> Jesus
Christ.
Can we get a sketch artist in here to draw this vagina I'm about
to describe? Guys, you got like different sizes of lips that
I'll describe for you. Or >> who cares? You're married.
Well, we're crashing out. >> It's like a fingerproof. >> Are
you saying you're lying about having sex with him? I wonder if
she's >> Yeah, I don't know if she told him. >> She
told him. >> That's kind of a [__] brutal way
to find out. >> You want me to release the messages?
Oh,
because if you think that she's lying. I wonder if she's deleted
them all. >> Oh, probably. >> Here it comes. This
is my next This is my next story waypoint. Okay. Is when Lav
Good. >> We've uh we've started using this as a meme template
now, guys, by the way. Here it is. Here it is. Here it is. It's
a new meme template. Okay, brand new.
Let's go. >> Yeah, I never made it significant to Paul.
I vouched for Gunner to be invited to events and things for that
reason. Paul didn't want him around, but I said he wasn't going
to tell people and that I think he's a good person and will remain
respectful. You didn't say that about me, you dumb, stupid when
you were mean to me.
I don't want drama either. Sorry that you're stressed about this.
Worried about being brought into it. I'm doing everything to
try to keep the peace. No, you. >> Luckily for us, guys,
>> the only advice I have is to not attack Sam or Paul.
They both don't really have anything to lose and don't care.
I said there's no reason for anyone. What's up, big guy? >> We
got all of these. Okay, man. >> I think Ice is watching.
>> Let's Let's check this out. Okay, let's check it out
from the top. I think is that the direction we're going in? This
is July 1st or Wait, July 1st, 4:28 9
July 1st, 4:11 p.m. Oh, this is See, they didn't go in the right
order. I see. Okay, so this is where it starts. Hey, I need to
know exactly what you told Paul about you and Tim so I can prepare
myself for if he decides to expose your and his business. Sam
Pepper is teasing releasing information and I don't want this
to be a thing. We're trying to get pregnant and it's stressing
me out and the last thing we need is CX flooding his streams.
Thoughts? Uh, I don't really want logs of this. I don't really
know if to uh this I don't really know to trust you or know you
to trust you. That makes sense. I mean, probably should say,
"Wait, what? What? Huh? I don't know. I don't even know what
you're talking about, [__]
I didn't reach out to drag anything up. I just wanted to be sure
you weren't still passively inviting chaos into something you're
no longer a part of. I'm just focused on keeping our side of
things clean. It was not significant for Tim enough significant
enough. Not significant for Tim enough to tell people.
Oh, Lav. I can tell exactly why this person doesn't like Lav.
This is why Lav Lav kind of leaves some things out sometimes.
Hey, this person who was like involved with Gunnar and reached
out to him like 6 months ago. Gunnar doesn't give a about you.
Gunnar don't care about you. Yeah, I can see why she might not
like you a little bit. A little bit. Or maybe this is after Kimmy
was rude. I don't know. I'm just focused on keeping her side
of things clean. It was not significant for Tim enough to tell
people. The roommates know and that's it. It seems as though
everyone else who knows about it knows about it from you. He
didn't respond to your message because he genuinely didn't know
what to say to you. He relayed to uh to you a lie about why you
weren't able to move in. They did not want you to move in, but
you were already uh but you were already not Oh, do we lose a
message here? So, 4:10 p.m. And then there's this one. Chat to
people about it. He forgot it even happened. So, we lose a little
bit of text there. Not think about this. He definitely doesn't
chat to people about it. He forgot it had even happened. And
when Paul was going off exposing you, I was the one who expressed
fear that he could that he could become uh involved. He was apprec
he appreciated your warmth and and vouching for him and the opportunity
he's been allowed to have despite your casual relationship. Adults
have relationships. They get lonely. I understand obviously.
We're happy and married, moved on from the past. You'll remember
I've had my fair share of public relationship drama. And don't
do relationship drama on stream. I would have nothing to share
the logs for. I just wanted to know this wasn't going to explode
in our faces. And while we have no reason to share this, we'd
never share this ever. We'd never do relationship drama on stream.
Actually, I like you could totally trust me with this. I'm I'm
definitely never share.
Uh uh-huh.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Unlucky.
I have nothing to share the logs for. I just wanted to know this
wasn't going to explode in our faces. And while I'm pregnant
on a whim of Pauls, and I'm sorry that you have to deal with
that. I imagine it's probably very excruciating to not know who
you can trust and I hope you know you deserve to feel a calm
and quiet enduring love. I have never passively invited Chaos
to something I'm not a part of. Uh I don't know why you even
say still. If he wasn't the reason I was to move I was to move
in and it was a lie that he was covering up then that's fine.
Obviously I didn't know about that and that makes sense why he
wouldn't know what to say. I've never made it significant to
Paul and I vouched for Gunnar to be invited to events and things
for that reason. He didn't want him to be he didn't want him
around, but I said how he wasn't going to tell people and that
I think he is a good person will remain respectful. Lav, I don't
want drama either. I've never tried to make someone's life harder.
I'm sorry that you're stressed about this and worried about being
brought into it. Uh I Oh, we have to go up. We have to go up.
I
am doing everything to try to keep the peace. No one is coming
after you and I'm telling you everything I know. I'm sorry if
it upsets you for me to tell you that Paul didn't like this or
that. It's Paul's feelings. I don't control them, and I'm being
open and honest. Sorry if that message seemed like I thought
you were coming after me. I felt better after reading it and
have no bad or negative feelings towards you
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. I was in the middle of
something while I wrote it and didn't want to keep you waiting.
We're totally good. It's fine. Just if you are worried about
anything going forward, the only advice I have is to not attack
Sam or Paul. They both don't really have anything to lose and
don't care. There's really no reason for anyone to be attacking
anyone. That's a That's a Lav challenge. Challenge accepted for
Lav right there. Challenge accepted.
Challenge accepted.
Don't pick off Don't piss off Ice or Paul or Ice or Sam.
Is Ice not Sam? Didn't tell him. Uh, he might be. Who knows?
I haven't seen him talk about it yet today. I didn't say there
was there was or ever would be a reason. Just telling you they
don't care. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Sorry, sorry. This
was the one. Don't attack them. There's really no reason for
anyone to be attacking anyone. Tim has no drama with either of
you or Sam or either of you or Sam and just respect and admiration
for Paul. Hopefully, this all fades into history. Wishing you
both the best. Wishing you both the best working everything out.
I didn't say there was or ever would be a reason. Just telling
you they don't care to keep secrets or care about people's feelings
like I do. I agree. Hope it all fades into history as well. I
wish the same for you. Uh well, now these now these logs are
up on streams everywhere all across the world. Unfortunate. unlock
right now. >> Terrible. I don't know if she leaks more.
And I don't know if somebody else put this out. Oh, missed one.
Missed one. What? At the start or at the end. Did I actually
missed one? Oh. Oh, this is new. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This
is new. So, we'll pull we'll pull this one up. Yeah. And I told
you I wouldn't weaponize that against you. This is from 2023.
I won't leak anything. You You just have to be careful who you
tell about stuff because you have a tendency to tattle on yourself.
Yeah, I know I tattled to Sam just now when I pressed him because
of that clip and really didn't know and now he does but I guess
I don't care. I guess I wanted to know why he'd do that and Sam
won't say anything. He's my friend. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Where was the kick or keep episode? Where
was the kick or keep episode? Kick or keep? Was this Was this
what? September 13th, 2023. Okay. September 13th, 2023. And then
when we go back to this guy right here, this is September 11th.
Wait, it's before. It's before.
Oh, maybe. Hold on. It would have taken it would have taken these
guys a few days to put it out, right? It would have taken Karanto's
channel a few days to put it out. Dude, 911 of their relationship
when when Sam mentions this on stream, but that's what she's
referencing would be the Kicker Keep episode. And Sam won't say
anything. He's my friend and his girlfriend is my friend. I know
all about his relationship stuff. He wouldn't go do that. But
point is, yeah, I was confused and hurt. I just felt wronged
and hurt. So, I wanted to tell you that again. Please don't say
anything. I feel really vulnerable and I wish I didn't care,
but it's different being a blank woman. I understand. Never going
to do something. I'd say, dude, Gunnar held this in the whole
time. Gunnar held it in the whole time. You never said and then
now it's all now it's all coming out. >> Actually, she
she first she cracked the [__] out on me and then
before I was able to screenshot it, she said, "I don't really
want logs of this. I don't really know to trust you. Probably
actually she she first she >> Oh, there's some stuff up
there. I don't think she crashed out. I don't really want logs
of this stuff. Don't know if I can trust you. I don't see where
she crashed out on you. Unless it's these ones up here. These
ones aren't in any album that I've seen >> out on me. And
then before I was able to screenshot it, she said, "I don't really
want logs of this. I don't really know to trust you." >> She
deleted it. I see. >> Probably good idea. >> Probably
should have all that in >> cuz that was the psycho one.
cuz that was the psycho message where you blame me for Tin not
texting you and you were saying that we were making fun of you
for your bad nose job. >> People
Oh, the nose job. That's going to come up. People always do this
though. People who really know how to do drama, they're like,
"Oh, like I'm going to I'm going to do never if you're if you're
really, you know, with people, it's never better than 80% true,
20% false, right? You'll sprinkle in you'll sprinkle in all of
the lies in between everything, right?
every time. So, she says there's a message there. We'll never
know, but like now you you could never know, right? And she's
saying a bunch of other things that are true that she's confirming
with other logs. And so, she sprinkles that in and >> which
like we weren't doing publicly
back, but >> we were trying to be nice. >> I refrained
from talking.
>> We couldn't control
because he's not ours to control. Just because he's black doesn't
mean we control him, Kimmy.
He's his own person.
>> You if you don't want it getting out, you have to be
careful. I mean, it's not a big deal. >> More messages
here. It's more of the messages. Hello. Who this really again?
All right. >> It's Kelly Jean.
>> It's Kelly
is a big deal. You said you realize you pressing him about me
would insinuate we have a history. You got >> We just read
these. If you want to read them yourself, I'll just send them
to you. We read these guys. >> What the [__]
Just TLDDR. TLDDR. I ain't reading that [__] >> It's
just confirming that it happened and and both of them being like,
I don't want drama. I don't want drama. Although in the middle
in the middle, um, hold on. Actually, did I pull that off screen
here? Just give me a second. Go to this guy. Load up. Load up.
Load up. Load up. Oh, they're both the same thing. Okay. Whoops.
Okay. In the middle of this lab does go. Um, sorry if that message
blah blah blah blah blah. And somewhere in here, she's like,
I won't leak anything. Obviously, no reason for anyone to be
attacked anymore. Wait, why why were they messaging about this
a month ago?
>> Um, because a month ago Paul was crashing the out and
I think Sam Pepper probably referenced it again on this stream.
I'm guessing he referenced it somewhere in here because because
Sam Pepper knew about it because Sam Pepper knew about it here,
right? And we got another DM which is
Nope. Wait, to be clear, the only thing they're talking about
is Goar Guimmy, right? That's it. >> Yeah. Yeah. Bro, who
cares? Who? It's really not this big of a deal like to be like,
"Oh, yeah. Let's, you know, let's not let's not leak it." I mean,
it's unless are they is she hiding it from Ice? Is that what
she's doing? >> Uh, well, I think she didn't tell Ice the
extent of it was what she said. So, I don't know what that means
exactly. >> The extent of it? What the does that mean?
Were they like three times daily like for months or something?
Like, what does it even mean? Extent of it. >> This I don't
know exactly. Okay. The extent of like Yeah. Whether they were
friends or whether they hooked up once or if they consistently,
I have no idea, but apparently she Ice talks about it and can't
say much more without spoiling. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. We We'll get
to the ice stuff in just a second. We're about to go to the ice
stream. Okay. >> We're about to go to the ice stream. Um
but this is a message from Gunnar. Um and this is just Kimmy
being like, "Please don't tell anybody about this. Please, please,
please." And Gunnar's like, "Yeah, I won't tell anybody, but
you kind of tell a lot of people." And it it's kind of [__]
up. So funny that Goonar kept it to himself for all that time.
Never said anything. Never tried to do a power play of any kind.
And then Lav shows up and Lav is like, "Ah, yeah. Well, my boyfriend
your girlfriend." You want to see the logs Lav is holding up?
We already went through all the logs on stream. We went through
all them. I just had an album. Did you miss it? Did you miss
it? We just went through all the logs through in an album in
an Imager album. We went through all of them. If there's more
there with Sam, we'll get to it cuz we're going to go through
this AMP stream as well. We're covering all of it, guys. We need
the whole story. whole story has to come through. >> Got
to learn to just let go and blow it off. She said, "Yeah, I know,
but Sam is my friend and so I would rather press him for doing
that because why? He proved that he really didn't know." And
said, "Yeah, and I told you I wouldn't weaponize that against
you until you were mean to my wife.
I wouldn't leak anything. Just be careful who you tell about
stuff because you have a tendency to tattle on yourself." Kimmy
said, "Yeah, I know. >> There's definitely way more DMs
here that we haven't seen. I could go stabilize and reverse these."
I titled go uh go Sam just now when I pressed her because that
clip and he didn't Sam probably has them all >> just repeat
just unintelligible writing because she literally is like >> yeah
I know that's I know that's I know that's Gonar's phone now yes
>> like actually was dropping >> pulled up one of
the screenshots
>> um I just felt wronged and hurt so >> okay I'll
grab all of them from Sam's stream in just a second uh here's
the clip yeah you know what we'll do it right now that's a that's
a good call it down thank you very much that's a good call let's
let's check this out real >> really vulnerable and I wish
I didn't care but it's different being a gal. I understand I'm
never going to do something that hurts you intentionally. Okay,
thank you. Has anyone asked you or messaged you or does anyone
know? No one has said anything and no one know. >> This
is, by the way, this is right after the stream here. This is
right after this stream.
>> She saw this stream. She saw some clip from this stream
and was freaking out cuz Sam was memeing about it. >> Oh,
except from the people you tell laugh my ass.
Life is hard when you're a It's fine. Just pull and sand 2023.
That's what I'm trying to tell you guys. Like I've known about
this Nick Y and Jamie and this bro. You know how you know me
drama king. I'm trying to hold this
whole entire time like silently.
What? I hate Goona. I hate Goona. He talks so much [__]
to me and I have so much dirt on him. So much dirt. >> Is
that D is that dirt on him? >> I feel like Gar is just
going to grow massively from this. >> Yeah, I was I was
going to say, oh man, he he [__] this this other
guy's girlfriend. Wow, bro. That's that's crazy, bro. That's
some crazy dirt.
>> I mean, I'm just >> I also have no idea why like
certain people they just Maybe I can't throw the first stone
on this. Okay, maybe I can't throw the first stone on this, but
I don't know how you trust Sam Pepper. That seems crazy. holding
it in silently. Every time that Kim me off, I'm sitting there
like, "Got to be a good friend, Sam. Got to be a good friend.
Don't don't break, you know, don't break." >> Okay, we're
going to we're going to cover this stuff in a little bit. All
right, I think we're basically done with >> Please don't
say anything. I feel really vulnerable and I wish I didn't care,
but it's different being a girl.
>> Stop [__] being mean. Stop being mean and
people won't do that. >> Kimberly, you see that? Kimberly.
>> Oh, she's verifying that she actually has the DMs here.
>> Such a crash. I love you so much. >> I'm seeing
people being like, "Lap, blah >> His chat is going crazy.
Let's watch. >> Oh, dude. Watching him try to maintain
mental discipline as his whole chat is like telling him to go
watch this. Go check it out. Like, go. Dude, that is I totally
understand crashing out in that case. Okay. When people come
to me when I'm like covering something, dude, it's like way worse
for Ice, too. You spent so much money to organize this event
and get everybody there and get all the RFIDs planted and then
everybody's like, "Bro, go watch these people. They're like leaking
your relationship drama on stream." It's like, I will I just
ban all of them. Just ban them all. Get them out. [__]
riff raff, dude. >> It's backwards. Screenshot it.
Did she have abortions?
>> That one isn't a story for us to tell. I am a feminist
first and foremost.
>> That's true. That is true. Lab is a known feminist.
Known feminist. Known feminist. Yep. >> Known feminist.
Yes.
>> Absolutely a feminist. Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> He's watching your screen on the second monitor instead
of the I wonder if she lied to him. >> I know. That would
suck so bad. >> That would suck so bad. >> That would
suck really bad if she >> honestly Paul I'm rooting for
you. >> In that case. >> You're welcome. >> Yeah.
In that case, you're welcome. >> In that case, you are
very welcome. >> Look through her messages with Zirka,
with Isha.
>> Who will know right off the bat? >> She was my
moderators, dude. Absolutely, >> dude. Okay, if Zirka knew
this, if Zirka did Kimmy, there's no way that he doesn't say
it, right? Cuz if you don't remember, I believe Zirka had a massive
crash out on Ice Boseidon cuz Ice Boseidon had his girlfriend.
What? Oh, her name wasn't Kim. It was What was Zurka's girlfriend's
name? >> Starts with Jay, right? Oh, what? What was it?
Jill. Jill, right?
>> She was over with Ice Beside and she started selfharming.
Yes. Miss PB and Jay. Yes, she started self harming in Ice Pesidon's
bathroom and apparently Ice Poseidon just walked away. He was
like, "Oh, I don't know what to do here." And he just left his
hotel and Zurka was like losing it on him. I feel like if Zerka
his girlfriend at that point, he probably would have just said
>> I think Zurka would have said anything. That's kind
of
>> Yeah. Yeah. He was He's not happy.
>> while she was you while Dude, >> dude. Brutal.
>> I'm so While she wasing what? >> While she was
her, she these other people apparently is what Lab's saying.
Oh Jesus. >> How does Lav go from having a music career
hang out with Paris Jackson and getting hyped by Billy Isish
to doing and chasing clout with Ice Poseidon? Uh her music career
wasn't massive to begin with and it was like she had a falling
out with Billy Eyish. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. She's
been doing like drama for like most of her adult life. Like different
kinds of drama, right? Tik Tok or being on streams. She and then
Only Fans. She did Only Fans also the whole time as far as I
know. Like while she was doing music, she was doing Only Fans,
right? Like I don't I don't think Only Fans was ever not a part
of her thing. Anyway, >> sorry that I was married when
we met. >> I know. >> So sorry the that you had to
go through. >> So let's get this 40 second RFID, guys.
Come on. Lock in. >> And you're getting a call. It's Eddie.
>> All right. You there with the ladder. >> All right.
Cool. Bye. >> See you. >> Adriana chicken calling
them. Apparently, we're just supposed to watch the outro and
then we'll go to the ice besiden stream. Okay, guys. >> No,
you were asking those sisters. I'm saying if you stop lying people.
>> Hold on. Do we do the ice stream next or the Nick stream?
We probably go to the ice stream next, right? Yeah, I think we
go to the ice stream next. We'll go to the ice stream and then
we'll watch Lav on Nick stream as well. >> If you get if
you go to get help for your lying problem. I need help with the
>> I need help with the dishes. I need help with the laundry.
I need help with the >> Come on, bro. >> I will teach
you how to do all of my stream. We're good. do have to put him
>> in the discord. He's notable. Yeah, Cosmo is not really
working very hard. >> Yeah. I get the though, you can lick
his >> Oh my god. >> You're the designated salad
tosser. >> Oh my god. You baby, you are [__]
>> You're insane. Did you read chaos theory? Like >> I
think I think I'm the >> any one of her streams right now.
>> On fire and you're >> bar I've ever heard.
>> Anonymous just hit $3. Looking at a fly cleaning itself
is the craziest bar I've ever heard. Your wife is cooking like
crazy. My wife and I are loving this. Thank you. >> You're
welcome.
>> Lav Lav is literally fantastic at talking [__]
I don't know if you guys remember when Spinboy came in and tried
to shock her and she just started calling him like Randall from
recess and mocking him the whole time and he like fell apart.
That's like one of my favorite streams was Spinboy is like this
guy who bullies everybody and he comes in, he's like the biggest
bully of like the entire DG Discord universe. Every He is the
top Discord queen of all Discord queens and he comes into stream
and gets totally mogged by Lav.
It was a It was a rough one. That was a rough >> You are
you're like you're on fire and you're evil. >> I'm a notur.
She is Watch Go back to any one of her streams right now. It's
like watching a fly clean itself. Occasionally, she'll like I
mean occasional. More than occasion. >> Vincent Galla respectctor
just tipped
>> Thank you. >> You two need Jesus. Isn't there
a river nearby? You can get baptized in. >> Yeah, I just
crashing out. I said he's going to destroy you. >> First
thing, you bring that point up. Uh I heard Destiny make that
exact same point in his stream today. Um
yeah. Wait, the spin boy thing or something else? Just that she's
good at talk. Is that real? Hold on. Wait. >> Oh, sorry.
Something else. >> There's no way. >> I can't see
quotes in here. So, if you're quoting people in the chat,
>> you all these events. >> Yeah, sorry. I should
have pointed that out that the Uncle Nick guy was just repeating
a Destiny talking point or whatever. Yeah, I should have pointed
that out. Good call. Good call. >> I was like, "No, I think
he's funny. I don't really see the wrong here." >> If not,
we'll just combine forces. But
>> her character >> Oh, they're back to watching
him. >> My character >> has been shown to be absolutely
>> You're welcome. >> I know. I >> Wait, did
I spec
attempt to pearl
>> I think your character is just so disgusting. I mean,
it's just been shown as so
I'm just >> Yeah, now that you pointed out, that's Ice
Boseidon saying that. That is Ice
>> we haven't watched it, but like you could just go watch
this stream at some point. We'll watch it. It's in the backlog,
guys. It will make it at some point. It's like 20 minutes. It's
very good. Okay. At some point, we'll watch it. And yeah, that's
the guy who like starts relationship drama. He starts relationship
drama with Kimmy from the stream cuz she's like, I just want
to have a nice Thanksgiving. You have to instigate like this.
Uh, we didn't watch it a few nights ago. We will watch it eventually.
You have to
be accept
>> because instead of messaging me
>> you've tried to clown me on stream. >> We thought
you knew. >> We did think you knew. >> We thought
you knew. I asked Kimmy if you knew and she said yes. >> Yeah,
Kimmy. I was under the impression. >> She said she told
me she told me that she told you everything. >> Yeah. So,
the problem you >> No. No. No. Well, wait.
I don't know what she told Lab. She definitely told Gunnar that
she didn't tell him everything that it was like I didn't tell
him the extent of it, which I don't even know what that means.
>> That's what she told Goonar.
>> That's what That's what Kimmy told Goonar was like,
I didn't tell Paul the extent of it, but he knows a little bit
or something, which I don't even know what that means. It's like,
did she get >> Yeah. What does that mean? >> She
get like DPD by Gunnar and a friend or something and just like
I didn't tell him how crazy we went. I didn't tell him how crazy
we went, but >> Okay, that's crazy. I was just saying maybe
she like asked him to be her boyfriend or something, [__]
Damn.
>> Uh maybe. I don't know, man. >> I was with Kimmy
>> and we thought that you were trying to bully
and then Kimmy said to me she he could leak anything. Just don't
bully him. We were getting ahead of it. She literally to me said,
>> "You are not getting ahead of it. Come on." Lab was
angry. Lab saw red and Lab started doing what Lab does sometimes,
which is she goes nuclear. Okay.
She just goes nuclear out of nowhere. >> She crashed out.
I could believe that they might have thought that that she knew
or sorry that Ice knew the extent of it. I could see that as
believable. >> Um she just Yeah. She But she just wanted
to make fun of him in public and that's what happened. >> Yeah.
But her whole thing right there where she was like, "Actually,
you know, I was just trying to get ahead of it. I wasn't trying
to say anything crazy." It's like, "No, you weren't. >> You
were. >> You knew. You know what you were doing. You know,
>> uh, I don't want drama. Sorry that you're stressed about
this. I'm worried about being brought into it. I'm doing everything
I can to get the peace. No one's coming after you. I'm telling
you everything I know. Sorry, it's no drama into your >> your
life." >> Probably. Yeah. She was bragging about how you
were going to get her like a $60,000 ring to her friends. Do
not do that now. Holy [__] We fully thought that
you knew. Like, actually, >> damage control. It's not even
damage control. It's just us being real. >> It's coming
off as damage control. It's It's given a bit of damage to try.
Like, let's Come on.
>> No, man. We We really care. Yeah, we care. We care.
What? No, we were just trying to get out of it. >> Yeah.
And like, nobody wants to admit it. Nobody will ever admit it.
But the thing that's actually the damage is when this gets out
publicly, right? Like him knowing personally, he can probably
tank that knowing personally, right? But him having to get mocked
with it every single day of every single stream for like the
next month, that's what he's going to have a hard time dealing
with. That's where the damage actually comes. So they can say
like, "Oh yeah, we we thought you knew. We thought you did."
Yeah, he's not because he doesn't know. He's picked because now
his entire chat is calling him a cuck and he has to deal with
that for the rest of like I don't know the next month. Probably
she deserves that 60k ring in alimony after that brutal dping.
Jesus Christ. Why would you say that? >> Was it that Kimmy
had told because I asked because I literally asked. >> Yeah.
I thought that Ice Beside knew when I was at the Hunger Games.
I thought Ice Beside knew when I was at the rat race. Like it
was completely >> Yeah. I even was like I don't even I
I was like did you make it significant? Did you make it feel
like you like did you say that like he was in love with you or
obsessed with you or something? And she said I never made it
significant to Paul I vouched for dinner to be invited to events
and things for that reason. He didn't want him around.
But I said how he wasn't going to tell people and that I think
he's a good person and will remain respectful. Is that real?
Cuz Ice just >> something like on a mattress. No, no, no.
was on a mattress with no furniture, implying that yes, she's
like uh cheap like Yeah. Yeah. They they rubbed it in. They salted
the wound. >> They salted the wound for sure. >> But
when he said I her on a budget, that's Oh,
god damn. >> That's a pretty wild thing to say. It's a
pretty wild thing to say is all I'm >> I don't know who's
in damage. >> Yeah. I don't know who's I don't know who's
lying to who at this point. >> But there you have it, guys.
You're welcome. ladder death.
>> They pulled their pulled their truck under it. >> That's
crazy.
>> Anything. Damn, what a mess. >> I can tell there's
a damage control. I could tell that's what's happening. >> Yeah,
I mean it's it's definitely what's happening. Yeah, >> he
didn't like you
not to invite you to Hunger Games and Ice told Kimmy he likes
you and you're funny. Makes sense, dude. >> Brutal.
Brutal. >> Who is lying? >> Yeah, I don't know. >> Yo,
let's talk about if Kiby's lying. never told Ice. Ice didn't
want to have Gunnar at these events. She was like, "No, he's
a cool guy. Let's have him there." After she did,
my god, >> that would [__] with
that would uh it would not be great. It would not be great.
>> Uh yeah, that's uh >> that might be the end. >> All
right. Well, guys, this probably my last KP stream before it
nukes to a dollar, so might as well still stay live for another
>> Did that happen to people? People lost their Dude, I've
never seen anything like that. I've never had anything happen
like that. My KCIP is fine. Like I It's weird that they're like
talking about how it can get nuked down. I don't know. What do
you have to do to get a nuke down? >> Say something bad
about Eddie right now. >> Uh Eddie is from Australia.
>> Say goodbye. >> Say goodbye, buddy. >> I'm
fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. Uh kick. Sorry,
not kick. Steak takes advantage of mentally ill people. People
pro uh prone to addictive behaviors in a worse way than basically
any other product in the world. You're like ruining a bunch of
people's lives. You've built a throne ruining people's
>> You know, I'll I'll take like a 0.00001%
of that. So, thank you for I guess I I don't know. Ice claims
it was Kimmy that didn't want Gunnar around, not Ice. Ice claims
he liked Gunnar and stuck up for his KCIP. That's what I thought
I heard, too. But
>> We'll see. We'll get to the ice stream. >> I'll
pee in >> just a little bit. >> Parking lot somewhere.
>> I was also ordering food there for a quick second. I
got it now. Would there be something wrong? Holy [__]
>> Brutal time to happen. >> I wish I would have
I wish I would have kept the screenshot of her crashing out at
me before she said, >> "Yeah, she was crashing out on you
and then deleting the messages." >> Yeah, she literally
did. And I There's proof of that. Hold on. And then she also
texted cute bot. >> Ricochet, you're taking some time off.
Now you're taking some time off,
>> Totally manipulatively trying to make it seem like I
crashed out on her for no reason, even though she crashed out
at me. And then Kupa was like, "It was so unnecessary for Lav
to talk to her like >> Yeah, exactly. >> When Kimmy
was the one who was weird to me first. >> She was doing
the weird political. >> Now she was trying to like Dude,
it's so weird. She obviously was probably so scared like >> I
mean it makes sense like when you she lied so much. Yeah, I definitely
do >> Yeah, she did after this. She was like thoughts and
then said I don't really want logs of this. I don't really know
to trust you. In between that, like right here is when she crashed
out at me. Deleted the whole message. It was huge. Lawsuit incoming
for what? What lawsuit? I'm suing you for my >> Yeah. 3
years ago. Well, >> okay. We're getting forward. Apparently,
I was supposed to go until they started listening to >> Yeah,
they start
This is the last thing we're going to watch from this stream.
>> No way. This is >> How many times do you have
to win? Like, how many times do you have to win today? Stop.
Stop.
Everybody knows, right? >> Everybody knows.
>> Everybody knows what the song.
>> Wait, you know the song, right? >> I
I don't think so. What is it? >> This is uh Kim by Eminem.
Do you you don't know the song? Just listen. >> Daddy's
so proud of you. >> Sit down, [__] I'll beat
the [__] out of you. Don't make me wake this baby.
She don't need to see what I'm about to
You just leave me alone.
Am I too loud for you? Too bad.
>> Oh my god.
>> You want to throw me out? That's fine. But
my
mind
is mine. You let him sleep in our bed. Look at you. Look at your
husband now. My dad, look at him. He ain't so high now, is he?
>> Why are you doing this? >> Shut the [__]
up.
>> It's really cringe. >> Come on. >> It's
not cringe. It's pretty funny. Okay. It's pretty funny.
>> Is this a song about getting cooked?
>> Yes. Well, I think his wife leaving him for someone
else. Yeah.
>> And we don't have
without him to [__] You did him. So I don't want
to go on
without KC
without you.
>> It's been really great, guys.
>> I guess we're poor now. We'll just have to go back to
loving each other in the trailer park. Each other being
>> uh Gunnar has a lot of money and like his family owns
a landscaping company that he'll always be able to work at. They
have no financial insecurity >> Honest with each other,
>> having babies and >> holy [__] >> being
in love. >> Zane cringe. I think it's funny. I think it's
funny to think of this on the fly. You guys aren't streamers,
okay? It's funny to just think of things on the fly and roll
with them. Okay. Well,
>> that might have been the greatest ending stream of anybody's
career. >> Yeah. So, retirement incoming. >> Well,
okay. All right. That's it for these guys. They're done. We now
have the Ice stream coming up. Okay. We're ready to go with that.
Okay. We got Ice and Nick, but I think we're just going to go
straight to Ice, right? Yes. Ice. And then we'll do Nick after
because Lav goes on Nick's stream, talks to him as well. How
much money do you think Ice has spent on Kimmy so far? I don't
know. Probably the same amount most same percentage most people
spend on their partners. I would guess. I would guess. I would
guess.
Okay. Ice gets a TTS that breaks him at the end of his stream.
Okay. Takes the next 40 minutes just talking [__]
the whole time. >> You are pathetic. >> Nickly. Yes.
>> Good one.
>> You are You are pathetic. You are pathetic. You are
you are pathetic. >> Oh, hold on. >> Good one. >> No,
that's a bad time stamp. That's a That's a bad time stamp. 9
hours 20. 9 hours 20. Got to go to that. We didn't get the whole
We didn't get the whole TTS there. >> Get your big ass
face out the way. >> Oh, true, true, true. I forgot I moved
this all back. I go like go like this. Like this. Like this.
What's redo? Oh, I can't redo. [__]
Moving myself up over here. Boom. Little penguin. Move chat over
here. Black box away. Okay, there we go. I hope they all have
suction cup gloves. >> That's not it. Could be the wrong
>> Anonymous tip $3.33.
Never forget Ice took Kimmy back after Goona pounded her with
his 9 ino. Dude, you are pathetic.
>> Good one.
>> No, that's better now.
>> They're losing.
>> And they have to go after my girlfriend who is not involved
with this at all, >> dude.
Okay. Ice,
you can't. You're He's the only person who can't. He's the only
person who can't ever do this. Like, it's just him. He's like
at the top of that mountain. >> You're gonna moralize over
this. No, they're just going after my girlfriend. Trust me, that
makes total sense for everybody else. Everybody else can say
that. They can make that excuse cuz they don't do that generally,
right? But Ice is the only one who >> the other side of
what?
>> Like the actual other side of this Captain Bllandon
tipped $3.33.
Did Kimmy really do go on a bathroom floor while she was dating
Ice? >> That's crazy.
>> This is, by the way, this is the damage. This is what
everybody This is what nobody wants. Ice ruined this event. He
He keeps giving hints,
dude. His whole chat's going to be like this. Mer true.
was easy. I could be wrong, though.
>> Call Kim. She's crying.
Uh,
>> why would they think that I'd put it? Oh, no. Oh. Oh,
wait. Yeah, that I mean it's I mean they're what they're doing
is a bit suspicious. >> Maybe it's this side. >> Why
would they think that I'm putting an RFID where a previous one
is? This is very close to where the other RFID is.
>> Yeah, that's a previous one. I >> [__]
There he had it. >> Help quickly, please. And he's like,
you can also scan. Unfortunately for you
>> always
a little bit of people who are helping him. >> Yeah, but
he's asking them to help quickly, please. And he's like, I feel
>> You should play the clip from Japan. Send me that clip,
McBoots. Send me that clip right now. >> It sounds like
a dying dog.
>> that's what you get for playing dirty. >> Oh,
is way up there. >> By the way, you uh you said that I
scanned for Mioi. Not one time have I ever scanned for her. We
found the second RFID, which nobody
>> even touched or saw. >> And we waited there for
[__] 20
>> Well, that is >> the way. >> Oh, he wasn't
talking about it here. >> He apparently rants about it
for like the last hour of the stream, but I haven't seen anything
else yet.
>> Yes, at least for >> See if he says anything else
here. >> Well, maybe nobody has it yet. I thought the riddle
would be easy. Kim you Kim you Kim you kill goon How does Ice
not know about Kimmy and Goon? Kim got gooned out. Imagine making
fun of people who helped you. What happens if Gooner wins now?
Kimmy has a lot to explain to you, Mr. Ice. Goon crying.
>> It's like all of his chat. It's like the whole thing.
>> Uh Goon crying him. They leaked the text. Goon and his
wife. What the [__] Why? Why? Uh wow. Do people try
to hurt others? Why? That is enough. Really? Stop. Oh, people
just saying like, "Stop. Ice. I love you. I feel sorry for you."
Goon leak. Kimmy texts.
Uh,
>> R. Brew. It's up. >> Can this thing cuz that's
Mochi's
>> Goon leaking hard. >> Go to the birthday party.
>> I mean, I guess it's possible, but I really doubt that.
It's pretty unlikely. I don't even think they're going to be
able to be able I don't think I don't think they're going to
be able to scan the RFID for this one anytime soon if I'm being
honest. Unless they're very
>> Oh, did you send it? Nice. Yes, that >> He says
he doubts.
>> He doubts it's gonna end before 18. >> Hold on.
We're about to add a new emote.
Will we have We got an emote coming in. >> He says that
this >> Keep skipping forward. >> Still looking around.
Eventually, he gets broken on this. So,
>> we'll see where or when it happens. I think there's
like sporadic commentary, but it might be short enough that I
>> You're on the right track, but it
>> donating. Come on, dude. What are we doing here?
>> The The real thing, the real tragedy here is how has
nobody donated more talk? You know that you'll break him. You
know that he'll start talking about it if you just keep donating.
>> Said stand here. Look up. The clue says >> Wait,
no. I I watched him commenting on it already.
They just did. Ice turned his TTS off.
No, we we watched the talk. That's where the time stamp was.
>> Captain Blandon tipped $420.
This one. It's not a very good threat. Guon has been streaming
like one. >> I don't care, dude. But thank you for the
donation. >> Oh, wait. Gary Gary David needed it for him.
No, no, no. Yeah, Gary David needed it for him. >> Oh my
god.
>> What up, bro? >> That's crazy.
>> Yo, lick his balls next, homie. Lick his balls next.
>> That's wild.
Here, hold on. I added the lav smug. Yeah, I added the We got
the Lav Smug in the chat now, guys. >> No, you told me
it wasn't on the >> Just in case you need to spam that.
>> Oh, you're crazy. >> Chase talk Lav Smug. >> Well,
Goon's KC VIP was about $1 for a very long time before Hunger
Games. I hope he enjoyed those $1 days. >> Uh, so he's
going to send it back to the $1 days.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, >> Yo, come here. He said
to stand at this >> Gary is 39 and not about that drama.
He's an IRL streamer. If you're an IRL streamer, you do drama.
I'm sorry. That's just facts. >> He said, "Stand on this
corner and look >> Oh, wait. The [__] light
pulled off >> and I think it's on the highway. He said,
"Stand here. Look up." And I think it's there. >> And the
clue says directly in front of the front door. >> That
door. >> It says point
>> at some point here. He actually gets back to
>> Oh, that's not that's not going to be long enough. Maybe
if you have a selfie
>> This can't be.
>> Dude, is that Tazo? Tazo is going all out to win this,
dude. That's crazy. >> He got it. Impressive. Impressive.
>> Oh, no. It's Florida boy. It's Florida boy MMA. Never
mind. >> Going to be a real big for everyone else to get.
Just cool down.
>> That's going to be a real big for >> Is that before
or after? That must be after got in that fight.
>> That's crazy. >> I don't know how they're all
going to scan this. They're they're going to have to go one at
a time.
>> Last 10 minutes, someone says. >> Okay, we'll
skip I'll scan through a little more aggressively here.
>> Scanning. I'm checking the list and it's not changing.
if he opens their stream again. >> Doesn't look like he
opens their stream
>> Hey, we get priority though. I'll give
>> events. Immed
to know. >> Okay. Here we go. Here we go. Here we >> Here
we go. >> Here it is. No, no, no. Here it is. >> Together.
No joke.
>> I got told the whole last hour he talked, but there
just wasn't very much there. Okay.
>> Give me your self stick.
>> We have 20 minutes, right? You know, Goon is kind of
the bad guy here, though, too. I just want Goon to know >> that
I fought for him in terms of bringing him to events and bringing
him to everything. Kimberly
was always like, "Don't bring him. I don't like him." And I was
like, "Well, whatever. I think he's funny. So, I always brought
you to the events. I always invited you to places. And you want
to try and me
This doesn't make him look better. This doesn't make Ice look
better. Maybe it would make him look better to like
normal people, but to his audience, he looks like way worse.
So, you fought for some dude who caught you. >> Cool. You
have the egg on your face. You fought for some dude who your
girlfriend >> and realistically it should just be like,
is the guy good content? And at every one of's events that I've
seen, Gunnar is one of the primary people driving the content.
at Hunger Games. He was the hardest worker who wasn't like somebody
who's already a major like ice lieutenant who's like a massive
ice orbiter, right? Like I I He was super Yeah, he was like super
nice to these or sorry, he was super nice to everybody else and
Gunnar was kind of on the outside, but Gunnar was always bringing
content.
Yeah. So, I don't know. I think you got you got to respect it.
>> Going to do my two together. I think I >> And
yeah, you don't look better just cuz you cuz you didn't let he
didn't let Kimmy cut him off from events >> But it's okay.
You showed me that Kimberly is not the girl for me, >> but
you also showed me your true character with your wife. >> So,
I will make sure to make it my mission in life
to now destroy everything that you and Lab have ever >> How
did How does he not feel like a doing this? You just learned
your girlfriend was letting him hit, as he said it, on a budget,
bro. eloquently put. And then your big idea, your big master
plan here is to sh on them.
Like, nah, man. I feel this makes him look so much worse to make
like, bro,
no. It's like, I'm going to [__] on you because you
my girlfriend. What the hell the is this? This exactly like those
dudes who like fight their girlfriend. Why the [__]
are you doing that? >> That make no sense, bro. Oh, I feel
this sometimes, buddy. I'll be going live tomorrow. I haven't
slept yet and I'm very tired, so don't worry. Damn.
Damn. Ice not going live tonight, guys.
That's a rough one. We got to understand it, though. Man, man
who threatens to girlfriend monthly pro clutching about cander.
Well, yeah, he he can't pro clutch. I haven't seen him talk about
his girlfriend all the time, but I've seen him do it at least
once, and that's a lot. Okay, that is more than most people do
it. Apparently, somebody asked me to pull this up.
This is Paul sitting under one of his emo bowie moments about
Kimmy. Apparently,
he's in Tokyo. He's just chilling. It's not Darius. It is Ice
Beside. It's been on for a week. Dude, I didn't know. I didn't
know where Darius got his inspiration from. Now I know.
So, so dark and serious. What is he thinking? I just want to
I just keep mad possibly be on his mind. So, >> how long
does he sit here for?
>> These like emo crash out like manifestation tracks.
I don't even know like words of affirmation for somebody who's
just lost their their partner. >> I don't even know. >> Yes,
apparently it is.
>> He was completely mute for the entire day. No way. Oh,
he is just sitting here.
Dude, what? Hold on. I'll zoom in so I can scan. He like finds
his way here and then he's sitting here.
Sitting. Sitting. Sitting.
Goes to sit somewhere else. Oh, that's He is literally sitting
in the sprinkler as we speak, isn't he? >> Or is he not?
He was before.
>> Maybe he is after. Oh, he rolls up here. I see. >> Is
this because of his girlfriend? >> So cold. >> Yes.
Oh, he just spoke so cold and he >> I don't think I've
ever been this up over relationship, >> dude. He's just
sitting here the whole time. Have a good one, Cyber Drifter.
Thanks for showing up tonight. We'll see you later, dude. Just
the whole time. That's crazy stuff. >> And as for Kimberly,
well,
>> I mean, I don't care what she does. Oh, >> my
bad. >> I just want her to go home and never see me again.
>> I mean, if that were true that you just don't care what
she does, I feel like none of this would be happening. He's probably
doing this in Austin right now instead of streaming it. I messaged
people to get you off the $1 KCIP.
I brought you to all these events. >> I think so. >> I
was like, "No, I think he's funny. I don't really see the problem
here." >> Hey, look. I mean, he is funny. Like, guilty.
Guilty.
>> But also, if you knew everything and you didn't care,
then why is it a problem now? What? What hap? You knew all of
this. Like, it's just I I mean, I know why it's a problem, but
he can't make it seem like he doesn't care. It doesn't bother
him cuz now he's upset about it, >> I thought I thought
he implied that he didn't know or thought he said he didn't >> Well,
he's kind of saying he didn't know, but now he's like, "Well,
Kimmy told me Kimmy told me like not to bring him to these things,
which I don't know how she would justify that, right?" And then
he's like, "Well, I said no, bring him. He's funny. It's not
a problem." Well, what's not a problem? >> Well, no. He
He said he said that. Well, like you showed me who Kimmy is is
what he said. He said he didn't know, but then later on Discord,
he didn't. He said he didn't know the extent of it. I see. I
see.
>> But we have to >> Your character I can reach.
I think it's going to be your wife. Too flimsy >> has been
shown to be absolutely
>> Just make sure you always >> absolutely disgusting.
>> Dude, he sounds like Dean Withers, man. >> Like,
chill the [__] out, bro. >> You You don't meet
the CX Universe moral standard, Lav. You and Gunnar, you guys
are disgusting. Sam would never have done this.
Wait, I would never have done this. Oh, wait. I He almost certainly
has. Remember Remember when he's like, "Hey, Zena, why don't
you just call Sam Bond right now at this Thanksgiving dinner?"
Dinner. Why did I say it like that? Yeah, he did that here. He's
like, "Zena, why don't you just call Sam Bond right now?" And
then he got Sam Bond to call Nick White, who is here on a couch,
so that Sam Bond could like enter this argument with them. Or
what do they get Nick White to opt into this? >> I can't
remember. I don't know why he's being so much of a bro. If if
if you're in Ice Boseidon's position in this, this is just good.
This is just good for you. This just brings numbers. It's good
content. It's funny. Like, whatever. Like, it is what it is,
man. Like, I don't know. Whatever. >> Why would this mas
given the entire CX roster of BJ? Uh,
okay. I I can't confirm or deny that. I have no idea.
I don't I also don't know what it's relevant to that you said
that is kind of weird but
>> think I'm a magician that always do like this a bit
lower but two spots >> so we're good >> the
sorry I skipped way too far >> I'm a magician that always
do like this a bit lower but two spots
>> because instead of messaging me
>> you've tried to clown me on
tried to I I don't know what they tried to, bud. I don't know.
I think they did a little more than try. I think this is one
of the most brutal moggings I've ever seen between like two streamers
talking [__] back and forth. >> Like every
time he opens his mouth, he's just taking more L's. Just shut
the [__] up or do something else, bro. >> It's
uh it's tough. It's tough. It's >> Like I said, enjoy the
inflated viewership for the time being. >> All right, [__]
out of here. At the end of the day, I am successful.
>> You and Lab have to each other on camera for money.
>> We doing nothing wrong.
>> and it's not even that much money. >> So, it's
just sad. >> You know, this would go way harder if you
just shut the up and stop coping about it. Nothing says I actually
don't think money solves all problems when you constantly keep
bragging about how much money you have.
>> Like, he's like, "Man, I'm I'm successful because I
got money." Yep. That's why you keep telling everybody, >> Yeah.
But also, nobody can believe you, right? You already have the
money. That's why you shouldn't be mad right now. You can't say,
"I'm not mad because I have money." You're mad. You're like upset.
You're [__] You're distressed right now. >> Yeah.
Make no sense.
>> Yeah. If the cops show up here, these guys are not going
to be able to scan this. And Florida boy is going to have a massive
lead. >> He's always been sensitive about his relationship.
I mean, it's not like he cancels the TTS's that point. It's not
like he's ever censored nose job from any of his TTS's or anything,
right? Like that's the thing. I I watched one stream where Kimmy
was on and he just had chain donations of like Kimmy got Kimmy's
nose job is awful. Kimmy's nose job is awful, right? To the point
that she tried to get a second nose job. That's not a joke. He
leaked that the last time they he crashed out about her. He tried
to get a second nose job. Dude, I don't even think it looked
bad before. I think I saw it. I don't think it looked bad in
the first place. >> That is brutal, bro. There is no way
I would ever do that. To your N man, those
>> Apparently, she did get a second one. Jesus. That's
You're on your way to being Michael Jackson at that point. Don't
[__] around with those jobs, dude. >> You want
me to see if I can reach
>> Lav is on stream.
>> It's a TTS. >> Anonymous tip. $3.33.
Lav is on stream right now saying Kimmy told Laugh she already
told you everything and that it was fine they leaked it. Guess
Kimmy lied to them
like forever.
>> All right.
>> I got to get Captain G first. >> All right. We
build together. We die together. You build up and put your
>> What do we do? >> Put your little
>> [__] crazy.
>> Let's just wait here and then we'll throw your phone
on. >> The monkey [__] >> He's definitely
watching that clip on the second monitor right now. >> I'm
moving on. >> Uh yeah, you see the You see the head go
over, right? >> What's up? >> Once you get scanned,
I move. >> All right. >> Yeah, just >> the
eyes go over. He goes back. Oh no,
>> That's rough. >> That's rough.
>> There's no other way to say it. >> Hey, so much
selfie stick.
>> Yes, this is about lab slime mode. I'm sorry that you're
not caught up, okay,
>> some happened.
>> I'm only choking. You threaten to base me. Harrison
IRL tipped $3. Harrison IRL Harrison IRL Harrison IRL Harrison
IRL
>> dude he's just
>> he's just chilling.
>> I'll summarize what's happening in about two seconds
guys once we get to the end of this. Okay. >> Ah [__]
I'll just do it right now. Okay. So Lav and Gunnar were arguing
with Ice Boseidon about some problems with Hunger Games or not
Hunger Games with the scavenger hunt. Ice Boseidon got into it
with Lav. They fought a little bit. He said she was and bet her
I think that he could beat her in an IQ test or some [__]
right? And so I think Lab took that she was seething a little
bit and then they had something bad happen later in the night.
I can't remember what it was or I didn't even look into what
it was but they they started talking [__] about Ice
Beside and the the event, right? They were complaining about
the event said it was run poorly and then Ice started watching
them and then he started talking about how they were whiners,
right? So he started talking about how they're whiners and Lav
and how Gunnar's a loser and and Lav goes she says something
like yeah well he may be a loser but that didn't prevent him
from your girlfriend or some and then there's this whole set
of leaks that have have happened since where yeah Gunnar used
to Kimmy and it was apparently like a bit of a known secret in
that universe Sam Pepper knew Sam Pepper referenced it we went
back to all the references we showed all that [__]
okay but it's essentially and then and then they started clowning
him for it Like Ice was like, "Well, I make a lot of money and
whatever." Like I I'm rich, so [__] you guys. And
Lav was like, "Yeah, well you may you may be a millionaire, but
Gunnar your girlfriend on a mattress on the floor with no furniture
in his room, so good luck." Started like actually talking and
hitting hard and he kind of just got rolled. He had no response.
It was uh it was pretty rough, dude.
>> How much? How many? >> Deal with some stuff. So
>> Oh, he's ending. He's ending stream now.
>> But don't worry, guys. We've got Lav coming back right
after this.
>> All right. Well, I'm going to let these guys sit here
and try to figure this out and marinate. I got to go deal with
some stuff. So, I'll be back tomorrow. All right. So, uh sorry
to end it this way, but I have >> just so we know. Now,
we know that's a lie cuz he will not be back tomorrow. Okay.
Oh, wait. Where did I have it? I don't have it here. Uh he is
not coming back. Okay. Okay, he is not back today. He is taking
the day off. We found out much to our sharin. Okay, cuz it was
a could have been a good content day. >> Some other things
that are very important to go handle. So, >> got to take
care of >> I'm going to give somebody a host here and I
will see you guys tomorrow. I don't think they're going to figure
out the next few clues, so I'm not really too worried about that.
All right.
>> All right. Well, see you later, guys. I'll see y'all
tomorrow. I'm host Gary. >> Yo. Okay. All right. >> I'm
gonna go ahead and roll out. It was good hanging with you, JT
Stuck. >> Yeah, it's cool having you here. Thanks for coming
around and uh yeah, come back whenever. Um I'll >> you
should get ready to watch the rest of this though because it
is good drama and it's still going now. Like they went live today,
so >> stay caught up. It's good stuff. >> All right,
talk to you later. >> All right, byebye. >> Boom.
Boom. Okay, so we're going from ice back to Niko Wickeri
the W the Nick Wick Lee stream. Okay. Amaran's husband decided
to call Lav last night. Our favorite buddy, our favorite guy,
fan of the stream. We're fan. We're certainly fans of his stream.
Okay. And he calls
he calls Lav last night to get a lowdown from Lav.
>> I can Hi. >> Hey. How's it going? >> It's,
you know, it's it's going pretty okay. You a lot of people are
like, why did this happen? They were like, you know, is it all
because they didn't work with 30K?
And no, it's not that at all. I first of all, Ice is a bully
and so is Kimmy. They're like huge bullies
and everyone just lets them do it cuz they like run the kick
community. So everyone's like I's like little slave and Kimmy
is like his queen and she's like and everyone's like a little
slave to Kimmy. Kimmy tried to get like every woman black balled
and blacklisted that I has ever talked to. You probably saw him
crash out about your wife like a >> Jesus Christ.
>> She She tried to isolate every single woman in the space.
>> Wait, Dunle crashed out a bit, too. What did What happened
with Dunle? Okay, we're going to we're going to keep listening
to this. And um we're keep we're going to keep listening to this.
We're also going to check out the Goonar stream from today as
well. Oh, hold on. Yeah, we're also going to check that out.
Okay, we're going to keep going. Why didn't Tommy buy Patreon
to Jtock? Wait, Tommy who? does
politicking. She was extremely rude to me. She was super weird
towards me, super rude to me, but I was like, "Whatever. I'm
just like not going to deal with this." And then finally I hit
my the final straw when I had been calling my husband soon uh
like stupid and like a loser and and all these things over the
past couple days and he like got you know his whole thing is
like exploiting smaller streamers and then like that's his whole
content which like I guess if you want to be like the house stern
of dick you can be.
>> Not like when I have a [__] >> what
an unfamiliar story. What a what an unfamiliar story. >> Info
on you like that and you're like that guy like I don't like I'm
not going to keep your secrets. You know what I
>> Gotcha. So you knew about it the whole time or I guess
I I don't know y'all's history originally. I thought I was like
man I thought Goon had leaked it based on the people in my chat
talking about it. I was like man like he's standing next to you
>> because he called he was tight lipped about it probably
cuz it's embarrassing to automaton. Um, but I uh
>> so ang >> what the angry with him trying to ego
my husband that I was just like dude like he your girlfriend
like you're trying to ego the guy who like gaped your girlfriend
like what the [__] are you like come on >> is
that a detail is that is that an actual detail or me >> is
something like
done bad things like implying with like the Destiny drama I had
but Destiny never [__] me I never [__]
Destiny so then >> oh you're the Destiny lab. >> I
don't even know that situation. I've heard those two names thrown
together.
>> Oh, interesting. Okay, cool. We're cool.
>> the Destiny lab. That's [__] >> over
the scavenger hunt. It was just over these like super like >> Nick
doesn't even know. She He just talked mad. >> I I'm not
For what reason we're holding this back? >> Yeah, we stopped
giving a [__] about the hunt like 3 days ago. Yeah,
we did still care about uh like our teammates possibly getting
to it, but then after
we had to go home. >> Gotcha. Okay. Well, that that makes
a little more a lot more sense actually. Um because I real I
was like, man, like that's not that's not like I don't know.
I thought this my first ICE event. Um I'm pretty new at streaming,
but basically
it seemed really fun like day one and then like it got kind of
nutty. >> Oh, Nick Nick also quit. Nick is another >> They
all go because then >> we're not fans of quitters, Nick.
turns into I'm going to change rules. I'm going to [__]
people over. And then it turns into like who's willing to do
the most for like the least amount of money for the most amount
of money. Like how can I get these people who are on their luck
who are desperate to start their career here to do whatever I
want for entertainment? And he'll put people in like continuously
bad humiliating positions. And it's yucky. I got I literally
did that. I exposed Destiny for the same [__] Everyone
said I was a liar and now he's in litigation.
it like I just I have a thing about taking
>> men with big egos I guess.
>> Okay.
I might need to see a clip. Okay. I hate Destiny content. Okay.
I just watching Destiny talking about him talking [__]
about him. Totally good. But I don't really like watching his
content. I might have to see his reaction to that clip right
there where Lav is like I just I love taking men down men with
big egos or whatever. That would be funny as Okay, that would
be really [__] funny. >> I had that thought
too cuz like this is my first event and I remember thinking like
running at these >> $1 chests or whatever. I was like this
feels like it's just a lot of people who >> $1 chest >> that's
their they use that money and like it's like a whole uh hamster
wheel of people doing that in an event.
>> Yes, it's a fake mustache >> and then like people
drive to be like people spend thousands of dollars to go to the
events. Julie ate a And then he he planted a uh like desperate
to like win or whatever. Then he planted like a demon box or
whatever. And then he like made it so that it was like negative
2,000 points even though Shub is sort of an idiot. Like he's
just doing stuff like that where it's like I like I get that
this is entertaining for people who like are soulless, but it's
like I it's just yucky. And then I obviously have a >> it's
not Dude, it's literally entertaining in multiple ways. Doesn't
all have to be entertaining the same >> It's all tie with
like solving the >> My husband a loser. Like how are you?
Like there's no way you can call my husband like a loser like
holding information like that. >> You hearing this? Next
time I need you to defend me. >> I don't have any uh things
to get back at streamers yet. She >> She would probably
be like, "Yeah, he's a loser." >> Hey, my loser. >> Yeah,
I know. I know. Evil Johnny Bravo. I know. >> Can't do
that. You got to have your man's back. >> Well, Nick, you
gangster. >> Yeah. No.
Yeah, she's not really moralizing. She knows. She knows what
this is. She knew what it was. All the content's really obvious.
>> Ammo, Nick, we're on good terms now. Yes. Women.
>> No, I'm I'm glad I got y'all's uh in the cuz I I was
a little bit confused at how everything went down. >> Yeah.
Everyone keeps acting like it's about money. We were like top
five. We were literally going to like We could have won, but
he was never going to let us win. Well, we actually didn't even
know. So Kimmy's such a huge liar that like we thought she had
been feeding me information that he knew and that he like did
that that if we didn't get ahead of it, he was going to say >> And
then she had fed information to Sam Pepper that like she had
rejected
uh Goon Tim and that like nothing ever happened but like he sent
her love letters. Like what is a fully fabricated lie and I along
said that would be nice. He was like no no I don't want him to
join. and they don't want him to join when she was doing the
opposite. Like, it's just so we had no idea. We actually thought
that we were getting ahead of it because he was going to release
information. Like, that's what she made it seem like. She almost
>> No, no, no,
no. That's the most insane cope.
They did it because they were mad at him. She was mad at him
and she was nuking him. That's not Don't do the whole thing where,
oh, we're worried he was going to leak it. We We just thought
we were getting ahead of it. No. Shut up. Come on, man. >> Oh,
interesting. But but so y'all are kind of surprised, I guess,
that we all kind of surprised then that uh he wasn't aware or
>> Oh, no. We were we were completely surprised. In fact,
we both like kind of feel bad now. I sent him a message that
was like, "Hey, I know that you do not want to hear from me,
but like we fully thought that like we like we did not realize
that this was the situation. I thought that like we were on an
even plane. I almost thought that he was taunting us with it
with talking about him. Okay, then. Yeah, now now it makes a
lot more sense because >> I think Ice was just talking
and he's used to be he's used to being able to [__]
talk people and have total leverage over them cuz for the exact
reason he just said, "Oh, well, good luck to your KCIP. I'm going
to ruin your career, right?" So, he's used to be able to just
He's used to being able to just talk people with impunity. And
he was doing it. He probably didn't even think about it. I I
doubt he thought about it at all cuz I've never seen him like
be super rude to Gunnar for no reason.
It's hard to believe that he would be doing that now. It's probably
cuz Lava was talking Y'all thought it was just like a a you know,
maybe a little pointed rib back at him that he already knew about.
>> Uh yeah, at least to like some degree cuz he also like
it's not like he tried to protect Kimmy. He like tries to kill
her. So I thought that he like >> I I thought that he was
like trying to bait us and then we were like getting ahead of
it. And then also I was so pissed at him that I like wanted to
ego him back. Like it was I'm not >> That's that last one
is like 99.9%
of whatever's happening. I was so angry at him that I was going
to ego him back. That's what it was. You're chipping down my
partner. You sh me. You loser. You don't get to talk me. >> I
think it was all truest. Like it was a mix of things. Obviously,
I wanted him to feel bad because he was trying to ego my husband.
But yeah, it was like very convoluted and we totally thought
the situation was different. There was no I had an inkling cuz
Tim actually had asked her before Hunger Games like, "Does he
know? Is it weird if I do this?" And she can pull it up later.
Thank you for the
music. >> She totally lied to everyone. Like we thought
we we there was no thought in either of our minds that he did
not know and we both and we >> that's the only thing we
feel bad about like the rest of it it's pretty justified cuz
Kimmyy's such a like abusing people but we do genuinely feel
bad that he wasn't aware that it all came out like this. >> Yeah,
it's that's obviously wish that on >> Yeah, that's super
unal. He is still a scumbag but that I'm like empathetically
that sucks. >> Yeah, especially in that setting. Uh, but
I feel like guys generally would rather know than not. >> Yeah.
Yeah. It has been It's been three years also. So, she's been
lying for three years. >> Like just gnarly. Like it's just
gnarly. I can't imagine. >> Yeah. I'm new to the space.
So, it's always like I'm learning how the dynamics work and it's
like uh trying to not step on any
>> Off topic. What about Nick?
>> You count YT views as most real. His Bradley collab
is almost a mill and everyone else was like lower even as >> Okay,
hold on. You so off topic, but about about Nick from VOD last
night. Okay, hold on. I totally didn't catch that. I I thought
that was something happening on on their stream for a second.
So, I'll pull that back up. You said Nick, so I was like, "Oh,
I didn't see what it was." Hold on. Something about Fuentes.
I'll play it one second. I want you to get ripped off. Okay.
I want to respond. Replay. Replay. Replay. There a clip of Ice
calling him a loser. I'll try to find >> one just take
$5. >> Off topic, but about Nick from last VOD. You count
YT views as most real. His Bradley collab is almost a mill and
everyone else was like lower. Even Hassan.
Yeah. Uh Hassan doesn't get good views on YouTube either. But
fair fair enough. Fair enough.
Um I think Nick has like a dedicated audience. I think you get
a lot of like um if you have a big group of very dedicated fans
who will mob something immediately, you will get big YouTube
views because you you you hit the algorithm like a meteor. Okay.
When you have like a fan base that you mobilize like 5 10,000
people who are going to watch the whole thing, they're going
to talk about it. They're going to comment. They're going to
like it. Yeah. You you hit the algorithm like a meteor and you
send that skyrocketing, right? People with very very cult-like
audiences, like m like super fans, they'll do that all the time.
Okay.
>> Just like don't like >> don't expect people to
like keep your secrets if you're going to like them over or like
be a huge dick. Like I think I feel like it's like street rules.
It's like normal.
>> Okay. I mean, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
>> I Yeah, I'm very like Kate's been in the space for a
bit, but uh I've mostly been behind the scenes if if at all.
And so the whole streamer dynamics are are super new to me. I
feel like uh I mean it's funny I say this because like hearing
that I'm like okay so it's a little bit uh webbed and >> uh
Captain C319. Why would I be interested in hearing that when
I'm watching the Lav Nick content >> stuff but like it's
I feel like it's worse on Twitch. >> I we will watch that
later tonight >> Oh no. It's way worse on Twitch. We It's
honestly I think because Ice had to move over to Kick that's
like last of the toxicity. Every single person we've met through
kick is incredible. It's like, >> yeah, a lot of the people
are really humble and cool, >> but when you get to that
level where they're like just like boarding over a bunch of people,
it turns you into >> Yeah, Action Man's great. Even though
he's sort of like a gooner, he's still like very genuine and
great. Like even Ice's friends, like great. >> Action Man
is at least as bad as Ice, if not worse. Action Man's not cool.
>> Chicken Andy's great. Adriana Lee is great. Like there
I don't go. Like there's so many people who are like genuinely
good people. It's just like the people who >> I will watch
$5. >> Also another point you asked. He gets six to 7k
per show on super chats. I don't know the equal to YT subs do
but do you think Destiny gets more? >> There's no way he
gets 6 or $7,000 per show on super chats. That is not possible.
What? cuz when I I I watched him pretty consistently like one
or two times a week for like an entire uh like an entire winter
spring period like once twice a week and he never got more than
like a hundred bucks in donations. Dude, that's crazy if that's
true. I'm not shocked he gets money. His last Tucker show was
7K. Yeah, but that's like massive. If he got $1,000 in super
chats per show, that would be crazy to me. That would be amazing.
I I don't know.
He does that. Then he's making infinitely more money than he
ever has before. Like when I was watching him before, he makes
infinitely more money now. That's insane. >> Who moved
over to kick because they couldn't do >> Nick Fuentes.
Nick Fuentes >> anymore that suck.
>> The the perma bands or whatever you're >> Yeah,
exactly. Exactly. >> Gotcha. Yeah, I hung out with AC7.
That that was fun. I got the same impression. >> Yeah.
just super genuine. Like basically what you see is what you get.
Um he doesn't really mince anything. Yeah, >> totally super
genuine guy and there's like Yeah, there's plenty of that on
Kick. I think Kick is the optimal website. I think it's much
better than Twitch in regards to like networking and making friends.
But yeah, definitely don't like go into it entitled thinking
that like you can you can ego people because of who you are because
of Yeah, that's just stupid. >> Gotcha. Are you guys um
at any level? Huh? This is crazy. Um, wow. I didn't know that.
That's That's wild. >> I was worried about like what he's
saying about the whole,
you know, because I I saw y'all made the joke right when y'all
got off of like y'all retiring.
Um, but like how seriously do you take him saying that like will
he come down off of it or does he forgive or does he like get
over things or not? >> I I I mean you'd have to if I was
in his position, I would do anything I could. you like I
>> he has to save face so I'm not got to like make a >> I
don't care though. I don't care about streaming anymore. I've
stopped giving >> It's not good for the platform. It's
not good for the platform if someone who's like barely involved
can like cut people's KCIP and get you banned or like destroy
you in that way. Um just because of like a beef. >> I don't
think that that's like a good precedent to set, especially cuz
this is the same guy who literally was like threatening to kill
his girlfriend like not even 4 weeks ago. And so for him to be
able to do >> this is like uh I was like super on their
side through all of this. I don't like the I don't like the way
they're reframing personally >> something like that liveally
can't like expose his girlfriend for being like >> you
know for sleeping around and for Rice besid being like a little
[__] >> like it that just it's not a great
look for Kick. But also like you know we both have real jobs,
real things like this is more of like a hobby stuff for us. So
it's not like this isn't the end of the world if he does take
>> mudahar mudahar mudahar mahar >> but it does like
>> although I don't think goon streams that much when he's
not doing events. I think goon streams way less when he's not
doing events. >> Yeah it does suck. We're we're we're sad.
I think that he will probably black ball us which like I think
that he will say like if you interact with goon then you're out
of like CX events or whatever. Um and if that's the case then
>> that sucks but >> so be it. We'll be friends off
stream. >> Yeah. I'll just be >> We understand that
we won't be like touchable now. But I I don't know. >> I
have a real job. I don't give a [__] >> It
matters. Like I don't know. I I just hate when a man tries to
ego my man. I don't know. I like it felt worth it to me. I don't
know. >> Or you were crash. >> Yeah. I guess I'm
crazy. >> I love you.
>> You guys sound very compatible. Can I ask how long have
y'all been together
>> Did you believe that I put her in a psych word last
week? >> True. It's true. >> But yeah. Anyway, it
was
>> It was great connecting. We're big fans. >> I
uh I don't know. She took pictures. I don't think she'd have
her phone if that's what actually happened. Yeah. >> Oh,
I don't know what was happening. >> I I was introduced
to uh Goon Stream through uh You're reacting to the fights at
uh >> Sorry, she took pictures. If you're actually in some
ward or something, you don't have your phone >> I think,
right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Dream Hack. Yeah. >> Oh, Dream
Hack. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There you go. >> Yeah. We
will be doing another uh another debrief stream here pretty soon.
>> I'll be doing a big >> Oh, for this event. >> Zero
dollars from it. >> I expect this Kimar for Ice to walk
everything back. Yeah, he did it the last time. I expect him
to do it again. We've still got, by the way, their stream from
today. We'll have their stream from today. And we will also have
all of Ice Besides like Crash Out Discord messages and the sand
pepper call. Dude, there's so much more left.
This whole stream is just It's all this all of this. Holy. Yeah,
it's unfortunate that there's like a a small version of I guess
the whole black balling thing because that's something I heard
happened a bunch on Twitch. Um >> Y happens so much. >> But
people don't ever like get in front of it and expose it so they
don't do anything. Like our good friend Adriana got black balled
out of all the OT.
>> Like it it happens to people and they take advantage
of these smaller streamers because they come forward to tell
the truth. But I don't really give >> Yeah. As long as
we have our integrity in each other, that's all really that >> Yeah,
that was surprising to me. The Adriana Lee thing with the whole
Maya helping with >> they're they're farming. They're farming
a lot. >> I mean, like I I guess I shouldn't be that surprised
that the the people who are kind of uh connected at Twitch, you
know, you have it. Uh and so my I just have to tell you something.
You are Maya. You are Maya. I >> was kind of surprised
at the concerted effort like they went through to
you know, trying to lowkey, I guess, pressure her. >> Yeah.
Makes me super sad because Adriana is like the actually like
the realest
I know through this streaming. Like the just like the sweetest,
most genuine girl, but that's like what gets you that's what's
that's what gets you
>> Gotcha. Are you guys uh like uh cool with Train or any
of the other characters kind of uh siminal to the kick story
or >> No, we're not really like in it in it. Ah man, I
don't think I don't think he's maximizing this interview. I feel
like I I feel like I could maximize this interview more. It's
like one, you got to be able to push back. Okay. Got to know
Lav. Got to know some of the bullit. All right. Got to know some
of the I just think it's funny cuz Lab's in a place now where
everybody else operates like her, right? Like the only thing
you can't do if you want to criticize Lab here is go, I can't
believe you're so disgusting. You're like morally you you're
just so morally gross. You're morally disgusting to me. No, all
of these people
act the exact way Lab does when they get in fights. They all
leak. They all are just crazy >> just tipped $5. >> Drama
Puritans. >> How much are you going to donate to Team Water?
Every streamer is donating around a hundred or 200,000. XQC,
Asmin, Aiden, Train, etc. What about you? >> Uh $0. They're
trying to raise the Antichrist. Okay. The the red heer has been
sacrificed and this if this team water donation goal hits its
max. Okay, the Antichrist is rising. I will not donate. I will
not donate. I will not donate. I will not donate. >> Uh,
just to be clear, I don't know what that red heer thing is. I
saw a clip on Twitter of a guy on Tim Pool explaining it, and
I saw what I know to be a Groper account posting it. So, I was
like, "Oh, that's an anti-Semitic conspiracy of some kind."
Um, I don't even know what I said. You might find what I said
funny, okay? But I'm just going to keep watching this content.
>> Do our own lane of stuff. Like Tim really does like
react tent and >> Okay. Well, and then are are you guys
banned on Twitch or just prefer kick? >> I got banned off.
>> I just prefer I prefer kick. I moved over kick day one
so I've never looked >> Yeah, I said a bad word. >> Kick
is huge.
>> And I also Yeah, I agree. Yeah.
>> It's unfortunate about the whole uh blacklist thing
cuz like I mean you hear about that a bunch in like various different
things and I just this was kind of the kick was kind of the escape
from all that. >> Yeah. So for it to follow suit in such
a way would be very unfortunate. >> It's when a red heer
is born somewhere in the world x amount of times. It signals
the near-term destruction of Israel. But they also sacrifice
one in a ritual. I think they lit it on fire. sacrifice red hepher
at third temple to bring end of world conspiracy. Okay. Yeah.
So apparently there the guy in Timool was a guy. He's a pro-Israel
guy Adam King or something. I think he was explaining that they
did this ritual and the people who did the ritual were carrying
it out like at the behest of they were supposed to do a test
or something but they really did the whole ritual or something
and he was like we we won. It was like the weirdest
the weirdest video I've ever seen. Anyway, >> good for
everybody. >> Yeah. It's not great optics for kick if anything
does happen. He also said I mean he had said before that like
when someone him off with Kimmy he got hit he got that guy's
KCIP I thought he was talking about you guys KCIP like lowered
or something for like a few months or something. So I don't know
what hands he has in it but like optically it's like
you know just not great. Also it makes him look like a like >> Yeah.
Just deal with it. Like get rid of >> Yeah. Dump your girlfriend
who obviously lied to you and is doing your thing and like move
on. You got like >> Lav didn't leak my first name. Lav
asked me what my first name is and I said Chad. Lav didn't leak
anything. Said that on stream. >> No, he's his ego is so
big. He he like takes one L and it's the end of the world. Like
just move on. >> Yeah. I mean uh before he ended the stream
he was trying to I think he was trying to seem like he was unaffected
but I feel like you can tell his voice that was kind of >> weighing
on Kimmy. For me Kimmy was acting at first he said that it was
a
I'm I can't even believe she lied to him. I >> Yeah, I
can't even believe like him finding out in real time after like
I was releasing messages like had to had to have sucked. And
I do feel bad for that cuz I literally had no idea. I was completely
under the impression that he knew. So >> you figured you
were sparring like, "Okay, you're going to say this thing about
my husband. I'm going to say this thing that other people don't
know, but you know."
>> That was the thought. I guess we we got lied to as well.
So >> yeah, I went I went too I mean I went nuclear. It
was I was supposed to go nuclear, but I like I destroyed the
planet with my nuclear blow. I accidentally hit Earth's core.
>> Is there any chance of you guys reconciling with ice?
I I don't know him well enough to know if that can happen. >> I
don't think No, I don't think there's any way. I mean I >> we
sent him a good message. Yeah, I I sent a message that was like,
listen, I like you are sort I mean, I still think you're a scumbag
for doing what you did and you shouldn't have egoed my husband,
but like I really am sorry that you didn't know and I'm glad
that like if this is how you find out that now like >> I
feel like there's no way he responded to that at all, right?
>> Like I there's just no way. And I that's I'm sure that
that's not the only or the first lie. Like I'm she's >> Okay,
I'm I'm letting this go for a little bit longer. Uh I'm going
to speed it up cuz it's honestly
>> not as much content as I'd hoped. Give me two seconds.
I'll be right back. I'm use bathroom. >> Why are they separated?
Cuz it's not a financial thing. I mean like clearly he could
just move her down or she could move down. Like why do they stay
>> I I don't I mean if I had to be anywhere near Kimmy,
I'd want to you know I' I'd be posting a gun at my head in my
Discord also. But I don't know. Maybe they thought this face
would make it work. I have no clue. She probably has a boyfriend
or two. Who knows?
Well, hope for y'all's sake uh everything patches out because
uh yeah, now it makes more sense because like I I get that aspect
because that is like a measured response if if he already knew,
right? Cuz you're like, "Okay, fine. You're going to embarrass
me, we'll embarrass you." You know, it's fine. Um but then it
became this whole >> power cake. It was >> Yeah.
Hey, it was good to finally uh you know, virtually meet you guys.
I saw >> we heard that you also play Warhammer that you
paint the figurines. I >> I do. I do. It's like It sucks
because like I What are they? >> Oh, uh I switch like uh
in 10th edition, I think it was. I played the uh [__]
uh let's see I played the dark eldar. I played played marines
and then uh I started painting up a third but like that always
happens. I burn myself out painting and then like I I step away
for a bit. >> See if with Lee has three army then. >> Oh
yeah. Well we have funny you can.
>> Yeah. I used to play with my brother and we had this
room with the table set up and then like I just noticed that
like it became harder and harder to do games every time we had
a kid. It was like one kid okay uh you know every other week
and then two kids. It's like okay like you know once a month
and then like three kids it's like he just doesn't have time.
>> I'll never take that away from you baby. But you could
you could always have two days a week if you wanted.
>> Okay. Well, yeah, it was nice. It was nice talking to
you. >> Yeah, you guys sound uh super on the same page,
which is always cool.
>> Yeah, we do love each other a lot. >> Love each
other a lot. >> All right. It was great to meet you guys
in Are you from Austin? Nice to >> meet you, too. Take
it easy. >> Are you from Austin or >> Oh, no, no,
no. We live in Chicago.
let's play some Warhammer. >> Sounds great. >> Yeah.
All right. I'll see you guys. Take it easy.
>> Wait, dude.
Nick said that like longingly, didn't he? Like, oh, it's you
guys seem like you get along really well. That sounds nice. That
sounds like that would that would be cool. I would love to just
get along. I would love it if we could just get along. My wife
I can't be the only one who heard it. I feel like I heard it
directly. My stupid wife will She will not stop arguing with
me. That point of stream I had to switch headphones. Actually
missed nothing. >> Well, that was inward.
>> Yeah. Hopefully we're not blacklisted now. Yeah. That's
unfortunate. Um
cuz what she's saying headphones >> and I kind I actually
do believe that >> it doesn't Oh, by the way, this is the
dumbest thing he said. Oh, it seems like approximate response.
Seems like a measured response if uh if you thought he knew.
No, it doesn't. Hey, your girlfriend this other guy is not a
measured response. That's like literally going at the most personal
thing you can immediately. That's not a measured response in
any case, whether he knew or not. If it's not public knowledge.
Oh, I my other headphones didn't die. Just these ones are charged
now. And these are my nice ones. I like these ones way better.
So I switched
anyway. Yeah, >> see if she didn't know. He didn't know.
>> Am I going to throw an opinion? >> Like there
are all these um things dramas beneath the surface. No matter
if it's Twitch or kick or wherever, even in a regular 9 to5 workplace,
there's these dramas, right? And you know, if you if you you
know, kind of elbow someone, they tend to elbow you back. And
and you know, it's a proportionate response >> Yes. But
when when you elbow lab, when you elbow lab, she literally claws
your eyes out. Okay. like you you like bump lab in the hallway
and she claws your eyes out. All right,
that's the difference. It's not proximate. >> Um and I
guess in this case, uh due to the head, >> they thought
they were giving a proportionate response. >> Two headphone
swaps. I had these ones on originally. I realized they weren't
charged, so I switched my AirPods and now I switch back to them
cuz they are >> on that ended up being really really contagious.
Something like that, you
>> Um Oh man, I've never had I've literally never had my
go this fast. We cannot see anything. What do you mean you cannot
see anything? [__] does this mean we cannot see anything?
>> I mean, >> Like a lot of you guys are uh Ice guys.
Um I actually don't disagree that she wanted to humiliate him,
but I don't think she actually Well, unless you all are saying
it's one and the same. Humiliate humiliating him is hurting him
because like what we're talking about in terms of >> Well,
when I say these ones, I mean the headphones I'm wearing. >> He
didn't know. That's like a dagger to the chest, right? Um whereas
I think she thought it was just like a very public venue, you
know, very public venue. um being being the way that you know
it gets back at him, you know, whatever, >> Gosh, it's
awkward. >> Yeah. Them faces. >> It's because like
I just hung out with Kimmy and so then it's like weird to be
like on a Discord call and then they're like, "Yeah, I [__]
that caught." And you're just like, "I have nothing to >> Oh,
she did just hang out with Kimmy, too. That's That's why it's
important context from before. Kimmy was just hanging out with
Amv. And now they're on a call and Lab's just like this stupid
Kimmy. Yeah, >> I like I don't have anything against either
of them, but >> I pride myself on being friendly with people
and and and kind of like knowing them for who they are, and that
leads me to having a lot of friends that don't mutually get along.
And so far, it's been fine. Hopefully, it can continue to be
that way because I kind of see where uh everyone is coming from.
Uh to be >> dude, I I kind of want to watch this Dickers
debate. I will watch it, okay? But it sucks right now. >> All right.
Welcome to the show, y'all. Welcome. Welcome. Shut up, Kyle.
Shut up, Kyle. Shut up, Kyle. Shut the up, Kyle. Shut up. Shut
the [__] up. Sorry. Um, okay. I've got so much content
that for this for all of the kick stuff, all the kick drama.
I've got so much content. I might have to do like the whole day
on that. Guys,
we're about to cover the Ice Boseidon logs. Okay, I went through
and painstakingly clipped out every single log from Ice Boseidon
so I could read them for you on stream. Okay. Is there a reason
for the avatar? I don't know. I was feeling funky today. Feeling
funky. Feeling funky. So, I went and clicked all of these, but
if you like the content, I want you to follow me on every platform,
okay? Follow me on
with an underscore. Twitch.tv/jdklk
with an underscore. I'll throw the Twitch channel in the kick
chat, guys. If your primers are up, go to the Twitch channel.
Send me a primer. Okay, Twitch primes always appreciated.
There it is. There it is. There it is.
Follow on every platform. Join the Discord. Discord.gg/jstl.
GG/JSTK.
And if you want to take your support one step further, you can
always give me money. I really appreciate money. Makes the stream
go longer. Gives us more time to get through all of the content.
All right, we have fantastic comment com fantastic content coming.
There's the Zena getting arrested stuff, which also extends into
today where I believe she asks Shuy to bail her out. Okay, I
It's fantastic content all night. So, we need 8 hours. We need
you guys to donate, donate, donate. There's a couple ways you
can donate. Okay, you can give subs on kick. You can sub individually
on kick. I love individual subs on kick because if you sub individually,
that's a rolling monthly charge. It's a rolling monthly investment
in the stream. Okay, I can depend on that money. I really appreciate
it. All right, you can give subs on kick. You can donate through
TTS. There's the kickbot that's pinned in the in the kick chat
right now. Kickbot TTS AITTS $2 minimum. There's Streamlabs as
well. Streamlabs TTS exclamation point donate in the chat. We'll
give you those links. The Streamlabs is a $3 minimum. Okay. And
last but not least, if you want to give some money, I really
appreciate every dollar from every chat, every chatter,
there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jsk.
All right, multiple tiers.
Hop over there, shoot me a couple bucks. I really appreciate
any money you give. Okay, love you guys. You guys are awesome.
Okay, go sign up for the free Patreon if nothing else so that
you're ready. All right, Amrath needs to subscribe on Patreon.
That would be cool. I would love that. All right, I would love
that. Okay, thank you guys so much. I love you. We are nine subs
away from another hour on the stream. All right, I will be shilling
again in exactly 1 hour. But let's continue on with the content.
Ice Boseidon Discord rage from this morning. All right, so we
had that live call last night. Ice showed up this morning and
he starts going off. I wasn't aware. I wasn't aware of the relationship
Kim had with Goon and it's pretty upsetting and I can't look
at her the same anymore. It's pure disgust and how she lied for
so long. But I ceased all communication with any girl I ever
had a thing with. Goon is a coward for not telling me. Manto
man and Lav is mentally ill is a mentally ill weird ass dog [__]
Goon and Lav are cowards for how they decided to tell me this
is all in Kimmy and not Goon or Lav. Wake up. Uh but you already
knew about the relationship. No, I didn't know the extent of
it. I don't know what that means. I don't know. I mean, I don't
trust Kim or Sam. Why do you care? You were broken up. Hold on.
Why do you care? You were broken up. Did you zero people while
broken up? It's not about her other people during our time on
break. It's about her lying to me about it. She forced me to
stop talking to any girl I've ever had a thing with, but she
continued to text Goon sometimes without giving me full context.
It's a little bit of a double standard in the relationship. He's
not a fan. He's not a huge fan. He didn't know she got gaped.
He did not know that she got gaped. That's true. these where
there's a couple you got to read bottom to top. So I would have
never dated her again if she told me. Yeah, she's out and I'm
never going to talk. So wait, so he he just said that the problem
was her not was her lying, right? And her continue to talk. And
then he says, but I would never have dated her again if she told
me.
>> Uh-huh. Yeah, she's out and I'm never going to talk
to her again. I I can't see anything but pure disgust for wasting
my time. And hearing the details as well. Mattress on the floor.
I would never marry some streets. That's disgusting. Oh, it's
Ice Poseidon who calls her a streets. It's not anybody else.
It is Ice that calls her a streets. It hurts cuz he's hurt. I
hurt when he hurts. And yeah, she forced Maddie out of every
stream possible. Lol. That was true. Oh, cool. He's leaking all
that stuff, too. Interesting. Okay. I remember Cutebot IG stories
of all those roommates going out clubbing and Goon was there
while y'all were dating. Probably cheated. Well, Cupot is the
one who got a nose job and convinced Kim to get one uh to get
her one. So, that [__] Okay.
Can't be can't be a Kim an ice beside and crash out without a
comment on Kimmy's nose job. Pretty sure Maddie doesn't like
me. No, I've been uh Has Bro been sliding in DMs all night? No,
I've been asking myself why I trusted her for so long after everything
she's ever shown me. What did she message Goon when I was in
Japan? Oh, yeah. I knew she messaged about her ugly nose to him
because I thought they were just friends.
Was the laboplasty real? Yes, she had a laboplasty. She actually
got it done twice, which severely affected her ability to stay
wet. You sure it wasn't just that? She'd goon and then my brother,
my brother, my brother, my brother.
Uh,
I had the surgery and I can't just get wet for you anymore. Meanwhile,
she's like, "Fuck goon." And she's like, "I just listen, you
just don't measure up, okay? You just don't measure up." Aha.
Once you go once you go BWC,
there is no other Wii. I don't know. I I can't finish it. I'm
not good at rhyming. Okay,
I'm going to stop talking about Kim and I don't want people to
talk about her. Just let her die off. She has 10K in her bank
living in LA. Let her die off and become a to guys who won't
give her who won't give a [__] about her to get her
rent paid. I paid it. She will never go live again.
Let's be real. She's shameless as [__] Wouldn't surprise
me if she tried to go live in a month. Now, if people bring her
nose job up, nose her nose up, she will never go live. Nose reactions.
Goons is the reason she needed the second leia blasty.
>> Gunnar got that coke. Ken Ice got a pee pe. Okay. All
right.
Why? Dude, there's a lot of there's a lot of watching energy
in this chat right now. I need you guys to all chill. Okay. Chill,
chill, chill, chill, chill, chill. All right. Yeah, I'm not going
to attack him or leak anything. Just forget her. Have you messaged
her after you went offline? Yeah, she said she forgot to tell
me about it. So, I just said never talk to me again. Oops. Forgot
forgot to say something.
So, you're going to [__] with Goon today or let him
stay uh get away with that. Um, no. If Goon wins, I just won't
pay him so he should just quit. That is the most [__]
Disqualify him or let him play, but do an action. Don't be passive.
Don't do that. Well, he should just quit cuz I won't even pay
him. She's leaked stuff before about how Ice has a flap over
his ass. Damn. Is that a tail? Are you describing a tail? What
is a tail if not a flap over the app? I feel like you're describing
Ice has a tail. Okay. Anyway,
you already basically paid him to him if you think about it,
boy. So, if he wins, you you're even if you don't pay. No, I
win. I lose the lying girl and I'm a millionaire. While Goon
and Lab have to money and Kim has to learn to deal with having
no money.
Oh boy.
That's rough, guys. That's rough. That's rough. That's rough.
That's rough. That's rough. How much was her rent? Just trying
to figure out how long before she broke. Is her lifestyle expensive?
It's 24,400 or something.
That's not actually That's actually not bad. It's a studio apartment
with no AC because SJC basically SJC's apartment. Let's be real.
She's just going to fight another rich guy. Too old plus too
much maintenance plus lazy aka doesn't clean or cook or do laundry.
I have no clothes 7 days into this event and my house is a mess
when she's been there every day. Please tell me you took back
all the you bought her. No, I don't care about that. It's like
10k. I could care less. You couldn't care less. You mean she
was completely useless as a woman. Didn't do anything. Just leech
my money to buy stuff and rent. Okay. Is it your house, though?
My wife doesn't do any laundry, and if we weren't married, she
wouldn't feel obligated to clean my house. >> I asked her
to as a favor. Okay.
>> Hilotonics, thank you for the gifted sub. Do lav of
all people. Very interesting. Thank you. Thank you.
Chill, Ice, do you cook or clean or do laundry either, lol? Yes,
I do. My house is clean and everything is organized when I'm
alone. When she comes, the house becomes a mess within days.
I promise you, nothing would hurt Kim more than you airing out.
Don't say and just ostracize her from your life. Yes, that's
what I'm doing. I just need everyone to stop mentioning her.
Okay, that's not a good thing. Ice thinks Eddie is going to ban
Goon at his behest. Nah, I can't ask that. But totally excluding
him from everything in the future is just as bad. Genuinely,
how do you care? Because he and Lav are cowards.
Off Sam. Honestly, I think Goon
knew not to bring this up. Think Goon not to bring this up. Sorry.
I think Goon knew not to bring this up, but he's a beta [__]
to his wife, and when she started saying, he had no choice but
to go with her or get his ass. I mean, his life he let his wife
talk for hours. So, he's at fault, too. Okay. All right. How
did this leak? This right here, how did what leak? How did the
Gooner his girlfriend? Lav literally just yelled it at him. Literally
yelled it at Ice Beside while Ice Beside was talking [__]
to them. Yeah. Yeah. I don't think L or sorry, Sam and Ice both
have like some weird red pill looking like weird weird red pill
way of looking at things. I wear the pants. No, you don't. No,
you don't. No, you don't. Go just lets you think that. Not true.
I think it's funny that when I said I don't want to date anymore,
I didn't get a response or anything. Lol. She knew it was over.
That's crazy. She isn't even fighting for you. Please don't take
her back no matter what. Okay, this guy's a rider. Jesus Christ.
She's not even fighting for you. Oh my god. My god. Yeah. The
only response I got before she stopped was trying to blame me
for not believing her. Lol. kick.com/kickplays
live. Does anyone know if RFID number 42 was removed/destroyed?
Yes.
Oh, okay. That's uh I don't know why I took a screenshot of this
last one. I was not reading them, I guess, as I was taking screenshots.
Let me check real quick to see I want to check really fast and
see if he put more in here cuz somebody told me he put more in.
So, I'm going to go check real quick from Ice_Poseidon69.
Oh, he did put more in. He just said He just said he's not going
live and he's tired. That's it. I'm not going live. I'm tired.
That's it. That's it. That's all. That's it. That's all. That's
it. Wait, what is this? Quick quick Kimmy clip. What is this?
What is this? What is this? Oh, don't mute. >> I'm on stream
right now. Can u me and Alan take your Dora of your closet off
for you? Can I put you on speaker? Okay, you're on stream. Um,
me and Alan are making a box fort for you. We're making you a
little fort for your bed. And I wanted to know if we
>> No, like your floor like pile of blankets that you call
a bed.
She know she's fully She's on board. She's on board. >> Putting
like boxes over it or making you a little hut. It's going to
be really uh very cool and manly.
and we wanted to know if we could take your closet door off.
I can take it off just by removing the hinge. That way you don't
have to keep opening your door and like moving >> Bro,
is this before the nose job? That's wild. If she got a There's
literally nothing wrong with her nose. People are so [__]
I hate this idea. This is Bro, you guys you guys destroyed this
guy's life. Are you guys satisfied? this
>> bed to get into your closet
>> and all I have to do >> leave this man alone is
I just take the
>> take the like the what they call >> okay
sorry I'm like I bounce around between my Discord and I's discord
it's like half of Ice's Discord right now is just people taunting
him with like Kimmy clips and [__] sorry we got another
one we got another one we got another one let's go there's a
good line by the grateful dead once in a while you get shown
the light in the strangest of places if you look at it Okay.
So, you need to go. >> Sounds like a like a bedtime story.
>> No, it it's a song. It pretty much is. But that line
sticks with me. I'll never find anything that I'm looking directly
for. It's like in the fridge. I open the fridge, I'm like, "Where
the is the ketchup?" All I can think about is ketchup, ketchup,
ketchup. I can't find it anywhere. But if I'm not looking for
>> Wow. So true. I think this is just getting posted. So
Ice has to look at Kimmy and Kunar together. I think that's the
only reason people are posting these things. I feel like they're
just like, "Oh, it's a clip of Kimmy and Gunnar in the same place.
Upload it. Get it on the cord. Get it there now. He needs to
see this." She doing a mustache right now or
mustache. Okay. All right. Oh, yeah. I don't know if Hold on.
I'll send this to Lav just in case you guys want to show this
on your stream at some point. Let me send this to Lav here. This
is the first time it gets referenced on this episode is Sam goes,
"Oh, I know who you are. Oh, I put so many things together that
I can't talk about on stream. Yeah.
All right. Okay. We're We're on to the Sam the Sam stream now.
The Sam interview. Let's take a look. Let's take a look. I don't
have the whole Sam stream. I don't have time stamps for it. But
there is Sam does go off on
on Lab specifically. We might go back and find some more timestamps
from Sam's stream as well if there's if there's more choice
time stamps. Okay. But for now, I've just got this one of him
going after Lav. All right. >> Show you this, which is
already a message that's been posted. I don't know why. We've
seen this.
What's this? What's this show, Gwen? >> We read all of
these already. Here, give me a sec. I need to get caffeine.
>> Yeah, we've seen this. What do you Do you understand
the relevance of this? Like why why Gwen thinks this is a big
deal?
I called him. He didn't answer. Because Kimmy leaked, >> bro.
I'm getting absolutely horrendous
sent to me on my the person who just DM' me on Discord with an
image. Please consider removing yourself from the gene pool.
Holy, I need to go get caffeine. Give me a second. I'm triggered
as now >> it to you in a panic.
And you didn't tell Ice. What? No, she says right here. It's
fine. Just Paul and Sam know.
>> Hey, still think there's a love letter? Yeah, of course.
I think there's a love
>> Yeah, Kimmy made that up to spin the story so Paul wouldn't
know and get
>> No, I think it was just part of the whole thing. Like,
it was part of the fact that Look, >> Hold on. Hold on.
I thought this was I didn't realize this was a call-in. >> Nobody
told me this was a call-in. I thought it was just Sam talking
[__] I didn't realize this was them going back and
forth. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Then you have Down syndrome. >> You lived with You lived
with Kimmy. Okay. And you fell under her spell. >> Content
gods have blessed us. >> No, she was my portable holster.
Like, what are you talking about? >> You fell under her
spell. >> I would call her in the room and borrow friction
from her and kick her out so I could gamble and play World of
Warcraft.
>> You You fell for her. Okay. Or
Horrendous way to speak about a woman there. Okay.
Hor disgusting.
Borrowing friction. I'm never going to use that at any point
in the future. Okay. Borrowing friction. That is gross. I'm not
writing that down. Listen, you don't own No, >> she panicked
it to you and you never told Ice. >> She didn't leak it
to me. It was an argument that
it was an argument that >> on September 12th, 2023. Yes,
I just showed you the screenshot. In the screenshot, she said,
"It's fine. Just Paul and Sam know."
>> That's what she wrote. Just Paul and Sam. Because we
both we >> She leaked it to you in a panic because she
didn't know what you knew cuz you were alluding to that nobody
else was. >> No, I knew about the love letter and that
I knew that you two >> There was no love letter.
Well, it sounds like what she told
Sam and what she told uh
I now I know exactly why I can explain everything about this
stream now. Oh, did I move the kicker keep thing? I did, didn't
I? I think I just sent it to someone else. Now this all makes
sense. So, what Kimmy told Sam and Ice Poseidon was about the
love letter. So, right here, Sam is like mocking Gunnar and going,
"Ah, now I know who you are. I can't say anything on stream.
And Gunnar's like, "Yeah, that's who I am." Being like, "Yeah,
I [__] that guy's girlfriend." They're both totally
missing each other, right?
But Sam knows, is is this this seems like what's going on here,
right? Is Sam thinks, "Oh, Gunnar's like this pathetic loser
who is in love with her, right? I think I think that's what Sam
thinks." And Gunar's sitting there like, "Yeah, that bitch."
And so they both think that they're they both think they understand
each other here. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I get it. I get it. off. Kyle Kyle Kisky out of nowhere.
>> Obviously that is and that's what you're so upset about.
You've been upset about >> Obviously that is >> because
I get it. I get >> so you can show a love letter. >> Okay.
I get first of all I get why you don't want this to come out
because it looks it looks it makes you Yes. Cuz that's what you
want for Lav. You want Lav or whatever name is to believe that
that you to >> Didn't he just do a whole stream before
this on Lav? Dy or whatever her name is.
>> guys with like bigger streams who have streamed for
a long time. It's just like a natural thing. I don't know that
person. I don't know anything about this. It's just a natural
thing they do all the time. >> You only
you only wanted to use her as a whole. But in in fact, you actually
were in love with her and now you're with a new
bring up my current wife. Now you're >> I was still married
when they were [__] He would talk to her about me.
>> Now you're with a new e Now you're with a new e girl.
You don't want the You don't want the You don't want the new
>> What is this? What is this? What is this? Space Ghost.
Thank for the gifted soul. Appreciate it.
Um
Sam is just like writing his own story, right? We see this a
lot. Okay, this is just creative writing. He's just writing a
little story for himself in his head. He's just trying to make
it real, right? Speak it into the ether and let it become real.
Uh, unfortunately, there's just too much hard evidence on the
other side of this to
I or produce a letter or just produce this letter, right? You
have to you have to produce >> eal to know you were in
love with an egirl before.
>> First of all, that's not his first egirl. If you think
I'm under the impression that Tim was not a before me. No, but
but no, but the difference with the other ones were they were
he was just girls. He was he was actually in love with Kim and
that's why this one really hurts.
>> Okay, I can't hate him totally cuz like he totally knows
he's full of as he's like making this up. He's just spinning
a story that's like going to make you guys upset. I can't hate
him completely, okay? He's just he's just stirring as much as
he possibly can right now. He knows it. >> Stopped mid
her the last time to say he was bored and they never again. >> Okay,
that's of course that's what he's going to tell you, you
>> know. I tell every girl, oh, you know, oh yeah, no.
Yeah, nothing's like that's what guys do. >> If that's
true, by the way, Gunnar's a psychopath and he did that just
to make that girl obsessed with him. I can't think of something
more like weirder than that to [__] with a girl.
So, that's probably why she got the nose job, dude. Good one.
That's probably why she got the second laboplasty. Okay, good
one. That you just destroyed this person if that's true. I hope
it's not. That's sick. >> You ain't going to tell the girl
you're with that like they've had better before or whatever.
>> You're the best. You're the best. You're the actual
down before. I've never >> I've never had better. I've
never had better before.
>> Did they just invent the wheel in Thailand or like where
you guys at right >> Oh, you're clearly a welltraveled
guy. How many countries have you been to,
>> How many countries are you banned from? You scumbag.
You can't even come to
>> Wait, is he actually banned from America over the crypto?
>> I didn't know that. >> You can't even come to
America. You >> Yeah, I overstain my visa.
>> Yeah, so do like 20 million Mexicans and they don't
give. >> No, but when you leave, I'm not going to sneak
in through the border to get into America. I don't care enough.
>> Cuz you're a [__] Yeah, >> but I know
what you're >> Wait, would he not be at all of these Ice
Boseidon events if he could
>> doing? You're diverting from the fact that you don't
want your girlfriend to find out that you are probably still
currently in love. You are still currently in love with >> unlike
Timmy for like
>> just so you guys all know the sub the subtext going
on here. Okay. Sam's like pretty consistently walking a line
between ice besidon off and
and being friends with him. And this is his penance for whatever
up he's done earlier in this stream or last month or whatever
where he like over Ice Boseidon. This is his way of trying to
get back in his good graces, right? He's consistently in this
cycle. So he's going to do this. He's going to try to make up
He's going to try to do whatever he can to make Ice look less
bad in this >> Saw your face when she started going through
yours and Kimmy's DMs. You looked so nervous for her to see them.
>> What are you talking about? She >> your face on
stream when you're going through them. You were like twitching.
Yeah, because because my wife was alting for two hours straight
on this woman and I felt genuine pity that this woman had put
herself in such a terrible position and was getting exposed this
way. Yeah. Genuinely pitiful. >> Mhm. Yeah. Okay. >> For
her whole life going >> the same way is pitiful that you're
so hurt by Kimmy. I can't believe you are still currently to
this moment still so hurt by Kimmy. Dude, are you you don't you
not like genuinely?
>> No, I'm I can just feel it. And I can feel that your
your gal is insecure about Kimmy, too. That's what's crazy.
>> Okay, hold on. Uh I hope Lav I hope Lav walked away.
That one might be possible. Okay, that one might be I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
That one
is probably possible. the fact your girl is this insecure about
Kimmy that she had to >> I don't know if it's like insecurity
so much as like um like feral instinct to just kill this person.
I think I don't think Lav had to like I don't think Lav had to
be reassured. I think she was just like I'm going to kill you.
>> You you're you were with this guy before. You're dead.
You're dead. You're dead. Number one, not her business to bring
up, by the way, Gwen. Yours, yours and Kim, right? Yours and
Kim. This girl is so insecure about your relationship with Kimmy.
She thought I have to burn this once and for all. I will take
the liberty to bring this up on stream so that I can take down
this whole thing so there's no chance of Gwen and Kimmy getting
back together again. Wait, >> it's so I would say a sign
of insecurity is to keep mispronouncing somebody's name intentionally.
There's nothing where I see insecurity more than when you it
doesn't Hey, your girlfriend this other guy is not a measured
response. That's like literally going at the most personal thing
you can immediately. That's not a measured response in any case
whether he knew or not if it's not public knowledge. Oh, I my
other headphones didn't die. Just these ones are charged now.
And these are my nice ones. I like these ones way better. So,
I switched
anyway. Yeah,
>> if she didn't know, he didn't know. >> Ammo going
to throw an opinion. >> Like there are all these um >> things
dramas beneath the surface. No matter if it's Twitch or kick
or wherever, even in a regular 9 to5 workplace, there's these
dramas, right? And you know, if you if you you know, kind of
elbow someone, they tend to elbow you back and and you know,
it's a proportionate response typically. >> Yes. But when
when you elbow lab, when you elbow lab,
she literally claws your eyes out. Okay. like you you like bump
lab in the hallway and she claws your eyes out. All right,
that's the difference. It's not proximate. >> Um and I
guess in this case, uh due to the head, >> they thought
they were giving a proportionate response. >> Two headphone
swaps. I had these ones on originally. I realized they weren't
charged, so I switched my AirPods and now I switch back to them
cuz they are >> on that ended up being really really contagious.
Something like that, you
>> Um Oh man, I've never had I've literally never had my
go this fast. We cannot see anything. What do you mean you cannot
see anything? What does this mean? We cannot see anything. >> I
mean, >> Like a lot of you guys are uh ICE guys. Um I actually
don't disagree that she wanted to humiliate him, but I don't
think she actually Well, unless you are saying it's one and the
same. Humili humiliating him is hurting him because like what
we're talking about in terms >> Well, when I say these
ones, I mean the headphones I'm wearing. >> He didn't know.
That's like a dagger to the chest, right? Um whereas I think
she thought it was just like a very public venue, you know, very
public venue. um being being the way that you know it gets back
at him, you know, whatever, >> Gosh, it's awkward. >> Yeah,
them faces. >> It's because like I just hung out with Kimmy
and so then it's like weird to be like on a Discord call and
then they're like, "Yeah, [__] that caught." And
you're just like, I have nothing to say. >> Oh, she did
just hang out with Kimmy, too. That's That's why it's important
context from before. Kimmy was just hanging out with Amv. And
now they're on a call and Lab's just like this stupid Kimmy.
Yeah,
>> it's like I have nothing against either of them, but
>> I pride myself on being friendly with people and and
and kind of like knowing them for who they are, and that leads
me to having a lot of friends that don't mutually get along.
And so far, it's been fine. Hopefully, it can continue to be
that way because I kind of see where uh everyone is coming from.
Uh to be >> dude, I I kind of want to watch this Dickers
debate. I will watch it, okay? But it sucks right now. >> All
right, welcome to the show, y'all. Welcome. Welcome. Shut up,
Kyle. Shut up, Kyle. Shut up, Kyle. Shut the up, Kyle. Shut up.
Shut the [__] up. Sorry. Um, okay. I've got so much
content that for this for all of the kick stuff, all the kick
drama. I've got so much content. I might have to do like the
whole day on that. Guys,
we're about to cover the Ice Boseidon logs. Okay, I went through
and painstakingly clipped out every single log from Ice Boseidon
so I could read them for you on stream. Okay. Is there a reason
for the avatar? I don't know. I was feeling funky today. Feeling
funky. Feeling funky. So, I went and clicked all of these, but
if you like the content, I want you to follow me on every platform,
okay? Follow me on
with an underscore. Twitch.tv/jdk
with an underscore. I'll throw the Twitch channel in the kick
chat, guys. If your primers are up, go to the Twitch channel.
Send me a primer. Okay. Twitch primes always appreciated.
There it is. There it is. There it is.
Follow on every platform. Join the Discord. Discord.gg/jstl.
GG/JSDK.
And if you want to take your support one step further, you can
always give me money. I really appreciate money. Makes the stream
go longer. Gives us more time to get through all of the content.
All right, we have fantastic comment com fantastic content coming.
There's the Zena getting arrested stuff, which also extends into
today where I believe she asks Shui to bail her out. Okay, I
it's fantastic content all night. So, we need 8 hours. We need
you guys to donate, donate, donate. There's a couple ways you
can donate. Okay, you can give subs on kick. You can sub individually
on kick. I love individual subs on kick because if you sub individually,
that's a rolling monthly charge. It's a rolling monthly investment
in the stream. Okay, I can depend on that money. I really appreciate
it. All right, you can give subs on kick. You can donate through
TTS. There's the kickbot that's pinned in the in the kick chat
right now. Kickbot TTS AITTS $2 minimum. There's Streamlabs as
well. Streamlabs TTS exclamation point donate in the chat will
give you those links. The Streamlabs is a $3 minimum. Okay. And
last but not least, if you want to give some money, I really
appreciate every dollar from every chat, every chatter,
there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
All right, multiple tiers.
Hop over there, shoot me a couple bucks. I really appreciate
any money you give. Okay, love you guys. You guys are awesome.
Okay, go sign up for the free Patreon if nothing else so that
you're ready. All right, Amar needs to subscribe on Patreon.
That would be cool. I would love that. All right, I would love
that. Okay, thank you guys so much. I love you. We are nine subs
away from another hour on the stream. All right, I will be shilling
again in exactly one hour. But let's continue on with the content.
Ice Poseidon Discord rage from this morning. All right, so we
had that live call last night. Ice showed up this morning and
he starts going off. I wasn't aware. I wasn't aware of the relationship
Kim had with Goon and it's pretty upsetting and I can't look
at her the same anymore. It's pure disgust and how she lied for
so long. But I ceased all communication with any girl I ever
had a thing with. Goon is a coward for not telling me. Manto
man and Lav is mentally ill is a mentally ill weird ass dog [__]
Goon and Lav are cowards for how they decided to tell me this
is all in Kimmy and not Goon or Lav. Wake up. Uh but you already
knew about the relationship. No, I didn't know the extent of
it. I don't know what that means. I don't know. I mean, I don't
trust Kim or Sam. Why do you care? You were broken up. Hold on.
Why do you care? You were broken up. Did you zero zero people
while broken up? It's not about her other people during our time
on break. It's about her lying to me about it. She forced me
to stop talking to any girl I've ever had a thing with, but she
continued to text Goon sometimes without giving me full context.
It's a little bit of a double standard in the relationship. He's
not a fan. He's not a huge fan. He didn't know she got gaped.
He did not know that she got gaped. It's true. These where there's
a couple you got to read bottom to top. So I would have never
dated her again if she told me. Yeah, she's out and I'm never
going to talk. So wait, so he he just said that the problem was
her not was her lying, right? And her continue to talk. And then
he says, but I would never have dated her again if she told me.
>> Uh-huh. Yeah, she's out and I'm never going to talk
to her again. I I can't see anything but pure disgust for wasting
my time. And hearing the details as well. Mattress on the floor.
I would never marry some streets. That's disgusting. Oh, it's
Ice Poseidon who calls her a streets. It's not anybody else.
It is Ice that calls her a streets. It hurts cuz he's hurt. I
hurt when he hurts. And yeah, she forced Maddie out of every
stream possible. Lol. That was true. Oh, cool. He's leaking all
that stuff, too. Interesting. Okay. I remember Cutebot IG stories
of all those roommates going out clubbing and Goon was there
while y'all were dating. Probably cheated. Well, Cupidot is the
one who got a nose job and convinced Kim to get one uh to get
her one. So that okay.
Can't be can't be a Kim an ice beside crash out without a comment
on Kimmy's nose job. Pretty sure Maddie doesn't like me. No,
I've been uh Has Bro been sliding in DMs all night? No, I've
been asking myself why I trusted her for so long after everything
she's ever shown me. What did she message Goon when I was in
Japan? Oh, yeah. I knew she messaged about her ugly nose to him
because I thought they were just friends.
Was the laboplasty real? Yes, she had a laboplasty. She actually
got it done twice which severely affected her ability to stay
wet. You sure it wasn't just that she goon and then my brother,
my brother, my brother, my brother.
Uh,
I had the surgery and I can't just get wet for you anymore. Meanwhile,
she's like [__] And she's like, I just listen. You
just don't measure up, okay? You just don't measure up.
Once you go once you go BWC, there is no other Wii. I don't know.
I I can't finish it. I'm not good at rhyming. Okay,
I'm going to stop talking about Kim and I don't want people to
talk about her. Just let her die off. She has 10K in her bank
living in LA. Let her die off and become a to guys who won't
give her who won't give a [__] about her to get her
rent paid. I paid it. She will never go live again.
Let's be real. She is shameless as [__] Wouldn't
surprise me if she tried to go live in a month. Now, if people
bring her nose job up, nose her nose up, she will never go live.
Nose reactions.
Goon's is the reason she needed the second leia blasty.
>> Goonar got that Coke can ice got a pee pe. Okay. All
right.
Why, dude? There's a lot of there's a lot of watching energy
in this chat right now. I need you guys to all chill. Okay. Chill,
chill, chill, chill, chill, chill. All right. Yeah, I'm not going
to attack him or leak anything. Just forget her. Have you messaged
her after you went offline? Yeah, she said she forgot to tell
me about it, so I just said never talk to me again. Oops, forgot.
Forgot to say something.
So, you're going to [__] with Gunnar today or let
him stay uh get away with that. Um, no. If Goon wins, I just
won't pay him, so he should just quit. That is the most made.
Disqualify him or let him play, but do an action. Don't be passive.
Don't do that. Well, he should just quit cuz I won't even pay
him. She's leaked stuff before about how Ice has a flap over
his ass. Damn. Is that a tail? Are you describing a tail? What
is a tail if not a flap over the ass? I feel like you're describing
Ice has a tail. Okay. Anyway,
you already basically paid him to him if you think about it,
boy. So, if he wins, you you're even if you don't pay. No, I
win. I lose the lying girl and I'm a millionaire. While Goon
and Lab have to money and Kim has to learn to deal with having
no money.
Oh boy.
Oh
That's rough, guys. That's rough. That's rough. That's rough.
That's rough. That's rough. How much was her rent? Just trying
to figure out how long before she broke. Is her lifestyle expensive?
It's 2,400 or something.
That's not actually That's actually not bad. It's a studio apartment
with no AC because SJC basically SJC's apartment. Let's be real.
She's just going to fight another rich guy. Too old plus too
much maintenance plus lazy aka doesn't clean or cook or do laundry.
I have no clothes 7 days into this event and my house is a mess
when she's been there every day. Please tell me you took back
all the you bought her. No, I don't care about that. It's like
10k. I could care less. You couldn't care less, you mean? She
was completely useless as a woman. Didn't do anything. Just leech
my money to buy stuff and rent. Okay. Is it your house, though?
My wife doesn't do any laundry, and if we weren't married, she
wouldn't feel obligated to clean my house. >> I asked her
to as a favor. Okay.
>> Hilotonics, thank you for the gifted sub, too. Lav of
all people. Very interesting. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Chill ice. Do you cook or clean or do laundry either,
lol? Yes, I do. My house is clean and everything is organized
when I'm alone. When she comes, the house becomes a mess within
days. I promise you nothing would hurt Kim more than you airing
out. Don't say and just ostracize her from your life. Yes, that's
what I'm doing. I just need everyone to stop mentioning her.
Okay, that's not a good thing. Ice thinks Eddie is going to ban
Goon at his behest. Nah, I can't ask that. But totally excluding
him from everything in the future is just as bad. Genuinely,
how do you care? Because he and Lav are cowards.
Off Sam. Honestly, I think Goon
knew not to bring this up. Think Goon not to bring this up. Sorry.
I think Goon knew not to bring this up, but he's a beta to his
wife, and when she started saying, he had no choice but to go
with her or get his ass. I mean, his life he let his wife talk
for hours. So, he's at fault, too. Okay. All right. How did this
leak? This right here, how did what leak? How did the goar his
girlfriend? Lav literally just yelled it at him. Literally yelled
it at Ice Beside while I beside was talking to them. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't think Lav or sorry, Sam and Ice both have like some weird
red pill looking like weird weird red pill way of looking at
things. I wear the pants. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you
don't. Go just lets you think that. Not true. I think it's funny
that when I said I don't want to date anymore, I didn't get a
response or anything. Lol. She knew it was over. That's crazy.
She isn't even fighting for you. Please don't take her back no
matter what. Okay, this guy's a rider. Jesus Christ. She's not
even fighting for you. Oh my god. My god. Yeah. The only response
I got before she stopped was trying to blame me for not believing
her. Lol.
Does anyone know if RFID number 42 is removed?
Yes. Oh,
okay. That's uh I don't know why I took a screenshot of this
last one. I was not reading them, I guess, as I was taking screenshots.
Let me check real quick to see I want to check really fast and
see if he put more in here cuz somebody told me he put more in.
So, I'm going to go check real quick from Ice_Pidon69.
Oh, he did put more in. He just said He just said he's not going
live and he's tired. That's it. I'm not going live. I'm tired.
That's it. That's it. That's all. That's it. That's all. That's
it. Wait, what is this? Quick quick Kimmy clip. What is this?
What is this? What is this? Oh, don't mute. >> I'm on stream
right now. Can u me and Alan take your Dora of your closet off
for you? Can I put you on speaker? Okay, you're on stream. Um,
me and Alan are making a box fort for you. We're making you a
little fort for your bed. And I wanted to know if we
>> No, like your floor like pile of blankets that you call
a bed.
She know she's fully She's on board. She's on board. >> Putting
like boxes over it or making you a little hut. It's going to
be really uh very cool and manly. and we wanted to know if we
could take your closet door off. I can take it off just by removing
the hinge. That way you don't have to keep opening your door
and like moving >> Bro, is this before the nose job?
That's wild. If she got a There's literally nothing wrong with
her nose. People are so [__] I hate this idea. This
is Bro, you guys you guys destroyed this guy's life. Are you
guys satisfied? this up >> bed to get into your closet
>> and all I have to leave this man alone. >> I just
take the >> I just take the like the what they call >> Okay.
Sorry. I'm like I bounce around between my Discord and I's Discord.
It's like half of Ice's Discord right now is just people taunting
him with like Kimmy clips and [__] Sorry. We got
another one. We got another one. We got another one. Let's go.
>> There's a good line by the Grateful Dead. Once in a
while you get shown the light in the strangest of places if you
look at it right. So you need to go >> sounds like a like
a bedtime story. >> No, it it's a song. It pretty much
is. But
that line sticks with me. I'll never find anything that I'm looking
directly for. It's like in the fridge. I open the fridge, I'm
like, where the is the ketchup? All I can think about is ketchup,
ketchup, ketchup. I can't find it anywhere. But if I'm not looking
for
>> Wow. So true. I think this is just getting posted. So
Ice has to look at Kimmy and Gunnar together. I think that's
the only reason people are posting these things. I feel like
they're just like, "Oh, it's a clip of Kimmy and Gunnar in the
same place. Upload it. Get it on the cord. Get it there now.
He needs to see this." She doing a mustache right now or
mustache. Okay. All right. Oh, yeah. I don't know if Hold on.
I'll send this to Lav just in case you guys want to show this
on your stream at some point. Me send this to Lav here. This
is the first time it gets referenced on this episode is Sam goes,
"Oh, I know who you are." Oh, I put so many things together that
I can't talk about on stream. Yeah.
All right. Okay. We're We're on to the Sam the Sam stream now.
The Sam interview. Let's take a look. Let's take a look. I don't
have the whole Sam stream. I don't have time stamps for it, but
there is Sam does go off on
on lab specifically. We might go back and find some more timestamps
from Sam's stream as well if there's if there's more choice
time stamps. Okay. But for now, I've just got this one of him
going after Lav. All >> Show you this, which is already
a message that's being posted. I don't know why we've seen this.
What's this? What's this show, Gwen? >> We read all of
these already. Here, give me a sec. I need to get caffeine.
>> Yeah, we've seen this. What do you Do you understand
the relevance of this? Like why why Gwen thinks this is a big
deal?
I called him. He didn't answer because Kimmy leaked. >> Bro,
I'm getting absolutely horrendous
sent to me on my the person who just DM' me on Discord with an
image. Please consider removing yourself from the gene pool.
Holy, I need to go get caffeine. Give me a second. I'm triggered
as now. >> It to you in a panic
and you didn't tell Ice. What? No, she says right here. It's
fine. Just Paul and Sam know. Hello.
>> Hey. Still think there's a love letter? >> Of
course I think there's a love letter.
>> Yeah, Kimmy made that up to spin the story so Paul wouldn't
know and get
>> I think it was just part of the whole thing. Like it
was part of the fact that
>> hold on. Hold on. I thought this was I didn't realize
this was a call-in. Nobody told me this was a call-in. I thought
it was just Sam talking [__] I didn't realize this
was them going back and forth. Oh my god.
Oh my god.
>> Then you have Down syndrome. >> You lived with
You lived with Kimmy. Okay. And you fell under her spell. >> Content
gods have blessed us. >> No, she was my portable holster.
Like what are you talking about?
>> You fell under her spell. >> I would call her
in the room and borrow friction from her and kick her out so
I could gamble and play World of Warcraft.
>> You you you fell for her. Okay. >> Absolutely.
Horrendous panic.
>> Horrendous way to speak about a woman there. Okay.
Hor disgusting.
>> Borrowing friction. I'm never going to use that at any
point in the future. Okay. Borrowing friction. That is gross.
I'm not writing that down. >> You don't own No, >> she
panicked and leaked it to you and you never told that. >> She
didn't leak it to me. It It was an argument that
it was an argument that >> on September 12th, 2023. Yeah,
I just showed you the screenshot. >> It's in the screenshot.
She said, "It's fine. Just Paul and Sam know."
>> That's what she wrote. Just Paul and Sam because we
both we were all >> She leaked it to you in a panic because
she didn't know what you knew cuz you were alluding to that nobody
else was. >> No, I knew about the love letter and that
I knew that you two >> There was no love letter. You Well,
it sounds like what she told
Sam and what she told uh
I now I know exactly why I can explain everything about this
stream now. Oh, did I move the kicker keep thing? I did, didn't
I? I think I just sent it to someone else. Now this all makes
sense. So, what Kimmy told Sam and Ice Poseidon was about the
love letter. So, right here, Sam is like mocking Gunnar and going,
"Ah, now I know who you are. I can't say anything on stream.
And Gunnar's like, "Yeah, that's who I am." Being like, "Yeah,
I [__] that guy's girlfriend." They're both totally
missing each other, right?
But Sam knows, is this this seems like what's going on here,
right? Is Sam thinks, "Oh, Gunnar's like this pathetic loser
who is in love with her, right? I think I think that's what Sam
thinks." And Gonar's sitting there like, "Yeah, I that bitch."
And so they both think that they're they both think they understand
each other here. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I get it. I get it. off Kyle Kyle Kiski out of >> Obviously
that is and that's what you're so upset about. You've been upset
about >> Obviously that is >> because I know I get
it. I get it. >> So you can show a love letter. >> Okay.
I get first of all I get why you don't want this to come out
because it looks it looks it makes you Yes. Cuz that's what you
want for Lav. You want Lav or whatever name is to believe that
that you to >> Didn't he just do a whole stream before
this on Lav? Denny or whatever her name
>> guys with like bigger streams who have streamed for
a long time. It's just like a natural thing. I don't know that
person. I don't know anything about this. It's just like a natural
thing they do. Although >> you only
you only wanted to use her as a whole but in in fact you actually
were in love with her and now you're with a new
bring up my current wife. Now you're >> I was still married
when they were [__] He would talk to her about me.
>> Now you're with a new E. Now you're with a new E girl.
You don't want the You don't want the You don't want the new
>> What is this? What is this? What is this? Space Ghost.
Thank for the gifted soul. Appreciate it.
Um
Sam is just like writing his own story, right? We see this a
lot. Okay, this is just creative writing. He's just writing a
little story for himself in his head. He's just trying to make
it real, right? Speak it into the ether and let it become real.
Uh, unfortunately, there's just too much hard evidence on the
other side of this to
I or produce a letter or just produce this letter, right? You
have to you have to produce >> eal to know you were in
love with an egal before.
>> First of all, that's not his first egirl. If you think
I'm under the impression that Tim was not a before me, >> no.
But no, but the difference with the other ones were they were
he was just girls who was he was actually in love with Kim and
that's why this one really
>> Okay, I can't hate him totally cuz like he totally knows
he's full of [__] as he's like making this up. He's
just spinning a story that's like going to make you guys upset.
I can't hate him completely. Okay, he's just he's just stirring
as much as he possibly can right now. said he stopped mid her
the last time to say he was bored and they
of course that's what he's going to tell
>> you know I tell every girl oh I you know oh yeah no
yeah
nothing's like that's what guys do >> if that's true by
the way Gunnar's a psychopath and he did that just to make that
girl obsessed with him I can't think of something more like weirder
than that to [__] with a girl so that's probably
why she got the nose job dude good one that's probably why she
got Second laboplasty. Okay, good one. That you just destroyed
this person if that's true. I hope it's not. That's sick. >> You
ain't going to tell the girl you're with that like they've had
better before or whatever. >> You're the best. You're the
best. >> You're the actual down. I've never >> I've
never had better. I've never had better before.
>> Did they just invent the wheel in Thailand or like where
you guys at right >> Oh, you're clearly a welltraveled
guy. How many countries have you been to, Gwen? How many countries
are you banned from? You scumbag. You can't even come to America.
>> Wait, is he actually banned from America over the crypto?
>> I didn't know that. >> You can't even come to
America. You >> Yeah, I overstain my visa.
>> Yeah. So do like 20 million Mexicans and they don't
give. >> No, but when you leave, I'm not going to sneak
in through the border to get into America. I don't care enough.
>> Yeah, cuz you're a [__] Yeah, >> but
I know what you're >> Wait, would he not be at all of these
Ice Boseidon events if he could? >> Doing you're diverting
from the fact that you don't want your girlfriend to find out
that you are probably still currently in love. You are still
currently in love with
>> just so you guys all know the sub the subtext going
on here. Okay, Sam's like pretty consistently walking a line
between Ice Boseidon off and and being friends with him. And
this is his penance for whatever up he's done earlier in the
stream or last month or whatever where he like over Ice Boseidon.
This is his way of trying to get back in his good graces, right?
He's consistently in this cycle. So, he's going to do this. He's
going to try to make up He's going to try to do whatever he can
to make Ice look less bad in this >> Saw your face when
she started going through yours and Kimmy's DMs. You looked so
nervous for her to see them.
>> What are you talking about? She >> your face on
stream when you're going through them. You were like twitching.
>> Yeah, because because my wife was alting for 2 hours
straight on this woman and I felt genuine pity that this woman
had put herself in such a terrible position and was getting exposed
this way. Yeah. Genuinely pitiful. >> Mhm. Yeah. Okay.
for her whole life. >> The same way it's pitiful that you're
so hurt by Kimmy. I can't believe you are still currently to
this moment still so hurt by Kimmy. >> Dude, are you you
don't you like
>> No, I'm I can just feel it. And I can feel that your
your girl is insecure about Kimmy, too. That's what's crazy.
>> Okay, hold on. Uh I hope Lav I hope Lav walked away.
That one might be possible. Okay, that one might be PO. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
That one
is probably possible. >> The fact your girl is this insecure
about Kimmy that she had to >> I don't know if it's like
insecurity so much as like um like feral instinct to just kill
this person. I think I don't think Lav had to like I don't think
Lav had to be reassured. I think she was just like, I'm gonna
kill you. You You're You were with this guy before. I'm You're
dead. You're dead. You're >> Number one, not her business
to bring up, by the way, Gwen. Yours yours and Kim, right? Yours
and Kim. This girl is so insecure about your relationship with
Kimmy. She thought I have to burn this once and for all. I will
take the liberty to bring this up on stream so that I can take
down this whole thing so there's no chance of Gwen and Kimmy
getting back together again. >> It's so I would say a sign
of insecurity is to keep mispronouncing somebody's name intentionally.
>> There's nothing where I see insecurity more than when
you are just continuously mispronouncing somebody's name. I I
feel that way. It always feels weird to me. Sam, weren't you
always threatening to leak and try to take it down? >> No,
but I I held this. I'm the ultimate drama king. I've held this
in for so long. You know, I'd love to, but I
>> About the letter about the letter. >> Okay, you
little I am a 27.
>> If you guys didn't catch that, that's the YouTube censorship.
The did she just
dude, that was a long bleepout. What the >> 7-year-old
woman. I've had before. Tim >> really We know what happened.
We know. We know. We know. >> Yeah. What do you know? >> We
We know you've had We know. Okay. >> Yeah. Like Yeah. Do
you? >> You're a random only girl. We know you. We know
you've had before. Yes.
>> Thanks for the Thanks for the intro.
Um, yeah. I'm This is >> self-promoting her Only Fans.
Yeah, she does that. >> First of all, I went up to Kimmy
at DreamHack to say thank you for sending me a very sweet message
3 years ago. >> Oh, I bet you did. You're just such a You're
such a girl's girl. You're such a girl's girl. I bet you really
went up to her and you said to her, "Oh, Kimmy, thank you. We
can be friends." You're such a girl's gal. I Oh, continue. Tell
continue telling me. Please continue. I can't wait to hear the
rest. >> Literally on stream. >> Oh my god, you're
such a good person. Continue the story, laugh, you're such a
girl. Continue. Continue trying to justify how you leaked someone
else's private business so that you could try and stop your boyfriend
for going back to a girl that you're scared of him leaving you
from. Please let me hear
>> I'm ready.
Damn. What is there to go back to? She has three nose jobs. Double.
>> Oh, you don't have to. That's more of like the from
Goon right there where he plays it. I feel like you're playing
into the insecurity. You know, you know, Lav feels some kind
of way. You got to go. You just said 5 minutes before this, "Oh,
I don't want to hurt this girl. I feel bad for the way this came
out. It just [__] her over. I just feel pity." And
now you're like going to run her down like this. I don't think
she did anything wrong here. Did she? This is like you guys fighting.
I don't think she did something new that was wrong. She could
kind of maybe talk to laugh. Maybe
that's it. That's it. All you need to Oh man. Let me >> leaving
you from. Please let me hear >> I'm ready.
>> What is the to go back to? She has three nose jobs.
Double.
The [__] is
the going under the >> Of course you're going to say that.
>> What do you mean? I We got married. Like what do you
mean? Sam, how's it feel to >> this is you guys are I'm
just saying you guys are letting him play you a little bit. Okay,
he knows what he's doing right there. >> I actually have
something to stream rather than just watching YouTube video and
watching your >> This is what I do. This is what I do and
answer the phone and fall for it. So, you're the idiot.
>> Fast forward. Kimy's a to literally >> Sam Sam's
kind of winning right now. I want you guys to come back. I'm
on your side here. Okay, I'm totally on your side. All right.
If you watch any of the coverage from before, I'm on your side.
But Sam's Sam's kind of winning right now. I hate to say >> woman woman
in the space. Like everyone knows that Kimmy's a [__]
That's like very well known. You know that Kimmy's a [__]
Also, I know that he does. He does know that. And he's like probably
either after this or before this, he'll spend like an hour ranting
about what a Kimmy is. Okay. He's just like stonefaced now cuz
he knows that he doesn't want to give Lav any wins on this one.
So he's not going to say >> my husband a loser for like
a whole week straight and I'm sitting on information like that.
Yeah, buddy. You don't get to call my husband a loser when that
loser girlfriend like >> when I was sleeping on the floor
>> had like
streaming
streaming there streaming drama and like >> you guys stop
just every time the floor mattress is mentioned it's really up.
Okay, that's worse. Talk about her nose jobs. Don't mention the
four mattress again. All right. >> He knew. We thought
he knew. >> Did you not see the message to me where I literally
>> He told me that he knew everything. >> Doesn't
matter whether he knew or not. You and him would believe something.
>> You You sent the messages to Kimmy saying, "Kimmy, please
can you let me know what everyone knows because you know I don't
want the whole of CX coming after me. I'm trying to I'm trying
to have a baby right now and I'm very stressed. Yeah. So, you
know, you know, you know when No, I just did. I just did. It's
my turn now. You said your thing and now >> I'm talking
on how much this
you released it. >> I will forgive you as a malicious as
a malicious thing. The fact you're acting as if The fact that
you're acting as if you released it without with thinking there
was no repercussions is
>> Yeah,
Sam's winning again. This is Trust me, Lav. Come on. The idea
that you're like, "Well, we thought he knew so it wasn't a big
deal." No, there's a reason you went to this. There's a reason
you went to this and went nuclear and you know that this would
[__] with him. You know, his chat is going to tell
him that he got for the next 6 months. Okay, Poseidon. Poseidon.
Come Poseidon. Come Poseidon. Okay. Absolutely. That is what's
going to happen here. I don't mind that you guys did it. And
by the way,
neither Sam neither Sam nor Ice can actually fault either of
you because you guys did exactly what they would do in your position.
They that they've built their entire careers doing. So when Ice
goes moral, he moralized and he goes, "It's so disgusting. I've
seen what your character is. I've seen your moral character."
Yeah. Shut the [__] up, loser. This is literally
how you built an empire. Okay, shut the up. It's disgusting to
watch you try to like sit here and clutch your pearls, right?
You sound But Sam's right that I think Laugh, you were trying
to nuke him. You were trying to go hard. You were trying to farm
and you won. You totally crushed him, by the way. You embarrassed
him super badly.
But you can't now go back and go, "But also, I didn't think it
was that big a deal. I'm just a small bean."
No. No. No, he had 1,000 HP and you knew that it was going to
do 900 damage at minimum and you kind of thought it would do
and you might have done 1,000 when you just thought you but you
wanted to him up. Come on. You wanted to him up and you him up.
I don't know why we're pretending otherwise but that's how that's
how the game works. All he had to say was okay and uh yeah but
his response made it worse for him. Yes, he coped extremely hard.
He made himself look so much worse by coping. Yes. Yes, that's
true. >> Is [__] You did it maliciously.
>> I'm going to pull it back here.
>> The fact that you're acting as if you released it without
with thinking there was no repercussions is you did it
>> We thought that it would take him I thought that it
would take him down a couple pegs. I knew it would hurt him.
I didn't know that it would destroy him. I didn't know that I
would potentially be caught with charges.
He uh yeah, that is that is what happened. Okay. You you did
destroy him. >> No, you I'm reading the screenshots. You're
saying I'm scared this is going to come out and I don't want
to deal with the drama. >> No, I said >> these these
texts also make you look quite bad. I'll I'll just be real. >> I
said, "What narrative are you spinning?" I released all of it.
I said, "What are you reading it?" And she says to me, she says
she says to you, I've read the screenshot. She says to you, "Look,
if you don't want drama, just don't go after don't go after Sam
and Ice." That's what she said. I don't think she's threatening.
You know, I'm not Kimmy's fan. I'm not Kimmy's fan, but I don't
think she's threatening.
>> Let me walk you through something real
>> Kimmy Kimmy was lying to both sides. She was lying to
Ice Poseidon about me and she was lying to me and my wife about
what she had told Ice Poseidon. That is the story. What did she
lie to you? What did she lie to your wife about? She >> She
said she said that she had already told Paul the full truth.
>> she did not. >> I didn't see that screenshot.
>> Yeah, because you're stupid.
>> Well, it to me then, Gwen, so I can cover the story.
I never saw a message of her saying she told the full truth to
>> how would you get >> I don't know if she said
full truth, but she was like, Paul knows about it, right? Paul
and Sam know about it. I think she says that exactly. Oh, Lab's
Lab's going to come on. Okay, hold on. Apparently Lab's waiting
to join. Can we I'll pull you on right now, Lab, but can I just
finish? There's two minutes left in the call. I'll just finish
the call and then I can pull you on. >> Get some less bots
in your community that can go. >> I would pull you in.
I can pull you in now. Just Let's watch the end of it. Okay,
I'll pull you in now. Hey, how's it going?
>> Oh [__] Hold on. My headphones aren't coming
through. You're probably going through to stream, but not to
me. One
>> I'm good now. What's up? I have a tummy ache. What do
you mean what's up? Like you're you're actually >> Sorry,
I just this placeholder. Don't read into it. >> Yeah. Um
you're missing the context in those messages that she like and
what I said on the stream when I was posting them is that she
had sent me this >> freaked out on you. She went over >> psycho
this psycho three-page essay that was like, "You're the reason
Tim doesn't talk to me anymore.
I messaged him three months ago. Uh like I I told him everything.
I told Paul everything. He hate he hates Gunnar, but I vouched
for him. Like a whole skitso thing that was like proving her
loyalty to like Tim or whatever. And then that's why my message
was so stern. I was like, "Dude, this like point by point I was
like, "This is why he didn't message you back. This is this is
this." And then in those messages, I'm just like, "I'm not mad
at you. I ju I just like want to know what the truth is." basically
like Sam Pepper saying that you were telling people that like
and this is before I knew anything. This is before I like pulled
the room and other people to see what she was saying because
the reason why I learned of everything was like Sam Pepper saying
that there was a love letter. So of course I'm like oh like did
my husband write some other girl love letter? Asked him about
it. He was like what the are you talking about? I was like I
was like oh like if if this is like real I'm going to be like
super embarrassed, right? Like just normal human reaction.
Um, and like no, he was like, "No, there's no like there's no
way that this happened. This is like the first time that we went
into depth about like I knew that he had like had sex with Kimmy
in the past, but they like didn't even date. Like it wasn't like
so it wasn't like it wasn't one of the significant relationships
that you have to like tell your partner about. You know what
I mean? So then we're doing this deep dive as like Ice Poseidon
is
like telling like is like trying to kill her with all of her
business and it's like oh yeah like she did this and this and
this and I'm like holy like now we're going to be involved in
this and like now I don't know if and he was at work too so I
was like I messaged her before like he even came home cuz I was
like oh like if Ice is going to release this and I look stupid
like I'm >> okay. What did he say that made you think he
was going to release it? Was it just that he was like going nuclear
on her? That he >> was talking about that. Sam was like,
"Talk about the love letters. Talk about the love letters." And
then Tim was like, "There are no love letters." And then I was
like, "Oh god, like holy, there might be love letters." Um, and
then I was like, "Oh, there's like a whole new situation I'm
like not aware of." Which is like that would have super sucked.
Um, so that was like the first part of that uh was me being like,
"Hey, like what did you tell Paul? What does Paul know? Is there
like is there something I don't know? But then Tim came home
and and >> was it it was on this stream, right, that you're
talking about? >> I believe this is on um be July 1st,
June 30th. >> It should have been on this stream,
>> Are you saying he was on a call with >> This is
the This is after went to that party and I skitsoed out. >> Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. >> Yeah. So So this should be the video,
but I don't see uh
I don't see the Hold on. Maybe this one will have it. >> No,
no, no. He entered he he entered chat. He entered Tim's chat
and was like, "Now's the perfect time to release the information.
Drop the love letters." Like something like that. And I was like,
"Oh, god." Like, "What the is going on?"
>> Oh, wait. Sam Pepper did that in Gunnar's chat?
>> Yes. Cuz he was streaming.
>> Yeah. So, I was scared. Then he came home and was like,
"No, that like never happened." And so then I started making
friends like in the streaming community and I started asking
questions and I was like what do you know? I was like cuz I didn't
like obviously when your when your uh husband's like no I've
never written another girl love letter. You're like okay I'm
going to ask more
>> Um and yeah I I was getting a different story from every
single person I was >> Sure. Sure. Let's uh let me read
this real quick >> real quick. Real quick. Sam in Goer's
chat. June 30th, 9:46 p.m. Pacific. It's around midnight Eastern.
You should expose the truth now. It's the perfect time. It's
the perfect time for you to drop the gossip. Do it, Goon. It's
the perfect time. Drop the gossip. Come on. Tell them it will
be content. It's time.
So, yes, he was definitely pushing Goonar cuz he was at the same
time when he calls Ice either to this day or the next day, he's
like convincing Ice to try to bar up with Kimmy, right? >> So,
he wants Gunnar to go and add another like another weight onto
Ice's back. try to push him to do that. >> Yeah. And and
Ice was already saying that she was like upset that she had emotionally
cheated with someone else. I was like, "Oh, like you're next."
And then now we're like now we're pulled into this with the narrative
completely out of your control because whatever Sam thinks is
true is going the first narrative out there is going to be the
narrative. That's like what you learn about being online. Everyone's
going to believe the first person that they hear. So I was like,
"Holy fuck." Like do you need to make a statement? Like what
the like what are we going to do? Um and then she was like, "No,
Paul knows." and and he's not going to say anything about it.
And then a couple of his friends were like, "No, like you know,
he would he wouldn't say anything about this. It l him." And
so I was like, "Yeah, that's probably true." Like
>> you just cut out Hold on. Hold on. You just cut out.
Sorry. Last like 3 >> Oh, and >> I can't imag.
But just go through whatever you were just saying again. >> Yes.
I then other people were like, "It looks worse for him." So like
he wouldn't ever say anything. And then Kimmy started to get
like more her words started shifting a little bit to like you
know Sam and Ice aren't really kind like me and don't really
care and they don't have anything to lose. So like my advice
is like to just not really poke the bear. And I was like okay
why would I poke the bear? Like I don't like what like I don't
it was just very like why would you poke the bear? >> Why
why are you acting like why did you tell her why would I poke
the bear? Cuz you constantly poke the bear and then
Because
at that point there was no At that point I had no I wouldn't
the only reason why I brought it up to Ice Boseidon is because
I felt like he was trying to him and then I was like oh like
you have like you're actually a you're trying to make my husband
look like a but like you're actually the
>> If it was if if Ice Poseidon was not that way there's
no reason for me to like leak that information. Like >> there's
no when you tell somebody you're not going to leak something,
you don't say I'm not going to leak this if uh unless Ice with
me. It's just I'm not going to leak this, right? You're like
you can trust me because because she said because she said that
he didn't know or because that he knew. I was like oh he's baiting
it. >> Like this is the this is the whole new thing is
like or not new thing but this is what the what we were thinking
this week while he was with Tim with like the chests and like
putting them right next to him. And I was like, "Oh, he knows
that they had they just fought where he tried to expose her and
he's like trying to like bait us or something. Like he's like
what she said is true. Like this is a guy who wrote her love
letters." You know what I mean? Like I So at this point I'm like,
"Oh, like the narrative is here and he's trying to like bait
something." And then he's like he's talking about how much money
he has and how like Tim's a loser and I'm like, "Yeah, what kind?"
Like a loser that [__] your girlfriend.
>> Uh-huh. I feel like >> I don't feel like any of
this calculation happened to be honest with you, which is fine.
>> I don't feel like this calculation happened, but I understand
that it like Sorry. What I think happened was he was Gunnar and
you don't think he's a good person and you think Gunnar is a
much better person and yeah, he had been [__] with
you guys and you were just pissed. Understand? I don't think
any of the other I've known that that he was trying to bait this
for 3 years. I' and I have not said anything. I don't like there
was no reason for me like there's this information was like never
like I've I've known this since I've kn and I were friends before
we were lovers and before we were together like I I have known
that he had sex with Kimmy >> for a very long time. I've
never like thought about leaking it. I had no reason to leak
it. So like >> sorry I'm just seeing a bunch of CX people
join up and they're like she's lying. They were talking [__]
about ISIS event every time you guys were talking [__]
at the event. Well, no. We were talking about his events, but
like the there was never a point where it was all the cards had
to fall. The the way that Kimmy was a huge [__] to
me cuz at some point I was like, "Yeah, there's no reason for
me to like leak this information. What happens between adults?
Like, you know, who cares?" Like, there are people still in like
Tim's chat who like bring up Destiny and it's like whatever.
Like, we're adults. You know what I mean? Like, there was no
reason to bring it up. And then when Kimmy was a huge to me at
Dream Hack, I was like, "Oh, like you're like, you suck." I It
was so crazy how much she sucked. And then she kept sucking.
And then Ice Poseidon kept sucking. And then I was like, "Oh,
he's like going he's exposing her for this. He's like toying
with Tim. He's like he's Tim." And then I was just like, "Yeah,
like I don't give a I I literally looked to him. And I was like,
"Do you ever want to do a CX event again?" He was like, "No."
And I was like, "Okay, I think it's time." So, I knew I was I
was
definitely
>> Yes. That I'm telling you, that's what went through
my head. I did not think that he did not know, though. Um I I
had like an inkling that maybe he didn't know the full story,
but him not knowing that even they had I did not know. >> I
I feel like I'm not sure that that wasn't said to be honest with
you. I she I well I I already posted screenshots of her telling
Tim that he knew and her telling me that he knew. So we were
under the impression that it at the very least that she had had
a narrative where he was obsessed with her and she finally gave
in and he wrote love letters and it was like a whole thing versus
what it what it actually was. like we we knew that there was
we had no idea that he did not know at all that they had >> Well,
I'm telling you that I feel like there's a decent chance he did
know, but he has to pretend he didn't know cuz obviously it'
be weird.
>> That's I I think that's in my head that's more what's
happening here is he probably did know. >> No, I don't
think he did know because of the way he acted on stream. >> Yeah.
Well, he said it was a lie. He kept saying that I was lying and
then >> it's a lie and then he broke up with her right
after. >> And then and then right after I showed screenshots,
he broke up with her. Yeah, I might not have seen the uh what
do you call it? The part where he called it a lie. I saw him
saying that like this isn't the whole thing >> and she
still tried to he already >> and he already leaked that
she was still lying. She he in that message she was like uh he
she the last thing she said was she was crying because I didn't
believe her.
Like she's still trying to lie about it.
>> Well, what wait what lie is she trying to tell now?
They they did not have >> Oh, yeah. That seems like a odd
lie to tell at this point. >> Yeah. Well, that's that's
what I'm saying is like I think she's I think she's genuinely
>> she I mean probably just coping. I don't >> No,
there's no way that you there's no way that you tell so many
people different. Like I think that she just got drunk with power
from being like Ice Poseidon's like girlfriend and just thought
that she could I don't know if she figured that nobody would
talk to each other. She probably didn't think that me and I mean
I don't know if she
of course I I have literally no idea what cuz also I'm like you
know that I'm with it was weird that she was so mean to me at
Dream Hack and then afterward she'd like been mean to me in his
like uh in his Discord server and I was just like why are you
do like I >> Wait, what did she say to you in the
>> She said Lav why are you here? Yeah, she she was like,
"Lav, why are you here?" when I was just like >> ISIS Discord.
>> Yes. Like a month ago.
>> Yes. It was like But it was after like something something
else had happened. I forgot what happened, but it was like a
It was a bunch of things to where I was just like, "What the
like why are you being mean? Why are you being so mean to me?"
It was like I I don't know if you heard the whole story from
Dream Hack, but I went up to her and I was like cuz she had sent
me a a very sweet message when when all the Destiny stuff happened
and was like, "Hang in there, Lav like
And uh and even when and even I don't know if this the weird
power play she even like talked to Tim about it and was like
make sure you send uh Lav a message like she's you know she's
going through a hard time right now or something like she was
sweet back in the day I guess when she thought that she like
held the cards or something. And so I went up to her because
I remembered that and I was like hi I wanted to like genuin like
actually introduce myself cuz she kept looking at us all night.
She didn't say hi to Tim. didn't say hi to anyone which was weird
and just like kept making eye contact and I was like okay I I
have to go say something maybe she thinks I'm mad because she
like >> she knows that they had sex or something. I didn't
want there to be like weird female and like dynamic. So I went
up to her to say thank you. >> Yeah. You don't think you
don't think you're asserting yourself there? You don't think
there's some weird dynamics there when you're like I have to
go up to this person used to [__] my boyfriend. I
think I mean there's definitely an dynam dynamic, but it's not
like it's like I'm gonna go make this like not weird because
we're all in the same space.
>> Uh, okay. >> And I and I was like and I like was
like I really appreciated what you said to me and I like I'm
I think I also apologize for Esho for making fun of her or something.
I was like I'm sorry that like there's been drama.
Like I I was like I'm sorry there's been drama. I I really And
I just want to say that this guy making fun of your terrible
nose job was weird and I called him out for it. >> No,
no, that was not that was not what I said. I obviously did not
say anything like that. I was like I No, it was not like that
whatsoever. It was like I'm sorry for Esho. Like I know that
that's super annoying. Nobody meant it. Like you know. And then
but before I even said that I that was when I was panic talking
because she was being so mean to me. So I go up to her. I'm like
thank you so much. She literally looks at me and is like, "Okay."
And
and I was like, I literally was stun locked. I did not know what
to do. First of all, she's six feet tall. I'm looking up at her.
I'm like already in like a weird position because she has my
boyfriend. So I'm like, "Oh, I'm like I What is H?" I I literally
like couldn't I was like, "What the is going on right now?" So
then I So then I panic talked and I was just like, "Oh, yeah.
I Yeah, and I'm sorry about Esrio." And then at the end of it,
she was just like, "Yeah, like I just thought we were f like
I thought I was friends with Esrio." And I was like, "Oh, well,
I'm sure that you still are. Like people make jokes or whatever.
I'm sure that there's no hard feelings." And then she was like,
"Okay, well," and then I I think I then like tried to softly
like touch her arm as like a it was great talking to you, like
a very like friendly like like what you do in church. Like it
was great talking to you. And then uh I went immediately back
to Tim and I was like that was so weird. That was so weird. And
then a week later, she had messaged me because I made a joke
that I was going to get like a BBL or something. And she was
like, "Don't get a plastic surgery." And I was like, but she
had said something that was like sort of iffy and weird that
was like power play. She keeps trying to she kept trying to power
play me. And it was very strange, but I kept just being nice
to her because I didn't want to look insecure or look weird.
And then yeah, the whole thing just flipped on its head when
I when everything went down. But there's no I mean there's no
what could I possibly say in a situation like this where
I it is public that my husband has a very tall pretty blonde
girl. Like I yes I yes I know that what Kimmy looks like. I am
married to my husband. We're very happy.
There's no I there's no way for me to navigate this in a way
that makes me look like
good.
>> But what I do know is that I'm ve they're very we're
very happy >> and I'm glad that I took I'm glad that I
took uh Ice down a a few pegs. I didn't mean to take down so
many pegs, but yeah, I think he >> can't be glad you took
him down multiple pegs. Okay. And then also be like, "But I didn't
expect to do that much." you. I think you just went with something
that was nuclear and I don't think you thought about how much
HP he had. Okay, just stop with that cope. >> No, I definitely
did. >> You're in a space where everybody acts that way.
Where everybody does that. Okay, just embrace it. >> Well,
think but yes, but but I also am in the position where people
do that to to Tim about Destiny and he's like I don't like I
don't care about this. We're adults.
>> So like I'm in public for a long time. That's pretty
different. >> I I guess I knew that I was doing something.
I like I knew that I was like leaking. Yes. But I I didn't think
that I was leaking to him. Does that make >> Yeah. But
where where's all of his anger coming from? Really? You know
he's an insecure guy. Like he's clearly insecure, right? He's
clearly June 30th [__] He's like, "She destroyed
my [__] self." Uh what is it? My my confidence. Like
you know he's insecure. So when you tell everybody publicly,
obviously that's what [__] with his insecurities.
That's what [__] with him, >> Our fault. >> No,
no, no. I I think he's really I think the worst part of this
for me >> because I'm smart enough to know that that's
what's going to happen. That's what I'm telling you. >> No,
no, no. And I and I say this to Tim all the time like I you say
this in a relationship like I want to hear it from you so that
I'm not surprised. The element of surprise is what hurts the
most. I think if you like >> it's like a 10,000 person.
>> It's a it's like a it's a it's a 100x like pain point
when you are learning it that way. I think that and me and Tim
have both said that we feel bad and we do about him like fully
not knowing like that actually does suck and I like I woke up
not feeling like great about that. I woke up feeling good about
taking him down a peg but like I I didn't think that that was
going to be the way that he found out. >> You don't I mean
you don't you literally don't have to believe me. There's like
I don't I don't care to convince you about >> Part of what
you're saying and I believe you might feel a little bit bad for
him in some ways. Okay. I do believe that, but I just don't believe
this thing where you're like, I didn't think it was going to
hurt him that badly. I don't believe that at all. That's the
one thing where I'm like, >> I No, no, no. I think I think
Ice Poseidon is a scumbag. Like I I The reason I said it was
not because of Kimmy. I I said it because I think that Ice Poseidon
is a scumbag. Like I wanted I was I I was seeing Red. I wanted
him to hurt. I I wanted him to get and feel below my husband
because he tried to make my husband feel below him. Yes, that
is what I wanted to do. Yes.
>> Yes. That was the intention. I did not realize that
>> I was giving him new that new of information. And and
coming from someone who that has happened to like where I'm learning
something for the first time through someone else, I know that
that does not feel good from an empathetic
>> Okay. Um yeah, >> and I sent him a message after
I sent him a message right after we found out that he had found
that he had just found out because he
publicly went from denying it to
then saying, "Yeah, I dumped her." like I I didn't I didn't know
basically. Um and then almost immediately sent him a a message
from Tim's phone that was like
I like I did want you to hurt and I do think you're a scumbag
and that you exploit people but I also like didn't for what it's
worth like I didn't know that you didn't know. So I know that
like you don't care. I just like you know like sorry basically.
>> Um and he said hope it was worth it and
>> I Yeah. I don't know. I Yeah, I think it it might change
a little bit that it wasn't public. I think just if I had to
bet, I bet you would still do the same
>> No, I in a hundred in a 100 situations, I would have
done the same thing.
>> Okay. All right. >> Well, actually, that's not
actually I don't necessarily think that that's true. If I would
have if I would have known that he didn't know, the situation
would have changed because part of the reason I thought he was
messing with Tim is because I thought that he knew and he was
trying to get like he was trying to ego Tim because he knew that
he had had sex with her.
>> So that that was like I don't know if if I thought that
he hadn't we would have just snickered about it offline. >> It
it felt like he was personally like trying to dog pile and get
like one over on me and try to like bait me with money and [__]
like that. Like he dropped chests on me during the scavenger
hunt and then would revoke them and [__] like that.
Just like scummy. >> And I said and I said that earlier
that's because you guys were like complaining about the event.
You don't think it was anything to do with that? >> No,
absolutely. That's part of it. But >> No, Gary was doing
that and he wasn't doing that with Gary either. Everyone was
complaining about that. >> Yeah, everybody was complaining
about the event. We were just the ones that took the charge with
it because it sucked so bad. Like he doesn't know how to run.
>> Okay. But yeah, and I you won't see me defend Ice Beside
in most cases. Okay. But he's like the only person who went to
kick and actually took like the insane amount of money they pay
to actually do something with it. Okay. Actually hold events,
actually do. >> No. And we've said that we even in the
call that we had literally Yes. or yesterday in the morning,
we were like, we listen, we know that this isn't like easy. We
appreciate the effort, but like and then it just dulged. Like
it just dulged. He was like then people were eating for more
money. He was giving people points for nothing. He was changing
the rules. And I was like, "Oh, you're just like back to being
a scumbag." Like, "You're back to like He saw that me and uh
Tim had fought." This is another thing. He thought he saw that
me and Tim had fought about his gambling addiction. So, he kept
dropping steak steak boxes around him. And I was like, "Oh, yeah.
You're like, you're like actually the scumbag. Like, why? If
you're trying to put a wrench in me and Tim's relationship because
you heard our drama, like why am I saving your drama?" It felt
like he was he was taunting us >> that. Yes, but that's
exactly what I'm getting at. >> He has no moral ground
to stand on when he goes, "I can't believe you guys would do
this. It's so disgust." Nothing. He's got no leg to stand on
whatsoever. Right. Cuz he is a piece of [__] and
he goes after people all the time. He would use this to [__]
with people. Absolutely. Right. If he knew this about somebody
else, if the situation was reversed, he would with the person.
So, all I'm saying is, yeah, he's got no reason to be actually
mad. He's got no reason to stay mad about this. He is a total
[__] If he can dish it out all the time and can't
take it. I >> don't think he's actually that mad at Tim.
I don't think he's actually that mad at Tim. I I think >> I
think he just saved his life. >> No, I I think he is really
like I think he's mad at himself. He's mad at Kimmy and he's
mad at me because I egoed him and I don't think he is like kind
of red pill. I don't think that >> he I mean he's with
a girl who like he tries to be he has an ego. >> Sam tells
him the red pill the red pill and he obviously doesn't do it
cuz he took Kimmy back the last time when he was like and Sam
was like
Yeah, he obviously has an Achilles heel. He obviously has an
Achilles heel where he's like sensitive about his masculinity
around women or whatever. So I I I know that he was mad at me
and he was mad at Kimmy or whatever, but I I don't I actually
don't think he's that mad at Tim. I like how could you be mad
at Tim? It was like a a girl throwing herself at him. I don't
I like I don't He said at one point like he should have come
to me as a man and told me where like what is he what was he
expecting to be like >> girls do? girls come to each other.
>> Hey girly. Hey girly. I had sex with your girlfriend.
Is it okay that I did
I have no idea.
That'd be so weird. >> I I think Ice would have actually
He's just coping. You would have actually blacklisted Goonhard
if he did that. Hey, just wanted to let you know I [__]
your girlfriend.
>> Yeah. And Tim was trying to be on his best behavior.
>> I absolutely behaved. >> You know, you were very
respectful. You were very respectful. You even asked Kimmy like,
"Does he know? Is it weird that I'm doing the rat race? Does
he know?" and she was like, "Yeah, he knows. It's not a big deal."
So, like the whole thing I I knew I'm part I mean obviously part
of me is like um glad that this happened uh because my husband
is an alpha Chad, but um I do like I actually I mean I do feel
bad. It sucks. >> Yeah, I wouldn't wish. >> Yeah,
if I was in his position I'd be upset. So
>> they just saved themselves millions of
>> That's true. Uh, well, they don't live together, right?
Is he going to have to Is there going to be anything where he
gets divorced here? Oh, sorry. You said you saved the millions
of divorce. I see. Cuz they were going to get married. My bad.
You cut it. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't even I mean, yeah.
I don't I don't know. I I don't know if there's common law marriage
for where they were, but she >> I don't think they live
together at all.
>> So, I don't even think common law would apply if you
don't live together. >> Well, she it it does because she's
completely financially dependent on him. So, common law would
apply. California is not a common law state. I don't think it
might be, but if you're completely financially dependent on someone,
that is common law. So, you don't even need to actually live
with them if they like pay your rent. >> Okay. Interesting.
>> But yeah, that's basically
that's basically uh the tea. I I disavow what Tim said about
calling her um aster. I think that that was yucking. >> He
didn't say that. You said that. He didn't say that. >> He
said he was borrowing friction from her. He said he was bored.
>> No, no, before that. No, before that, that's the first
thing that he said. What did you say? >> I said I used
her as my bolster. Yeah, >> I was bored.
>> Yeah, disavow. I think that's not a good way to talk
about women. I That's not That's not nice. Disavow. >> Yeah,
I'm very familiar with this. I do this all the time. I just keep
saying the thing and say it's disgusting. I'm dis That's gross.
I totally disavow that. Yeah, I know. I know. I know the game
we're playing right now. Yeah, I know the game we're playing.
I think listen a little shaming is kind of good. I made Tim wait
a year and a half to have sex with me. So um and he made he made
it through the litmus test
for a year and a half.
>> No, dude. You were trying to get me to fly out to you
or to to for me to fly you out because you were broke. And I
said and I said I am not meeting you until you have a job and
a bed frame and you are you have your [__] together.
>> I had neither. None of them. Oh my god. You at least
pulled the mattress into the room when I when I came. >> I'm
a romantic. >> That's true.
>> But um yeah, a little shaming and standards are good.
>> Can you guys say You keep saying like you have jobs
outside of this. Uh can you say like what you do? Do you guys
say that or is that totally private? >> Uh well Tim helps
run an own sub uh business. We don't really talk about what it
is except it's like blue collar and um >> I don't talk
about my job at all because
obviously you probably shouldn't. Yeah, >> subre is going
to get kicked off again after this. Yeah, it's um
>> less than ideal. >> Yeah, I don't I mean the subre
like I don't know what these people think that they uh I'm pretty
shameless. I don't like I don't I don't really show regrets with
my my I'm very aware of the things that I say. I don't I don't
know what these people when they were like, you know, at one
point they were spamming that I like my my dog. I was like, "Guys,
I started this rumor." Like, you're you're weaponizing a rumor
that I started for attention. Like, you're >> I mean, >> like
I did this, I orchestrated this. And it's not a rumor, by the
way. It's real. And >> the whole kissing the dog thing
that with your
>> What kind of dog is that? I can't even remember. That
was like people totally took that picture out of context. >> Yeah.
The dachshund. Yeah. >> No. Yes. Yes. But then but then
I Yes. But then I ran with it and and then I was like, "Oh, and
the video is on my Only Fans." And then for years I was like, "Oh,
yes, I am I am the dog." >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
And then I made thousands of dollars on it. >> Wait, this
isn't true, Pimosa. But also, she said she never hooked up with
Destiny. It's um that has been done to death. I don't even want
to talk about it on stream, but there's we've had like whole
streams on exactly what happened there. And it's not even in
dispute what happened like at all by >> He did He did say
today that I ripped him. Did you hear that? >> Yeah. Well,
he said it back a couple months ago, too. Like uh 18 months ago.
>> I like What are you doing, dude? But he didn't really
poke the bear. I I think after I released the him as like begging
to eat come out of my vagina, he sort of piped down a little
bit. He used to go really hard on me and uh ever since that and
the sandworm thing, he's um he's pretty quiet. >> I was
uh that was me knocking on wood right there. Just I don't know
why you invite that kind of thing, but Jesus. >> I mean
I Yeah, obviously I thought that was disgusting and that was
like I I
Yeah, he's like a wretch. I He should He should be chemically
castrated. >> Uh yeah, we're not huge fans here. I don't
know if you know that. >> I think I think I I came I came
out of that pretty unscathed for the most part. Like I Yeah,
I just I didn't let him. He's seething. I don't know. I like
from point A to B, I kept getting in trouble because I told everyone
he was gross. I remember our first drama when I called him a
cheese man and he like tried to fight with me and then the big
tech stuff like I I think it was pretty clear that the dynamic
was um what it was.
>> So, it is what it is. It is what it is. It is what it
is. You know, we all we're all adults here. We all have our fair
share of, you know, >> it's certainly not weird to relationship
>> Turns out people over 25 have usually at least one or
two other people at minimum. So >> yeah, I I Yeah, imagine
my shock when I found out the day before I leaked it to Ice Boseidon
that Tim had had uh before me. Imagine my shock. I was I was
>> Yeah, really sucked. I thought we saved ourselves for
this marriage. That uh that realization's got to be tough. So
really, you both found out something new today. Horrifying. >> Pretty
hard. Pretty hard. Divorce incoming.
Divorce incoming. But have you I mean have be honest.
If you were to
without know without knowing
like without knowing that me and Tim know each other, if you
had to build a perfect spouse or the person,
we're pretty close. Maybe you guys there there's a there's a
decent chance that like you guys blow up too. Sorry. You guys
get uh things get heated sometimes, I'm guessing. >> Oh,
no, no, no. We We fight We fight hard. We hard. We love hard,
but like I think I still I don't I still think like we're each
other counter in the >> Possibly. Yeah, I feel like probably
there's some there's some natural affinity there. I I would agree
with you, but again, it's like a long
>> Yeah. Like I feel like at some point you guys will be
like having a fight in your car and you'll be driving through
the mountains and whoever is driving is going to like 90° turn
off the side of the mountain. I think >> yeah, we've already
done that.
>> We've already done that. >> I'm just That's what
I'm telling you. It's like I I do believe you guys will be together
for the rest of your lives.
>> Yeah, it just could be >> all 900 days. Yeah.
All 900 days. >> that might be true. And that's a that's
you know, find what you love and let it kill you. Anyway, thanks
for having me >> That's beautiful. I'm going to have to
get that stitched on a pillow. Okay. Yeah. Thanks for coming
on. I'll talk to you guys later. >> See you. >> See
you. Bye. >> Oh, that was fun. I feel like I dealt with
the cope around like we weren't sure that was going to be like
hurt that badly. I feel like I dealt with that effectively. It's
like, dude, you you're around the people who like who just go
off like this, okay? You don't have to tell me that you didn't
mean to hurt them. You don't have to apologize. You're finally
around your natural counterparts who like nuke each other all
the time. You just don't don't feel shame about it. Just be like,
"This is Yeah, that's the game, bro. That's the game, bro. Let
me in the discord. You something. What the hell? What the
What the
I don't know why you're out of the Discord. Sorry, buddy. Bunny,
we find you. Jtock is the pillow one in the relationship, not
Cherry. I don't even know what that means. Okay. All right. We
have, guys. Yes. There's 36 minutes left on the stream. We have
six subs left for another hour. Okay. We need those six subs
big time. So, I need you to dig deep in your pockets, okay? And
donate, donate, donate. TTS
sub. Okay, we're six subs away from another hour on the stream.
Donate, donate, donate. Get the dollars in so we can go for longer.
Okay, 35 minutes left. Six subs away. I believe in you guys.
Okay, thank you very much. I'm not going to chill any more than
that. >> Details for your little React Lord
>> Lav, listen to me.
When I came into your stream and I saw >> Let's Let's back
it up for context here about 30 seconds. me and my wife about
what she had told I >> I just put a I put a clip of what
sounds like Sam talking to Zirka about Kim in 2023 in Discord
general. Okay. Put it in content suggestions or stream chat from
now on.
Gen chat sometime during gen chat or stream Gen chat can slow
down but I'll pull it up. Hey yo
Dvil, thank you for the gifted sub. >> Five subs away guys.
We are five subs
>> What is this? What is this? What is this?
Zirka and Crusaders.
No, it's fine. It's fine. And I never even leaked Kimmy's. >> Is
this actually Fuzzy or is this a fake? Is this just Moises wearing
the Fuzzy M? >> She sent me. >> It's just Moises.
Bro, I never even
used to be my angel and I was a nice guy. I blocked her on Discord,
but Moyes never seen the photos. Why are you acting like you've
seen them? >> I just don't like I don't
like this type like I Come on, man. Just >> I don't know
if you call her your angel. I don't know. Zurka said that about
a lot of girls. Okay.
>> My bad. My bad. >> I don't know, man. I don't
know, man. I don't know, man.
>> We got Greatest Go. Thank you for the gifted sub.
JTO is black. Why the would you say that?
>> Wait, no, hold on. I am. Yes, I am. That's why I can
say the N word. >> We appreciate you guys. CX in the chat,
boys.
Like, and bro, I need
>> Bye. Yo, I need
>> I still feel basically Spruce Willis. Thank for the
gifted sub. >> I still feel like Zurka would have leaked
this when he was fighting. Dude, also the jaw. The jaw. Zirka
is just like a caveman. The jaw right here is going crazy.
The the toilet teeth and the jaw. What What do we got going on
>> No, it's fine. It's fine. And I never even leaked Kimmy's
nudes she sent me.
>> Oh, I somehow missed that right off the bat. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. news she sent me. Okay. Yeah, it is 2023. Maybe maybe Zurka
just figured it was out out there, so it didn't matter, right?
Maybe that's all it is. All right, cool. Thanks for the clip.
Uh, let me see here. Content suggestions. Somebody threw a clip
in. We're still looking for that clip, right? I think we're still
Oh, people are also apparently we need to look at some clips
from today. Apparently, Destiny actually went and said that he
did send Willie Mack that entire narrative, which just makes
Willy Mack look so bad if that's true, right? I don't know. Is
Desi trying to kill this guy? I don't know what the he's doing.
I haven't kept up with any of that today. [__] Okay,
we're we're close to the end of this. Okay, we got to we got
to finish up we'll finish up this piece of content. Okay, all
the stuff around this and then we will go on to maybe some of
that stuff. Uh Destiny Willy Mack Destiny watched
Destiny watched like Queman's video today and reacted to it.
So, I might I might have to check that out. Poseidon. That is
the >> What did she lie to you? What did she lie to your
wife about? She didn't. >> She said she said that she had
already told Paul the full truth. >> She did not. >> I
didn't see that screenshot. >> Yeah, because you're stupid.
>> Well, send it to me then so I can cover
>> Uh, so I know this is happening, too. I do want to watch
this Moody Morgan. And that's why I need you guys to donate,
donate, donate. Okay? get more time on the stream so we can watch
the dickers food shops debate and Destiny's react to that. Okay,
I might switch over to that stuff cuz honestly although Willy
Mack is way more interesting the doxing that whole discourse
obviously far more invested in that. So I might switch over to
it after we finish here. >> Dory, I never saw a message
of her saying she told the full truth to him. >> Three
more subs.
>> How about you get how about you get some less bots in
your community that can go and find details for your little React
Lord stream. Lav, listen to me.
When I came into your stream and >> Hey, why why you guys
should talk the react lord stream? What the [__]
Hey yo, I'm catching here for no reason. I just had a perfectly
cordial conversation with these people. >> I saw lab sitting
there and I thought, you know what,
Gwen did Gwen did well for himself.
But now I completely understand how you managed to end up with
a girl like that. You are both the most just low life degenerate
peace.
>> I just don't listen. These insults could work from any
normal uh representative of the population. Okay? Any average
person could say these things and they would land.
Sam Pepper and Ice Poseidon cannot moralize over anything.
They are literally the most degenerate people on the planet Earth.
And that's why they're popular. That's why they're funny. Okay?
This can't come from This cannot come from you. This cannot land
from you ever. Ever.
Bullied. Bullied. I've never met two more bullied people in my
whole entire life. two absolute bullied growing up,
horrible, disgusting people. And when I watched you say that
about Ice on the stream, the look on your face, the
thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Two subs away, guys.
Two subs. We got it. We'll get there. >> About ice on the
stream. the look on >> I did not cover any of this yet,
Black Irish. But I will cover it possibly tomorrow, possibly
tonight. We started early tonight. We're not even close to the
ending time. Okay, I'll keep the hours right here. Okay, I'll
keep the hours cheaper to do more content tonight cuz I'm excited.
I'm feeling amped. It's a big stream tonight. All right, once
we finish this, we can move on to I think I'm going to do the
debate because I want to watch the debate before I
get anything else going. Okay, let's finish this. face, the smile,
it was disgusting.
And every single person in my chat, every person in my chat said
the same thing that you are a disgusting human. And it's so clear
on the way you talk, the way you look, and the words you say.
You are both disgusting people. You are
>> anonymous. Thank you for the five gifted.
That's $15 carrying over on to the next hour.
Boom. Boom. Boom. 4515 stream hours plus
We're going to keep doing it. We're going to keep going hard,
guys. We are now We've got the next hour rolling in. 1 hour 30.
We'll throw on there. Okay, I'll reset the subs and we're we're
good to go. >> You are both disgusting people. And I'm
so happy. I'm so happy that Please don't stop streaming. Please
don't stop streaming. both of you stream cuz I'm going to be
so happy to cover the drama as this move forwards. Thank you
you two. I'm I'm I'm excited. I'm happy. You scumbags. Bye-bye.
>> Wow. Oh, he's going to ah he's going to mic drop. You
could tell from the rant the way he started picking up. Okay.
That he was going to mic drop. Ain't this a or something? I don't
know. I've heard bad things. Okay. I've heard bad things about
Sam Pepper. I'm pretty sure he did the the crypto scam, too.
I'm pretty confident he did the crypto scam. I remember looking
into it. I think I think there's a decent chance he did some
actual scamming there. Sam speaks to Goon and Lav about Ice and
Kimmy from Clipto. Wait, is there Okay, we got this. But was
there anything else interesting from the Sam stream? Not that
I'm seeing neither of these channels right now. There's Clipto
and Clips Clips on Clouse. Okay, both of these channels do a
lot of this stuff. These are both disgusting. Uh, we've watched
all of this. We got all of it. I think we got it all locked down.
The only other thing I was going to go over was the Cobb Rubs
from last uh from last month, two months ago, but I don't I don't
think I'm going to do it actually. We will get to the Zena stuff
I might take a quick pause here and just switch over to that
either that debate or Yeah, we'll see. Oh, I need something to
throw up real quick. Just a real quick blast. All here, we'll
listen to this for two seconds. This is them fighting. Oh, wait,
wait, wait. No, no, no. I'll watch the beginning of their stream
from today. >> Let's throw up the beginning of their stream
from today before we move on. We don't have to watch the whole
thing. We'll just watch the very beginning where they talk about
this. >> What have I done?
>> Just a little bit. >> I just had a whole bunch
of caffeine. I got to take a bath really quick. I'll be right
back. >> What have we done? >> What have I done?
>> All right, guys. Let's focus up. We're on RFID number
43.
Um, I don't think we're going to be getting any hits today. Sorry
about the event. Uh, it's a little bit postponed for now.
I'm really I'm really only live to see how much my KP has been
removed. I think I'm at a dollar. I think I've got the vagabond
treatment. Should go well. Um
so I expect to make about $4.80
today.
Yeah. Minus 100. It's going to start withdrawing from my bank
account. Yeah. Listen guys, I know you all want me to talk about
it >> and we will. >> And we will, but
after this stream, I'm not going to talk about it >> until
next week. >> Yeah. Until the recap stream and then I'll
talk about it a little bit. I'll touch on it a little bit. But
I'm in a relationship with a beautiful woman who I married
and I don't need to dwell on the past.